THE JOINT SUNSET
REVIEW OVERSIGHT HEARING OF THE
SENATE BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND THE
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEES WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVE IN
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING.
REMOTELY PERHAPS I AM JOINED IN
THE SENATE CHAMBER BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW CHAIR. OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE AND
MEMBERS FROM BOTH COMMITTEES.
AS A REMINDER PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASKED THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THE TO USE THE RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM IF YOU WERE. EITHER
APPEARING REMOTELY OR OTHERWISE
EACH TIME YOU ARE RECOGNZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR. ASKING IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ON MUTE PLEASE SELECT
ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING. R. I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOU WERE DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED
TO SPEAK. PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU
CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN.
STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU
WILL BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEES. TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO THE SENATE
GALLERY TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS. WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY VIA THE TELEPHONE
AND REMOTELY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
POP PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE. IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE ONE SEVEN FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN ONE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. FOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR TODAY'S
HEARING PUBLIC COMMENT MAY BE
PROVIDED UPON THE CONCLUSION OF
THE PANELS PRESENTATIONS AND
FOLLOWING QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND PLEASE
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER.
THIS FRANKLY CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE ON MUTED. AND YOU
WILL BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEES. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE TELEPHONE.
IT IS IMPORTANT CERTAINLY THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU TODAY AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING-THIS HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY
AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE. OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HIRING
PROCESS. AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS. WHO WERE
ADJUSTING TO THIS NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS. AND TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO THAT ALL INTERESTING
PARTIES INTERESTED PARTIES MAY
BE HEARD. SUNSET REVIEW
HEARINGS LIKE TODAY'S ALLOW FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF REGULATORY
PROGRAMS AND TO DETERMINE
WHETHER CHANGES IN THE LAW. OR
IN THE BOARD OPERATIONS OR
FUNCTIONS ARE NECESSARY.
TODAY'S HEARING IS THE SECOND
IN A SERIES OF DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THE BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING. THROUGHOUT TODAY'S
DISCUSSION WE WILL HEAR FROM A
VARIETY OF INDIVIDUALS ON
CRITICAL LICENSING AND
EDUCATION ISSUES WHICH WILL BE
KEY TO INFORMING OUR CONTINUED
OVERSIGHT WORK FOR THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING. FOR A LIST
OF THE TOPICS TO BE COVERED
PLEASE REFER TO OUR HEARING
AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING. TO
ASSIST IN THE REVIEW AND
EVALUATION OF THE BOARD
COMMITTEE STAFF PREPARED A
BACKGROUND PAPER. A DETAILED
BACKGROUND PAPER WHICH
IDENTIFIES ISSUES AND MAKE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
BOARD'S OPERATION THIS PAPER
HAS BEEN POSTED ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. AND MADE
AVAILABLE TO INTERESTED PARTIES.
TODAY WE WILL HEAR ABOUT
VARIOUS PATHWAYS TO LICENSURE
IN CALIFORNIA AND NOW THOSE
COMPARED TO NATIONAL TRENDS WE
WILL TALK ABOUT OUR STATE'S
CURRENT WORKFORCE OF TRAINED
LICENSED AND AVAILABLE NURSES
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
DISCUSSION ABOUT NURSING
EDUCATION INCLUDING THE BOARD'S
ROLE THE AVAILABILITY OF
IMPORTANT CLINICAL PLACEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND WHAT BARRIERS MAY
EXIST TO ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA PATIENTS ARE WELL
SERVED. BY HIGH QUALITY NURSES.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES WILL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE
ANY OTHER ISSUES OR QUESTIONS
THAT THEY MAY HAVE. WE WILL
ALSO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HEAR FROM. CONSUMER GROUPS
PROFESSIONAL ORGANIZATIONS AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. AT THIS
POINT IN TIME I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE MY DISTINGUISHED
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYMEMBER EVAN
LOW CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE TO MAKE ANY OPENING
REMARKS THAT HE MAY DESIRE TO
MAKE SURE LOW. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHAIR ROTH JUST LOOK FOR
TO THE CONVERSATION AND ONCE
AGAIN REAFFIRM OUR APPRECIATION
TO THE BOARD AND STAFF- THIS IS
OFTENTIMES THE THANKLESS JOB
FOR THE PARTICULAR THE
VOLUNTEER OF BOARD MEMBERS BUT-
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
SERVICE. THANK YOU TO YOUR
LOCAL. BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH OUR
SPEAKERS TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE THOSE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO PARTICIPATE
TO CALL IN NOW PLEASE DIAL THIS
TOLL FREE NUMBER. 877-226-8152
AND WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE USE
THE ACCESS CODE. ONE ONE SEVEN
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN ONE. LET'S NOW
BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST PANEL
MISTER LAWRENCE TRUJILLO
PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING. AND LORETTA
MELBY EXECUTIVE OFFICER WILL
DISCUSS THE VARIOUS PATHWAYS TO
LICENSURE IN CALIFORNIA
AVAILABLE TO INDIVIDUALS.
INTERESTED IN THIS COMPLETELY
IMPORTANT AND VALUED PROFESSION
THE NURSING PROFESSION WELCOME
MR HEO IN MS MELVIN YOU HAVE
THE FOR. THANK YOU ROTH. GOOD
AFTERNOON I AM TO LOOK UP AND I
HAVE BEEN A REGISTERED NURSE
CALIFORNIA FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS. TO MAKE IT FOR THE
PANDEMIC I WAS EMPLOYED BY
INTERVIEW SOME TO THE BOARD OF
A NURSING AS A DIRECT PATIENT
CARE MEANT FOR. AS A LINE
HEALTH CARE WORKER I HAVE CARED
FOR PATIENTS WITH A SIMPLE
EXPOSURE TO COLD AT NIGHT.
USING MY EXPERIENCE I AM NOW
SERVING IN THE ROLE AS THE
PRESIDENT HE WHICH I WAS
ELECTED TO JUST START OUT. ON
MARCH SIXTEENTH. IT IS NOT-
TESTIFIED TODAY AT THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING. SECONDS
UNSAID OVERSIGHT HEARING. AS A
MEMBER OF THE PATHWAY TO
LICENSURE IN CALIFORNIA THE
LICENSING INFORMATION I AM
PROVIDING IS FAKE THE NEW IN
STATE AND OUT OF STATE
REGISTERED NURSE. CAN IN OR
NEAR THERE ARE SIX PATHWAYS TO
LICENSURE AS A REGISTERED NURSE.
THE FIRST PATHWAY TO LICENSURE
IS EXAMINATION. ALL UP FOR
LICENSURE EXAMINATION. MUST
PASSED THE AND COLLECTS. M.
AFTER HITTING AN EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM LEADING THAT
CALIFORNIA'S LICENSURE
REQUIREMENTS. THE END COLLECTS
R. N. IS A NATIONAL EXAMINATION.
ORGANIZED THROUGH THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF STATE BOARDS OF
NURSING ALSO NOT AND STATE SEN
AND IS USED TO TEST THE
COMPETENCY OF NURSING. GRADUATE
IN THE FIFTY UNITED STATES. THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA AND FOR US
TERRITORIES THE END CLASS WAS
DEVELOPED. BY NURSING
EXPERIENCE THROUGH THE M. C. S.
TN AND IS A CERTIFIED AIRBENDER
PETERSON YEARS. THE INFLUX ARE
AND I'M A NATION CAN ONLY BE
TAKEN AFTER THE NURSING STUDENT
COMPLETE INCREASE IN PROGRAM
APPROVED BY THE BOARD OF
NURSING FROM THE STATE OF
ORIGIN. THE BOARD OF NURSING
ISSUES AN AUTHORIZED ATION TO
TASK. ALSO KNOWN AS IN AT T.
AFTER MANUALLY REVIEWING
APPLICANTS TO ENSURE THAT ALL
REQUIREMENTS FOR LICENSURE HAS
BEEN MAPPED. PERFECT WAY TO
ENSURING CALIFORNIA IS BY FORCE
MEN. INDORSE MEANT ALSO AS
RECIPROCITY IS WHERE I JUST
HEARD THAT HOLD A CURRENT AND
ACTIVE LICENSE. WITH ANOTHER
STATE APPLIES FOR LICENSURE ALL
OF. TO QUALIFY FOR DOORS MEN
INTO CALIFORNIA APPLICANTS MUST
HAVE COMPLETED A NURSING
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM THAT MEETS
ALL OF CALIFORNIA SLICES THE
MAN'S. S. C. AND COLLECTS ARE
AND IS LICENSED THEIR STATE. US
TERRITORY OR CANADA.
ADDITIONALLY THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING E. VALUE
WHAT THEY SAY APPLICANTS LIKE.
DISCIPLINARY ACTION IMPOSED BY
OTHER BOARD OF NURSING FINAL
THE FINGERPRINT RESULTS.
RECEIVE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ARE
REVIEWED PRIOR TO. ANY
LICENSURE TO CARRY OUT THE
BOARD'S MISSION OF CONSUMER
ACTION. THROUGH THESE PATHWAYS.
THE APPLICANT CAN APPLY FOR.
SURE THE APPLICANT BY
EXAMINATION YEAH FIVE FOR AN
INTERIM GOVERNMENT. AND THE
SIGN DOORS MAN CAN UP FOR A
LICENSE. BOTH TYPES OF
TEMPORARY LICENSE HERE ARE IN
PLACE FOR UP TO SIX MONTHS.
WHILE THE OUTPUT WORKS CLEAR
ANY LICENSURE DEFICIENCIES.
EDITION A TEMPORARY LICENSE
APPLIED FOR BY DAY IN PERSON
REGISTERED NURSE CAN BE
EXTENDED FOR AN ADDITIONAL SIX
MONTHS. EQUALLY TWELVE MONTHS
OR ONE YEAR FOR BOTH TYPES OF
SHIP HALFWAY. EXAMINATION AN
ENDORSEMENT THE BOARD
REGISTERED NURSING ENCOURAGES
THE USE OF THE ONLINE AFTER. I
SAYS THERE. PLEASE THE
LICENSING PROCESS NINE POSTED
ON THE BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING SWEPSON. AT AND DOT CA
DOT GOV. THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING IS WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF OUR
FARES. THROUGH THE ENLIGHTEN
LICENSING PROJECTS AND ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF IMPLEMENTING
SEVERAL TECHNOLOGICAL
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE- IS
STREAMLINED AND IMPROVED
EFFICIENCY THEREBY REDUCING THE
FASTEST TIME TO OBTAIN A FAIR
IN CALIFORNIA. THANKS FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY. LORETTA L. B. THE BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSES. EXACT
OPPOSITE. SO ARE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
DR PAN. THANK YOU- APPRECIATE
THE PRESENTATION I DID HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS REGARDING-
PARTICULARLY AN AREA THAT I
KNOW OF REYES AND THE PREVIOUS
HEARINGS AROUND CONTINUING
EDUCATION THIS APPROPRIATE TIME
TO DO THAT CERTAINLY CENTER
FENCE YES THANK YOU- SHARE- SO
I WOULD MAKE NO TO ACTUALLY WE
HAVE BOTH ISSUE THIRTY TWO AN
ISSUE THIRTY THREE THIRTY TWOS
AUDITS C. E. PROVIDERS IN ISSUE
THIRTY THREE COMPLIANCE
DOCUMENTATION. BUT- SO I GUESS
MY FIRST QUESTION IN RELATED.
IT ALSO PROVIDESMAKE NOTE THAT
THE BOARD HAS INDICATED THAT
THEY'RE NOT DOING. AUDITS OF
CONTINUING EDUCATION BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TO NOT
FULLY STAFFED- WHAT'S THE
TIMELINE OR EXPECTATION OF THE
BOARD WILL FULLY STAFFED THIS
UNIT. WHICH OF COURSE WAS
BROUGHT UP AT HER PREVIOUS-
HEARING ON OVERSIGHT HEARING ON
THIS BOARD. THANK YOU SENATOR
AND FOR THAT QUESTION. I WOULD
NOT THAT ARE EXACT OFFICER
LORETTA MELBY ANSWER THAT
QUESTION OKAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN- TO ANSWER YOUR
JUST A BIT OF CLARIFICATION WE
ARE AUDITING THE CONTINUING
EDUCATION COURSES THAT OUR
LICENSEES ARE TAKING FOR THEIR
LICENSE RENEWAL. WHAT WE ARE
NOT DOING IS AUDITING THE
LICENSE THE CONTINUING
EDUCATION PROVIDERS- THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE DID PUT FORTH
IN JANUARY TWENTY NINETEEN IN
JANUARY TWENTY. THAT WE WILL BE
DOING THAT- AT THE PREVIOUS
SUNSET HEARING AND- IN OUR
PAPER WE SAID THAT WE'RE WE
NEED TO STAFF THAT IT HAS BEEN
VERY DIFFICULT TO STAFF THAT
UNIT THROUGH PANDEMIC- I WOULD
SAY THAT OUR GOAL TO FULLY
STAFF THAT UNIT WOULD BE WITHIN
THIS NEXT YEAR- THAT THERE ARE
SOME POSITIONS THAT ARE
DIFFICULT TO FILL WITHIN THAT
UNIT- ONE OF THEM BEING ANY C.
S. SUPERVISING NEC. SO WE ARE
LOOKING AT RESTRUCTURING THAT
TO CHANGE SOME OF THOSE
POSITIONS SO THAT THEY ARE
EASIER TO FILL OKAY THANK YOU
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT HOPEFULLY
NEXT YEAR. THE OTHER THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAVE IS I KNOW IF
IT'S PRESCRIBED BROUGHT IT UP
IN THE PAST THEY DO ASK THE
SOLVE ALMOST ALL HEALTH
PROFESSIONS BOARDS- SINCE YOU
DO HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY OF A
CONTINUING EDUCATION. DO YOU
HAVE A CONFLICT THE STATE OF
INTEREST STADARD FOR
CONTINUING EDUCATION TO ENSURE
THAT THE JUNIOR. EDUCATION
NURSES ARE TAKING. OUR OUR NOT
ISN'T SALES PITCHES FOR UP TO
TWO PRODUCTS OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS SO DO WE HAVE AS THE
BOARD ESTABLISHED A CONFLICT
INTERESTS STANDARD- FOR
CONTINUING EDUCATION. CURRENTLY
WE HAVE NOT HOWEVER WE ARE IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH DCA INDICES
LOOKING AT DOING THAT. AS A
HUMAN BOARD STATEWIDE- OKAY
OKAY WELL- I THINK I'VE BEEN
BRING THIS UP FOR A WHILE AND
I'VE BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE
FOR WHO'S TEN YEARS SO- HI.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN HAVE SOME
PROGRESS ON THAT- SO THAT'S
GONNA BE VERY IMPORTANT THE
OTHER ISSUE IS ON C. COMPLIANCE
DOCUMENTATION I ATE CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE MAY BE
SOME CHALLENGES TO HAVE
COMPLIANCE DOCUMENTS. UP
LOADED- DO DO- LICENSEES AT
LEAST HAVE TO CERTIFY THAT THEY-
GOT DID DAVE. FORM THE THIRTY
SAID- THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
DO- EVERY ETHNICITY EVERY TWO
YEARS- AND THEN- WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF THE- LICENSEES
WHO WHEN THEIR- DO YOU ACTUALLY
AUDIT TO CONFIRM THAT- THAT
THEY'VE ACTUALLY ACCOMPLISH
THAT SO IT CERTAINLY REALIZE
YOUR ANSWER SAYS ABOUT EVERY
LICENSING FOR IT THE UPLOADING
COMPLIANCE INFORMATION THAT
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO DO THAT BUT-
HE TALK ABOUT THE HOW WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF LICENSES DO YOU
ACTUALLY AUDIT. AND OF COURSE I
ASSUME THAT THEY SHOULDN'T
ASSUME THAT THEY HAPPILY
CERTIFIED TO THE FACT THAT THEY
LOOK AT LEAST TAKEN THEIR
THIRTY CREDITS OF CONTAINING
EDUCATION. YES I CAN ANSWER
THAT FOR YOU- OUR LICENSEES
FREE NEW REACH PROCESS- AND ON
THE BRIEFS DOCUMENTATION BE
NURSE DOES CERTIFY- THAT THEY
HAVE COMPLETED THE THIRTY
UNITS. ADDITIONALLY IN OUR
REGULATION THAT REQUIRED TO
KEEP PROOF OF THOSE FEES YOU
CERTIFICATES INCOMPLETIONS FOR
FOUR YEARS IN CASE WE DO AUDIT
WE CAN AUDIT TWO YEAR RENEWAL
CYCLE TO TWO YEAR RENEWAL
ABILITY. TO UPLOAD DIRECTLY
INTO GREECE THE COPIES OF THEIR
CD YEARS I'M A LICENSEE WHEN I
RENEWED IN MARCH OF THIS LAST
YEAR WHEN I GOT TO MY SEAT YOU
SECTION I ENTERED MY PROVIDER
NUMBER. NAME OF THE COURSE THEY
TOOK HOW MANY C. UNITS WERE IN
THERE AND I UPLOADED MY
CERTIFICATE TO PROVIDE PROOF OF
DOCUMENTATION. AND THEN A
CERTIFIED BY CLICKING THE NEXT
SCREEN THAT I COMPLETED ALL
THIRTY- FROM MY SEAT WAS WOULD
BE A VERY EASY ONE FOR THEM TO
AUDIT AS ALL THE DOCUMENTS. ARE
INCREASED SO WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT I AM WORKING
WITH I. T. TO MAKE THAT A HARD
STOP. I AM ASKED- WATER SPECIES
FOR MAKING IT HARD STOPS SO
THAT OUR LICENSEES THAT HAVE TO
UPLOAD THAT DOCUMENT- SO WE
WOULD HAVE THAT GROUP PRIOR TO
THEM MOVING ON OKAY ANYWAY- SO
WE'RE WORKING ON THAT SCENARIO
IS WORKING ON IT BUT IN THE
PROCESS OF WORKING OUT WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF. LICENSES DEAL ON
IT AT THIS POINT IN TIME- TO
ENSURE THAT- THAT AT LEAST YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE A REASONABLE RATE
OF PEOPLE COMPLYING WITH THE C.
REQUIREMENTS. THE FIVE CENT OF
LICENSE FEES- YEAH WHAT WHAT
PERCENTAGE DO YOU AUDIT- I
BELIEVE ARE PERCENTAGE- ABOUT
EIGHT PER- I KEEP GETTING
ACTUAL DATA FOR YOU AFTER SUN'S.
AND THAT TO YOU- BUT THE ONE
ABOUT I DO WANT TO DO IS THAT
THIS IS AN HONEST PROFESSION
AND EACH ONE OF OUR NURSES DO
YOU ADD TEST THAT THEY DID DO
THAT SO WE DO A- A AUDIT. AS
WELL AS GETTING MAD AT A
STATION FROM THEM THAT AND THEY
HAVE COMPLETED PRIOR TO RENEWAL
THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO RENEW IF
THEY DO NOT SAY THAT THEY'VE
COMPLETED THE THIRD OKAY. I
APPRECIATE THAT WE'VE WE'VE
SEEN A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT-
RANGES IN WHICH- FINDING SOME
ARTISTS FROM DFFERENT HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS I THINK THEY'RE
ALL HONEST RIGHT. SOME. SOME
SOME BOARD TO FOUND DOES. LET'S
COMPLAINTS OTHERS- OTHERS ARE
FOUND HIGH COMPLIANCE- THE
OTHER QUESTION I ACTUALLY DO
HAVE IS THAT. I UNDERSTAND
THAT- WE ARE IN REQUIRES THIRTY
HOURS CONTINUE EDUCATION IT'S
MANDATED AND ANALYSIS THAT
YOU'RE PROHIBITED FROM
REQUIRING MORE IN THIRTY HOURS
A DIRECT PARTICIPATION BUT ALSO
MAKE NOTE THAT YOU OVERSEE FOR
EXAMPLE NURSE PRACTITIONERS.
AND SO- WITH NURSE
PRACTITIONERS- SEEKING TO HAVE-
MORE. INDEPENDENCE SHOULDN'T
THEY BE. HELD A RALLY SOME SOME
MORE SIMILAR STANDARD TO THAT
OF PHYSICIANS AND OTHER-
INDEPENDENT PRACTITIONERS IN
TERMS OF NUMBER OF CREDITS AND
THEY TAKE WHICH IS MORE ALONG
THE LINES OF FIFTY CREDITS
EVERY TWO YEARS. TO MAINTAIN
THEIR THEIR SKILLS. THE SPEAKER
THAT. I CAN. LOOK UP I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THAT- CURRENTLY WE
HAVE TO FOLLOW WHAT'S IN
STATUTE SURE. VERY REQUIREMENT
IS THIRTY- SO WE CAN ONLY HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE TO THAT IF
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT- THE
LEGISLATIVE STAFF WOULD LIKE TO
CHANGE WOULD BE THE BILL
INTRODUCED TO REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL- SEE YEARS. OKAY ALL
RIGHT I'LL JUST MAKE NOTE THAT
THERE IS A DIFFERENTIAL THERE-
THAT PERHAPS IT'S OUR JOB TO
ADDRESS- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED. THANK YOU SENATOR
PLAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAUL.
THANK YOU TERRA- I I'D MAYBE
THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT- THESE
ISSUES I GUESS AND THE MORE
EXPENSIVE FASHION BY SINCE I
HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY. I DID
WANT TO ASK ABOUT THE NURSING
SHORTAGE AND WHAT THE B. R.
INS- POSITION OR OR OR- OR-
PROPOSED SOLUTIONS ARE.
CERTAINLY FOR US IN THE CENTER
VALLEY IN REAL COMMUNITIES AND
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM-
INDEPENDENT MAKE AS CLEARLY
EXACERBATED- THIS ISSUE IN OUR
OUR NEED FOR MORE. NURSES AND-
WE KNOW WE HAVE WAITING LISTS-
FOR A NUMBER OF OUR NURSING
PROGRAMS- THERE'S A LACK OF
BRIDGE PROGRAMS SO FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE. YEAH ONE OF YOU
CAN JUST ANSWER A GIVE ME- YOUR-
YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON HOW MANY
STUDENTS WE NEED AND ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS TO MEET. THE
STATE'S FUTURE NEEDS FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS NURSE FACULTY
NURSES NOT THAT'S THAT
HEALTHCARE. NOT JUST POSITIVELY
HOSPITALS BUT ALSO FOR A
HOSPITALS AS WELL. THANK YOU-
SO BY PULLING THE LICENSING
DATA- I CAN SHARE WITH YOU THAT
WE ARE UP ABOUT 4% IN- LICENSE
FOR EXAMINATION. FROM LAST YEAR
TO THIS YEAR. AND WE'RE UP
ABOUT 8% TO GET ENDORSEMENTS
INTO CALIFORNIA FROM LAST YEAR
TO THIS YEAR SO WE ARE ACTIVELY
SEEING THAT- THAT THEY SHORTAGE
AREAS AND THE SHORTAGE IS BEING
ADDRESSED- WHAT ARE BOARD HAS
DONE IT WHICH- I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT AS WELL IS THAT IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. THEY APPROVE
SEVEN- ENROLLMENT INCREASES IN
TWENTY TWENTY DURING THE HEIGHT
OF THE BACKGAMMON THEY ALSO
APPROVED FOR ENROLLMENT
INCREASES. IN JUST THE FIRST
HALF OF THIS YEAR ANOTHER
COMING OUT THE OTHER SIDE OF
THAT THEY HAVE APPROVED SIX-
ENROLLMENT INCREASES IN JUST TO
BOARD. AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS
YEAR- THE OTHER THING THAT I
WANT TO POINT OUT IS THAT E
HAVE RECEIVED AND ACCEPTED FIVE
FEASIBILITY STUDIES- AGAIN. AND
WHAT A FEASIBILITY STUDY IS
ACCEPTING THAT THERE IS A NEED
IN AN AREA AND WE HAVE AN
INSTITUTION OF SEEKING APPROVAL
FOR THAT NURSING PROGRAM. WE
HAVE RESPECTED THAT AS WELL-
AND SO BE IT AND JUST OUR LAST
BOARD MEETING WE ACCEPTED A
SELF STUDY WHICH MEANS WE NOW
HAVE A BRAND NEW NURSING
PROGRAM- WHEN I STARTED AT THE
BOARD IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WE HAD
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO
PRE LICENSURE NURSING PROGRAMS-
IN IN FIVE SHORT YEARS. WE
HAVE- WE HAVE A HIGH BECAUSE
AND FIFTY NURSING PROGRAMS THAT.
RIGHT AND IN CALIFORNIA- THAT
IS A AN ARDUOUS. FOR BOTH THE
INSTITUTION AS WELL AS- ARE ANY
SEASON OR BOARD MEMBERS TO
REVIEW AND APPROVE. AND I'D
LIKE TO JUST. PROVIDE TO THAT
WE ARE DOING THAT AND WE ARE
SEEING IMPROVEMENT. THE BILL
MIGHT BE FOLLOWING UP YOU. CAN
YOU PROVIDE YOU YOU INDICATED
YOU WERE UP 4% AND TOTAL NURSES
I BELIEVE. 8% ENDORSEMENT-
THAT'S STATEWIDE SO DO YOU HAVE
YOU DO YOU HAVE THOSE NUMBERS
BROKEN DOWN BY REGION. I DID
NOT COME PREPARED FOR THEM TO
BE BROKEN DOWN BY REGION I
CAN'T GET THAT INFORMATION TO
YOU- WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO POINT
OUT THOUGH THAT WHEN THEY ARE
PRESENTED. TO THE NURSING-
BOARD THE BOARD MEMBERS DO
RECEIVE REGIONAL DATA TO SEE
WHETHER OR NOT THE WORKFORCE
SUPPORTS THAT AND WHETHER THE
CLINICAL PLACEMENT SUPPORT THAT
AND THE BOARD MEMBERS MAKE
THEIR DECISIONS BASED ON THE
DATA THAT YOU PRESENTED SO-
THERE WOULD BE A NEED IN THAT
AREA WHERE THE SCHOOLS WERE
APPROVED- AND THAT WOULD BE THE
PROCESS THAT WE WOULD FOLLOW.
THROUGH YEARS OF THAT I
UNDERSTAND THAT A MYERS MOVE
INFORMATION IHAVE IS THAT THE
BEER AND HAS SHARED DATA THAT
ANNUALLY THERE ARE AT LEAST
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND QUALIFIED
STUDENTS WERE UNABLE TO ENTER
INTO PROGRAMS. BECAUSE THE BEER
AND HAS CAPTAINED ROMANCE BUT
IN ALL IS ALSO CLAIMED THAT
THERE IS NO SHOULD BE NO
NURSING SHORTAGE IN MANY AREAS
IS THAT STILL THE POSITION TO
BE IRAN OR DO YOU ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE ARE SHORTAGES.
GANKING CRITIC AND CRITICAL
NEEDS IN AREAS OF THE STATE AND
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE-
EXPANDED PROGRAMS AND EXPENDED.
BRIDGE PROGRAMS AND EXPANDED A
ROMAN. THERE ARE CERTAIN. IN
AREAS THAT- THERE IS SHORTAGE
OF NURSES THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT IN DO YOU AGREE WITH
THAT AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVE SHARED. I DO WANT TO
PASS THAT IN- I BELIEVE OUR
FIRST AS SUNSET REPORT IT WAS
SURE TO EIGHT NOW HAVE. ON LINE.
SERVICES WE'RE AT THE DENTAL
STUDENT CAN ACCESS AN ONLINE
APPLICATION A SINGLE ONLINE
APPLICATION AND THEIR
APPLICATION IS SENT OUT TO
UPWARDS TO TWO HUNDRED NURSING
SCHOOLS- FOR THAT STUDENT TO
APPLY. SO I THINK WE NEED TO
CLEAN THE DATA TO FIND OUT
EXACTLY HOW MANY NURSING
STUDENTS ARE INDIVIDUAL- UNIQUE
REQUEST VERSUS MULTIPLE
REQUESTS GOING OUT TO THE
SCHOOLS- PRIOR TO THAT
TECHNOLOGY IT WAS EASY TO SAY
THIS PERSON WENT TO. THIS
SCHOOL AND THIS WAS IN- NOW WE
NEED TO LOOK AT IT FROM A MORE
TECHNOLOGY GOAL EIGHT WHERE- WE
MIGHT BE TRACKING BY VARIOUS
IDENTIFIERS SO THAT WE CAN
PROVE THAT IT IS AN INDIVIDUAL
AND UNIQUE REQUEST VERSES ONE
STUDENT BLANKING OUT TWO
HUNDRED SCHOOLS. THE REQUESTED
GIRL NOW THAT THERE'S THE
TECHNOLOGY TO SPREAD OKAY WELL
I WOULD CERTAINLY APPRECIATE IF
YOU COULD SHARE THAT THE DATA
BY REGION I JUST RECENTLY HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH A AND L. V.
AND- IN BAKERSFIELD WHO
ACTUALLY IS A FACULTY MEMBER.
AT THE LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
WHO HAS BEEN ON A WAIT LIST FOR
FIVE YEARS TO GET AN R. EIGHT
TO GET INTO THE BRIDGE PROGRAM.
TO BE AT OUR END. THAT'S TO. AN
ATROCIOUS EGG OF HOW BACKLOGGED.
AND HOW WE NEED TO FIX THE
SYSTEM THAT FACULTY MEMBER
TEACHING NURSING. CAN'T BECOME
AN R. N. IN THAT SHE'S BEEN A
WAITING LIST FOR FIVE YEARS FOR
THE ONE PROGRAM THAT EXIST IN
BAKERSFIELD- AND THAT'S A
BIGGER SO THE NINTH LARGEST
CITY IN CALIFORNIA. WE'RE NOT-
YOU KNOW WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT
NEEDS- THAT CLEARLY HAS BEEN
SHOWN BY THE PANDEMIC HI I KNOW
THAT WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT
RECIPROCITY IN THE FUTURE SO I
WILL I CAN HOLD MY QUESTIONS
BUT YOU CARE. OR I CAN ASK- THE
QUESTIONS THAT WITH WHATEVER
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE. YOUR
AVAILABLE. IF YOU WERE ABLE TO
REMAIN WITH US UNTIL THROUGH
THE NEXT PANEL THERE WOULD BE
MIGHT BE HELPFUL I WILL ASK.
OTHER MEMBERS IF THEY HAVE
QUESTIONS ON THIS PARTICULAR
PANEL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG IF
NOT I'M PREPARED TO LET YOU
PERSONAL MAYBE I MAYBE MY ONLY
QUESTION AND I AND I WILL SAY
FOR THE I TRY TO STAY FOR THE
NEXT PANEL BUT- WHAT I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IF THE BEER AND
HAS- ANSWER OF HOW THEY'RE
WORKING TO IMPROVE RECIPROCITY.
AND I WILL THEN DEPART THE NEXT
PANEL IF THE POPULAR AND COULD
ANSWER THAT. I CAN'T- THE
RECIPROCITY IS IN AND OUT OF
STATE- SO WHAT I WOULD TALK TO
IS OUR VERIFICATION PROCESS AND
THAT'S- OUT. OF STATE. AND OUR
ENDORSEMENT PROCESS WHICH IS IN
STATE- OR OUT OF STATE
VERIFICATION PROCESS- JUST IN
APRIL WE RELEASED IT. ONLINE IT
IS NOW AND- ONLINE PROCESS YOU
CAN REQUESTED THROUGH BREEZE.
AND YOU CAN PAY FOR IT THROUGH
INCREASED. THAT'S A HUGE
IMPROVEMENT AS PRIOR TO THAT IT
WAS THE U. S. P. S. PROCESS AND
YOU HAD TO SUBMIT A CHECK- SO.
THAT WE'VE SEEN IMPROVEMENTS
IN- WHEN I STEPPED INTO THIS
ROLE I WAS MADE AWARE OF THAT
WE HAD- LICENSE THAT WERE ON
MICROPHONE. THAT MICROPHONE IS
NOW BEEN DIGITALIZED AND WE CAN
SEARCH THAT DOCUMENT- AND WHEN
WE PUT THEM THERE ENTERED INTO
GREECE. O THAT'S A BIG- STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND THAT
HAPPENED LAST. FALL
ADDITIONALLY. ON IT B. AND THIS
IS. STRICTLY SPEAKING
VERIFICATION OUT OF STATE SO
THAT'S THE RECIPROCITY RIGHT IN
AND OUT- OUR LICENSE
VERIFICATION PAGE. DIRECTLY
SPEAKS TO BREEZE AND SIR WHAT
GREECE HAS. WHAT ARE PUBLIC HAS
IN IT. WE ADDED THE FOR. THAT-
THE APPLE. EITHER RECEIVED
APPLICATION BY EXAMINATION OR
APPLICATION. LICENSE BY-
ENDORSEMENTS THAT'S IMPERATIVE
BECAUSE THE OTHER BOARDS OF
NURSING REQUESTED INFORMATION-
I DO HAVE A MEETING WITH AND
C-SPAN- IN I BELIEVE NEXT WEEK
WHERE WE WILL DISCUSS THAT
PROCESS AND I THINK THAT OUR
VERIFICATION PROCESS GOING
FORWARD TO BE SEAMLESS- THIS
WEEK ABOUT THE MORE PRESSING
ISSUE. WHICH IS THE ENDORSEMENT
PROCESS AND THAT IS WHERE OUR
AND I'M IN FROM OUT OF STATE.
IN THE CALIFORNIA. I KNOW THAT
THAT NURSING LICENSURE COMPACT
WILL BE PRESENTED NEXT AND I
KNOW THAT THERE'S LEGISLATION-
GOING THROUGH THE OUR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS RIGHT NOW
THAT A DRESS IS THAT- WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU BECOME PART OF
A COMPACT. IS IT DOES ALLOW FOR
EASE OF LICENSEES TO COME IN
AND PRACTICE ON A TEMPORARY
BASIS IN CALIFORNIA- THAT WILL
GREATLY IMPROVE- THE TRAVELLING
NURSES. THAT TEMPORARY STAFF-
AND BORDER STAFF- SO IF YOU
LIVED IN SAY LAS VEGASNEVADA
AND YOU WANTED TO COME OVER AND
WORK IN CALIFORNIA THAT THAT
WOULD BEHOOVE YOU TO TRAVEL IN
AND OUT- WHAT THAT DOESN'T
ANSWER IS WHEN THE NURSE MOVES.
CALIFORNIA WHEN THEY MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA AND THEY TAKE UP
RESIDENCE HERE THEY HAVE TO
CHANGE THEIR PRIMARY STATE OF
RESIDENCE. WHEN I PRIMARY STATE
OF RESIDENCE IS CHANGE THAT'S
DONE THE RAM DOOR SAME PROCESS.
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO HERE IS FLOW
THROUGH EVALUATION OF THEIR AT.
TRANSCRIPTS TO ENSURE THAT THEY
MEET OUR EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS.
RECEIVE THEIR FINGERPRINT
RESPONSE BACK FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. WE ALSO
NEED TO CHECK THEIR LICENSE
VERIFICATION THROUGH NURSES
WHICH WE ARE A MEMBER OF WE ARE
A MEMBER OF NURSES AND WE DO
GET OUR LICENSE VERIFICATION
THROUGH THEM. AND THEN THEY WE-
MAKE SURE THAT OUR CURRENT AN
ACTIVE LICENSE AND ONCE THEY'VE
MET ALL THAT WE ENDORSE IN THE
CALIFORNIA. THE ONE THING THAT
WE ADDED DURING THIS PANDEMIC
WHICH I THINK IS THAT BENEFIT
IS- WHEN WE REVIEW THE
APPLICATION ONCE WE RECEIVE IT
A BIGGER PRICE BACK WHICH IS
TYPICALLY THE BIGGEST DELAY
BECAUSE THAT IS A LENGTHY
PROCESS TO ANOTHER AGENCY- IF
THEY'RE- HAVING ISSUES MEETING
OUR LICENSE REQUIREMENTS FOR
EDUCATION. AND THEN A TEMPORARY
LICENSE. TEMPORARY LICENSE IS
GOOD FOR SIX MONTHS- THEY CAN
USE THAT SIX MONTHS TO CLEAR UP
ANY EDUCATIONAL DEFICIENCIES.
AND THEN THEY HAVE THE ABILITY
TO EXTEND THAT ADDITIONAL SIX
MONTHS TO EQUAL ONE YEAR. IF
THEY HAVE. CLASSES THAT NEED TO
BE CLEARED UP SO THEY CAN BE
LICENSE THEY CAN PRACTICE IN
CALIFORNIA. UNDER THAT
TEMPORARY LICENSE AND WE DO
PROVIDE THAT TO THEM RIGHT NOW-
WAIVER- WE- WITHOUT THEM HAVING
TO DO AN ADDITIONAL APPLICATION
ARE PAYING ADDITIONAL FEES- THE
OTHER THING YOU. MENTIONED THE
PANDEMIC ISWE HAVE AN
AGREEMENT WITH THEM STOCK. THAT
ALLOWS. FOR I THINK WE HAD.
THOUSAND SIX THOUSAND I THINK
AT ONE POINT WHEN I LOOKED
LICENSE- ARE AND FROM OUT OF
STATE WHO CAME INTO AND STUFF.
A SEPARATE PROCESS FROM B. R.
AND- SB ARE ATTACHED TO A
FACILITY- THE FACILITY. TO M.
STEP PROVIDES THEM WITH THE
NEED. THEY HAVE A NURSES THAT
ARE ASSIGNED TO THEM TO FILL IN
DIFFERENT. ETHNIC WHEN THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY ENDS AND
THAT PANDEMIC IS OVER- THEN
DATA AGREEMENT IS TERMINATED
AND THOSE NURSES GO BACK TO
THEIR STATE A REGION TO
CONTINUE TO PRACTICE- AND THAT
FACILITY THAT IS CONTRACTED
WITH THEM ARE MADE AWARE THAT
THEY ARE NO LONGER. ABLE TO
PRACTICE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THREE OF SEVERAL WAYS- THROUGH
VARIOUS AGENCIES TO HELP IN
THAT PROCESS. THAT CONSERVE OUR
FOREIGN. THANKS VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU A NUMBER FOR. NEXT TO
THE CHAIR LOW FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA DR WEBER. AND
MEMBER DOLLY HELLO IF IT BECAME
VERY MUCH A TEAR OFF AND- FOR
THE THOSE ON THE ON THE CALL.
I'VE NOT SEEN A SUCH A GREAT
PARTICIPATION- FROM BOTH TO SET
THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS OF BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS- FOR A SECOND-
HEARING- IT JUST DEMONSTRATES
THE LEVEL OF ENGAGEMENT.
SPECIFICALLY TO IRON OUT SO
MANY OF THESE DIFFERENT ISSUES
IN IN THE PUBLIC REALM SO I
JUST WANT TO REAFFIRM THAT FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC OR NOT
AND THE CHECK IN THE CHAMBERS.
ALSO THINKING THAT CHAIR AND
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
FULL PARTICIPATION. I'M IN THIS
IS THAT TO MISS MEL B. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THIS IS WITH
RESPECT OF LICENSING. TIMELINES
I UNDERSTAND THAT AND WITH
RESPECT TO REGULATION YOU'RE
LICENSING TARGET TIMELINES FOR
RESPONDING TO AN APPLICATION.
IS NINETY DAYS OR APPROXIMATELY
THREE MONTHS I JUST FOR A NEW
NOTICE ALONE WHETHER AN
APPLICATION IS ACCEPTED FOR
FILING OR IS DEFICIENT. AT THAT
POINT WHETHER ACCEPTED OR
DEFICIENT IN AFRICAN WOULD
STILL HAVE TO WAIT BEYOND THE
NINETY DAYS. AND AS WE
UNDERSTAND- STAFF HAS- IS
ALLOWED TO TAKE CLOSE TO A YEAR
TO THREE HUNDRED AND NINETY
DAYS TO PROCESS AN APPLICATION
AFTER. THE NINETY DAY-
RESPONSE- AND WE ALSO SEE THAT
THERE ARE SOME INTERNAL TARGETS
BUT STILL THE RELIANCE ON THE
NINETY DAY. REGULATIONS SO THE
QUESTION IS WHY WOULD IT TAKE A
THREE MONTHS JUST TO GO OVER AN
APPLICATION TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT- IT IS- BUT NOT
A CONTAINS THE NECESSARY
DOCUMENTS BEFORE. A SUBSTANTIVE
REVIEW. THE PROVIDER LITTLE
CLEAR FOR ON THAT- BEEN NINETY
DAYS IS THE STATUTE- YOU CAN
SEE OUR PROCESSING TIMES OUR
WEBSITE WE NEED ABOUT SIXTY
DAYS THEY'RE STILL. DEFINITE
AREA OF IMPROVEMENTS ALL PUT
THAT OUT THERE TO BEGIN WITH WE
DO HAVE A GOAL- TO MAKE THAT A
LOT MORE- QUICK WITH THE
INITIAL THE INITIAL REVIEW IF
THEY ARE FOUND TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE WHICH MEANS THEY'VE
MET ALL OF OUR REGULATIONS
THEIR LICENSE IMMEDIATELY THERE
IS NO FURTHER DELAY IT SAID
INITIAL REVIEW AND THEIR
LICENSE. IT IS WHEN IT'S A
DEFICIENCY DISCOVERED THAT WE
NOTIFY THAT AND THERE WE NOTIFY
THEM THAT THERE IS A DIFFERENCE.
THAT WE'VE BEEN ALLOW FOR UP TO
A YEAR BECAUSE THE BALL IS BACK
INTO THE APPLICANT'S HANDS AT
THAT POINT WE CANNOT FORCE THE
APPLICATION TO SUBMIT
DOCUMENTS- AND RESPONSE. FAST
RATE SO WE HAVE TO GIVE THEM
TIME WE DON'T WANT THEM TO HAVE
THEIR LICENSE APPLICATION JUST
KIND. OF VOTE AND THEY HAVE THE
TIME TO RESPOND TO THAT SO
DURING THAT ONE YEAR TIME
PERIOD AFTER THEY'VE BEEN
NOTIFIED THAT THERE'S A
DEFICIENCY. THEY CAN GO AND
REQUEST FINGERPRINTS THEY CAN
GO IN CEMEX- I DO WAY TOO
PASSED FOR LIKE PHOTO. THEY CAN
SUBMIT TRANSCRIPTS SHOWING THAT
THEY'VE MAX B. EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS- AND THAT ALLOWS
FOR THEMTO DO THAT ONCE THEY
RECEIVE THAT DOCUMENT BACK WE
DO GO AHEAD. AND REVIEW THAT
AND PUSH THAT OUT. NOW IT
DOESN'T TAKE THREE MONTHS TO
REVIEW AN APPLICATION SO I WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT AS WELL IT
TAKES UNDER AN HOUR TO REVIEW
AN APPLICATION- WE HAVE A VERY
LARGE VOLUME OF LICENSEES
COMING IN. PRIMARILY THAT
VOLUME COMES FROM CALIFORNIA
ARE IN STATE SCHOOLS- WHEN
LOOKING AT THE DATA COMPARISON
FROM FROM OUT OF STATE TO IN
STATE WOULD PROBABLY ABOUT
TWELVE THOUSAND THAT WE
RECEIVE- FROM IN STATE ADDED
TIME COMPARED TO ESPOUSING THAT
WE RECEIVE FROM OUT OF STATE.
SO MY FOCUS IS LAST YEAR'S BEEN
WHAT CAN I DO TO INCREASE
STATE- SPEED UP PROCESSING
THOSE TWELVE THOUSAND IN STATE
APPLICATIONS. THAT'S DONE
THROUGH OUR ANY CAESAR NEC'S
APPROVED THE CURRICULUM THEY
WORK WITH THE PROGRAM DIRECTORS
AND BECAUSE OF THAT WITH YOU
CAN MOVE TO A LICENSE PROCESS
WHICH HAS BEEN. RECOMMENDED
THROUGH THE LIGHTING LICENSE
PROJECT THAT WE MENTIONED IN
OUR OPENING STATEMENT THIRTY
CA- TO NOT. RECEIVE A
TRANSCRIPT FROM THE SCHOOL. IN
A FACT JUST RHYS. A GRAD ROSTER
THAT IS CERTIFIED THAT SCHOOL
SAYING THAT THAT. STUDENT HAS.
WHEN THEY GRADUATED AND WHEN
THEIR LAST YEAR ATTENDANCE WAS
WHAT DEGREE THEY RECEIVED. ONCE
WE HAVE THAT PROCESS IN PLACE
THAT WILL BE AN AUTOMATED
PROCESS RIGHT NOW IT'S A MANUAL
PROCESS BUT TCA'S IT AND IT
CONSULTANT THAT WE HIRED ARE
WORKING ON AUTOMATING THAT
PROCESS. SO ONCE WE RECEIVE
THAT THE DEEDS IN THE DIRECTORS
WILL NO LONGER HAVE TO SUBMIT-
TRANSCRIPTS WHICH WILL BE A-
TIME SAVE FOR THEM ACOSTA SAFE
FOR THEM AND DECREASE SOME.
ARDUOUS ED AFFECTS THEIR- AND
ALLOW US TO. IMMEDIATELY GIVE
THOSE STUDENTS THAT ARE IN
STATE CALIFORNIA GRADS IN AT T.
BARRING ANY. ENFORCEMENT ISSUES
THAT IS STILL SOMETHING THAT WE
WOULD HAVE TO. TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION ON AN INDIVIDUAL
BASIS THE OTHER THING THAT
WOULD REQUIRE SOME ADDITIONAL
ARGUE IS IF THEY HAD
ACCOMMODATIONS- BUT I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO THAT CHANGE IDC'S
IDEAS ON IT AND I AM SURE WE
WILL HAVE SOMETHING VERY SOON.
THAT WILL ALLOW OUR IN STATE
NURSING GRADS AND THE STUDENTS
AT NURSING SCHOOL SORRY VIEW-
HAPPY AUTOMATED PROCESS FOR
THEM TO GO THROUGH A LICENSING
DEPARTMENTS AND. AND THAT WILL
SPEED THINGS UP GREATLY. WHAT
DID YOU JUST THE FOLLOW THOUGH
I ORDERS THAT- FOR HIM I THINK
THE DATE WITH. THIRD A B. R.
AND STAFF OUR CAN STAFF. THE
BOARD IS AWARE THAT THE TIME
WHEN THEY'RE OUT OF DATE IS
THAT. IS THAT ACCURATE DOES
THAT SOUND CORRECT. THERE IS A
TWO TIME PERIODS OF THIS LAST
YEAR- IT DURING THAT CRUX OF
KOBE AND GOING TO A TELEWORK
ENVIRONMENTS THAT WE EXCEEDED
THE NINETY DAY PROCESSING. THAT
IS CORRECT WE ARE NOT OUT OF
COMPLIANCE NOW. IF WE WERE
BROUGHT BACK INTO COMPLIANCE
WITHIN ABOUT A TWO WEEK TIME
PERIOD WE AUTHORIZED OVERTIME.
AND WE PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
EQUIPMENT AND OTHER AREAS
WITHIN THE BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING. OFFERED STAFF. NUMBER
AND HELP. AND SO WE WERE ALL
HANDS ON DECK AND WE GOT
UNDERNEATH HER STATUTORY WE'VE
MAINTAINED ABOUT A SIXTY DAY
PROCESSING. EVERY OTHER TIME
OTHER THAN THOSE TWO TIMES.
WORK FOR THE BOARD IS. BUT
KNOWLEDGE IS THAT THE LINES ARE
OUT OF DATE. YES THE TIME LINES
ARE OUT OF DATE AS A LICENSEE
MYSELF WE WERE TOLD GREATER
THAN- THREE MONTHS AFTER. I AM
WORKING HARD TO GET THAT
CHANGED AND THAT'S WHY I TALKED
ABOUT THAT PROCESS IS GOING IN
A PLACE. THAT WOULD BE WEEKS
THAT WOULD NOT BE EVEN A MONTH
ONCE THAT'S DONE AND TAKING
CARE OF SO- MY FINGERS ARE
CROSSED THAT WE CAN GET THIS
OUT TO YOU OUR DEANS AND
DIRECTORS- BY THE FALL. THE
GREAT AND MOVIE WE WANT TO BE
INVESTED IN YOUR SUCCESS TO
HELPING TO UPDATE THOSE TIME
LINES AS WELL TOO BUT CAN YOU
THE FINAL QUESTION I HAVE IS ON
THE PLAN OF ACTION THAT. DOES
THE BOARD HAVE A PLAN
SPECIFICALLY. TO UPDATE. ON
UPDATE UPDATE THE STATUTE OR A
STATE OR PROCESS PROCESS.
PROCESS IS ALREADY BEING
UPDATED- FORTY MEMBERS ARE
AWARE I JUST SPOKE TO YOU SEE
YOU AT AND C. C. AND I'M
SHARING IT OUT TO THE WORLD- SO
THAT THEY CAN MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE PREPARED FOR THIS
ISSUE WHEN IT COMES- BUT
PROCESS IS ALREADY THERE WE'RE
WORKING TO EXECUTE IT AS WE
SPEAK IT'S IN DC AS HANDS- AND
THERE ARE VERY VERY CONFIDENT.
IS TO BE DONE IN. FIGURE IS
PROBABLY. THANK YOU CHIRLA
THANK YOU CENTER TOMORROW I
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I'D LIKE
TO THANK- MORE PRESENTERS
OBVIOUSLY THEY REPRESENT THE
NURSING INDUSTRY IN A COURSE
ALL OF US WOULD LIKE TO THANK
EVERYONE- OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
ARE NURSES AND DOCTORS FOR THE
WORK THEY DID DURING THE
PANDEMIC BUT I'VE BEEN HEARING
THINGS THAT MAY BE FACTUAL
MAYBE NOT MAYBE PERCEPTION. BUT
HERE'S A SITUATION WE WATCHED
ON TV WHERE NURSES ARE JUST
SITTING ON THE FLOOR EXHAUSTED
WORKING TWELVE FOURTEEN SIXTEEN
HOURS A DAY WHATEVER IT WAS
OBVIOUSLY THAT SHOW THERE
WASN'T ENOUGH NURSES SHOW AS
YOU CAN HEAR OUR PANELING
COMMITTEE HERE ARE ASKING WHY
IS IT TAKING SO LONG SO I'M
PIGGY BACKING ON THAT. WHEN
SOMEONE GRADUATES FROM THE
SCHOOL AND- IS GOOD PROCESSING
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT I'VE BEEN
TOLD IT TAKES UP TO SIX MONTHS
AND THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE
GRADUATING THEY GRADUATE RATHER
THEY'RE WAITING TO GET
EMPLOYMENT AND HERE YOU GO SIX
MONTHS LATER THEN THEY FINALLY
GET AN OPPORTUNITY TO PRACTICE-
IN SO I HAVE TO EMPHASIZE THAT
YOU MUST FIND A WAY TO EXPEDITE
THIS- OBVIOUSLY YOU MENTIONED
THAT YOU'RE DOING A LITTLE BIT
BETTER JOB. BUT WE'VE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING IS IT JUST THAT
TERRIBLE PERCEPTION THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS THAT THERE ARE NOT
ENOUGH NURSES WE HAD BRING
NURSES FROM OUTSIDE THE STATE-
AND OF COURSE THE HOSPITALS HAD
TO PAY MORE MONEY- FOR THEIR
TRAVEL THEIR STAY AND
EVERYTHING ELSE WHEN WE HAVE A
AN ABUNDANCE OF NURSES IN
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE GRADUATED
THAT WE COULD'VE EXPEDITED AND
GOTTEN INTO THE SYSTEM. SO.
YOUR COMMENTS ON THAT PLEASE.
YEAH COUPLE THINGS THAT I CAN
ANSWER WITH THAT- WE ALREADY
SEES WORK WITH OUR NURSING
DEANS AND DIRECTORS WITH THE
GETTING EDUCATION OUT WHAT WE
SEE TYPICALLY HAPPENS IS THE
NURSING STUDENT IS. VERY VERY
EXCITED TO GRADUATE THEY GOING
TO BE PRETTY BREEZE ACCOUNTS
AND THEY APPLY. THAT CAN BE TWO
TO FOUR WEEKS IN ADVANCE OF
THEM GRADUATING. AND ONCE THEY
GRADUATE THE DEAN OR DIRECTOR
HAS TO ACTUALLY GRADUATE
STUDENTS OUT OF THEIR SYSTEM
THAT GOES TO THE REGISTRATION
PROCESS OF THE SCHOOL. AND THEY
PROCESS THAT THAT CAN TAKE UP
TO FOUR WEEKS FOR. US IS THAT
AND YET THEIR TRANSCRIPTS OUT
AND ISSUE THEM A DEGREE. THEN
WITH THAT THEY UPLOAD THOSE
TRANSCRIPTS TO THE CLOUD AND WE
ACCESS AND THERE AND THEN WE
START TO PROCESSING. WITH THE
STUDENT DOESN'T UNDERSTAND IS
THAT TWO TO FOUR WEEKS THAT
THEY'VE APPLIED PRIOR TO
GRADUATION WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING
WITH THEY HAVEN'T MET THE
REQUIREMENTS THEY HAVE A RIGHT
TO BE TO THE PROGRAM. THEN WITH
THE NURSING PROGRAM HAVING
AFTER ABOUT FOUR WEEKS TO GET
TRANSCRIPTS THAT'S AN EIGHT
WEEK DELAY THAT THE STUDENT IS
SEEN PRIOR TO US EVEN RECEIVING
AND PROCESSING YOUR
APPLICATION. SO THAT IS WHY ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT IS WHAT WE DO TO NOT HAVE
TO USE A TRANSCRIPT AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT DOING
THAT GRADUATE CANDIDATE ROSTER.
WE'RE ALL THE NURSING THREE
DIRECTORS HAVE TO DO IS SUBMIT
A LIST OF NAMES THAT DEGREE
THAT THEY RECEIVED THAT LASTED
OF ATTENDANCE AND THE DEGREE
DATE THAT THAT WAS- ACQUIRED.
SO THAT WAY WE CAN FIX THAT THE
OTHERTHING THAT I WANT TO
BRING OUT- SO THAT YOU GUYS ARE
AWARE OF IS EACH ONE OF OUR
APPLICATIONS BY EXAM AND SO
THAT'S THE FIRST TIME NURSE
THEY HAVEN'T TAKEN THE AND
COLLECTS EXAMINATION YET. HAS
THE OPTION TO APPLY FOR AN
INTERIM PERMIT. BACK IN TERM
PERMIT IS GRANTED AND THEY CAN
WORK ON THAT UNTIL. THEY TAKE
B. AND CLASS. ONCE THEY TAKE
THE LACKS THEY DON'T NEED AN
INTER PERMITTING MORE BECAUSE
THEY TOOK THE BECOME A LICENSE.
BUT THEY DO HAVE THAT INTERIM
PERMIT PROCESS AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE OFFER TO
THEM. NOW IF THEY FAIL THE AND
CLACK'S. BE INTER PERMIT IS
CANCELLED THE END CLICKS IS
THE- TEST THAT WE USE THAT
ENSURES THAT THEY HAVE A
MINIMUM BASE COMPETENCE. AND IF
THEY FAIL THAT EXAM WE CANNOT
HAVE THEM OUT THERE ON THE
INTERNET PRACTICING ANYMORE
BECAUSE IN FACT TO BE EXAM THAT
DETERMINES THAT THEIR STATE HAS
DETERMINED THAT THEY'RE NOT
STATE. THAT THOSE ARE A COUPLE
THINGS TO DO. THE OTHER THING
THAT DURING THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY THROUGH- THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER- THAT BEAT
BISBEE PC COULD TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN CAME INTO A FAX.
AND WITH THAT IT ACTUALLY
ALLOWED FOR ALL NURSING
STUDENTS TO IMMEDIATELY HELP-
WEOFFERED ON OUR WEBSITE AND
EIGHT MATRIX FOR EMERGENCY. AND
BY DATA BIRDS THE USE AND MAY
BE LICENSE HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES CAN ABSOLUTELY
UTILIZE THAT UTILIZE OUR
STUDENTS EVEN WHILE THEY'RE IN
THEIR NURSING PROGRAM. TO HELP
OUT THOSE FRONT LINE WORKERS
WHO ARE ABSOLUTELY EXHAUSTED-
ACTUALLY LIKE TO GET MY BOARD
PRESIDENT A CHANCE TO CHIME IN
ON THIS AND KIND OF. TALK ABOUT
THE CODE EFFECTS IF YOU WANT TO
AS SHE IS A AB. FRONTLINE
DIRECT CARE NURSE. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU SENATOR- ARE
TO A- AS A FRONTLINE ARE AND-
WE ARE HI MIKE IN OVERHEAD AB
DE UM. HOUSE. WHICH REQUIRED
QUITE A FEW ARE AND TO CARE FOR
THESE PATIENTS- MY WORK IN THIS
PHOTO WHAT'S REALLY. LESS OF A
FRONT END OF IT AND MORE OF A
REAL OUT OF IT IS I'M IN YOUR
NATAL INTENSIVE CARE NURSE. SO
I CAN'T SPEAK FOR DIRECT. TO
BEING A FRONTLINE WORKER BUT I
DID HEALTH CARE OR INSENSIBLE
OF KOBE. SO THEN I WOULD
ENCOURAGE- I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THAT. THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION- HE HAS FROM LORETTA
MELKY ARE EXECUTIVE OFFICER. MR
PRESIDENT I'D LIKE THE AND ONCE
AGAIN THANKING YOU AND- AND
THANK YOU THE ENTIRE NURSING
INDUSTRY FOR THAT THE WORK
YOU'VE GIVEN US TO SACRIFICE
AND- THE LOVE YOU'VE GIVEN
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THEN YOU TRULY ARE RECOGNIZED
AND WE RECOGNIZE THREE HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
CHAMBER. AND- PLEASE CONTINUE
THE GOOD WORK. PLEASE LOOK INTO
EXTRADITING SO WE CAN GET THE
STUDENTS THROUGH THE SYSTEM AND
HOWEVER YOU CAN DO THAT- I
WOULD GREATLY APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THANK
YOU. THE REPORT OF DOCTOR WEBER.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE WHO IS ON THE PANEL-
AND YOU KNOW LIKE WAS SAID BY
SENATOR ARE TO LET I'D LIKE TO
THANK ALL OF THOSE. HEALTHCARE
WORKERS I WAS WITH YOU ON THE
FRONT LINES. TAKING CARE OF THE
PUBLIC PATIENTS AND WE KNOW
IT'S NOT JUST THE NURSES IN THE
HOSPITALS IS THE ONES THAT WERE
IN OUTPATIENT FACILITIES AS
WELL. WE HAD MANY PATIENTS COME
THROUGH CLINICS THAT ENDED UP
TESTING POSITIVE THAT WERE
INITIALLY SEEN BY OUR NURSES
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH FOR THAT
WORK. I WANT TO GO BACK TO- THE
DISCUSSION THAT. WE'VE HAD
CONCERNING THE SHORTAGE OF
NURSES SPECIFICALLY IN CERTAIN
AREAS. AND WHAT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER WITH THAT- I THINK YOU
SAID IN TWENTY NINETEEN. OR
TWENTY TWENTY YOU INCREASE THE
ENROLLMENT- AT SOME OF THE
NURSING- THE SCHOOLS ARE KIND
OF WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
CAPTAIN ENROLLMENT NUMBERS. AND
HOW DOES A SCHOOL GOAL ABOUT-
GETTING AN INCREASE IN THE
AMOUNT OF STUDENTS THAT THEY'RE
ALLOWED TO HAVE AND IS THERE A
FEE ASSOCIATED WITH THAT. THANK
YOU NUMBER- I WOULD LIKE THAT
OUR EXECUTIVE OFFICER. LARA MEL
B. GIVE ME THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION. THANK YOU- THERE IS A
PROCESS- A MAJOR CURRICULUM
REVISION IS- ESTABLISHING
REGULATION STATUTE IT DOES
REQUIRE A TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR FEE. AND WHAT IS DONE IS
THE NURSING PROGRAM REACHES OUT
TO THE NURSING EDUCATION
CONSULTANT. THE STATE DEAD NEED
BAG EVIDENCE BEHIND THAT
SUPPORTS THAT NEED- AND THEIR
ABILITY TO- SUPPORT THE
STUDENTS THROUGH THE PROCESS.
ONCE THEY'VE SUBMITTED THE
REQUEST- STATED THE NEED AND
HOW THEY WOULD FOLLOW UP WITH
THAT THEY PROVIDE-
DOCUMENTATION BACK AND FORTH
WITH THE NURSING EDUCATION
CONSULTANT THAT EVALUATES
RESOURCES. THE NURSING
EDUCATION CONSULTANT LOOKS AT-
WILL BE A FACULTY THE
AVAILABILITY OF- IF IT'S A
BRICK AND MORTAR CAMPUS- ON
GROUND CAMPUS DEEPLY HAVE
CLASSROOM SIZE THAT CAN'T AND-
ACCOMMODATE AN INCREASED NUMBER
OF STUDENTS. DO THEY HAVE-
TECHNOLOGY THAT WILL
ACCOMMODATE THE INCREASED
NUMBER SERVICE IT WAS STUDENTS
DO THEY HAVE A NUMBER OF
COMPUTERS AVAILABLE FOR THEIR
STUDENTS IF THEY DO ONLINE
TESTING. OR ONLINE EXAMS ARE
ONLINE LECTURES. IN ADDITION TO
HAVE AN ADEQUATE- SKILLS LAB
SIMULATION LAB- DO THEY HAVE
STAFF THAT CAN SUPPORT THAT DO
THEY HAVE A BUDGET TO. PAY FOR
THE FACULTY'S WAGES THE SUPPORT
SERVICES IN THE SUPPORT STAFF
BETTER THERE- BAIT VARIOUS
EQUIPMENT- ONCE THAT IS
ESTABLISHED AND THAT WOULD YOU
SEE THAT THERE IS A PLAN THAT
BUDGETARY PLANET FACULTY PLAN A
RESOURCE IS PLANNED FOR-
FACILITIES ETCETERA. AND
ULTIMATE- WHETHER OR NOT THERE
IS CLINICAL SPACE PART OF OUR
REQUIREMENTS IS THAT STUDENTS.
DO HANDS ON DIRECT PATIENT
CARE- AS PART OF THAT
REQUIREMENT THAT STAND IN THE
OUTPATIENT SETTING AN ACUTE
CARE HOSPITAL SETTING- VARIOUS
DIFFERENT MODALITIES CAN BE
DONE TO MEET THOSE- DIRECT
PATIENT CARE HOURS. WITH THOSE
DIRECT PATIENT CARE HOURS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO BE OUT IN
THE COMMUNITY WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE COMMUNITY IS ABLE
TO SUPPORT THE INCREASING-
ENROLLMENT THE REQUESTED AS
WELL. THAT IS DONE BY
EVALUATING CLINICAL ACTION.
LOOKING AT THE CLINICAL
IMPACTION WE LOOK TO SEE IF
THERE IS THEIR CLINICAL ACTION
THERE MAY NOT BE IN SOME AREAS
THERE'S A WORKFORCE NEED. AND
HAVE ADEQUATE CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS THOSE ARE EASY ONES
FOR OUR BOARD MEMBERS TO
EVALUATE WHEN IT'S PRESENTED TO
THEM. WHEN THERE IS NOT A
WORKFORCE NEED. OR THERE IS NOT
CLINICAL SITES TO ACCOMMODATE
THE ENROLLMENT INCREASE REQUEST
AND THAT IS- A MUCH BIGGER-
DECISION THAT OUR BOARD MEMBERS
HAVE TO MAKE- FOR THEM TO LOOK
AT WHAT WE DON'T WANT TO SEE IS
THAT SCHOOLS. STUDENTS ENROLLED
IN SCHOOLS IN THAT AREA ARE
READY. ARE DISPLACED BECAUSE
WE'VE INCREASE ENROLLMENT IN
YOUR BY SCHOOL- WE WANT THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE ALREADY
ENROLLED IN SCHOOL TO BE ABLE
TO COMPLETE AND NOT RUN AGAINST
ANY ISSUES HAVE NOT BEEN OKAY
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A
CLINICAL. SITE DO YOU THEIR
HOURS ACT. SO WITH THAT ONCE
THE NURSING EDUCATION
CONSULTANT HAS ESTABLISHED THAT
THEY'VE MET ALL THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS OUTLINED IN LAW.
THAT INFORMATION. IS PRICED
EDUCATION LICENSED COMMITTEE.
ASEMAN LICENSE COMMITTEE GOES
AHEAD AND REVIEWS THE DATA THAT
WAS PRESENTED TO THEM. TALKS TO
THE DEEDS OF DIRECTOR TALKS TO
THAT CAMPUS PRESIDENT OR THE
VICE PRESIDENT OR- THE CFO OF
THAT SCHOOL- TO ENSURE THAT THE
DATA THAT WAS RECEIVED WAS
ACCURATE AND THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND THE UNDERTAKING THAT
THEY'RE TAKING THAT COMMITMENT.
HAVE TO THOSE STUDENTS WHO
CHOOSE THEIR SCHOOL TO GO TO-
AND RECEIVE THEIR SECRETIVE AND
A COMMITMENT THEY HAVE TO THAT
COMMUNITY. ONCE IT'S BEEN
ESTABLISHED AND THAT COMMITTEES
BEEN ABLE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION THAT COMMITTEE
MAKES A RECOMMENDATION TO THE
BOARD AND THE BOARD
ADDITIONALLY HAS A CHANCE TO
MEET WITH THE DEANS AND
DIRECTORS THE VICE PRESIDENT
THE PRESIDENT'S- ANYBODY THAT
IS REPRESENTING THAT
INSTITUTION THAT'S REQUESTING
THAT A ROMAN PRIEST. AND THEN
VERIFIES WITH THE NURSING
EDUCATION ASSAULT AT THE DATA
SUBMITTED IT IS- ACCURATE AS
FAR AS THEY CAN DETERMINE AS
WELL BASED ON THEIR EXPERIENCE
AND THE NUMBER IS MADE. AND
ENROLLMENT INCREASES EITHER
GRANTED OR DENIED IF IT'S
GRANTED. THE SCHOOL BECAUSE I
HAD NEVER MONTHS THAT IF IT'S
DENIED IT PROVIDED FEEDBACK ON
WHAT MIGHT NEED TO BE-
CORRECTED OR- PRESENTED IN
ORDER FOR THEM TO COME BACK AND
RE PRESENT HIMSELF TO THE
BOARD. ONCE THE BOARD RECEIVED
AT DATA OKAY NOT A CHANCE TO
MAKE THAT DECISION IS DONE.
ADDITIONAL FEES ARE NOT
RECEIVED IT IS JUST A ONE TIME
FEE AS THEY GO THROUGH THAT
ENTIRE APPROVAL PROCESS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT- IT IT
ACTUALLY SEEMS LIKE A VERY
EXPENSIVE AND LENGTHY PROCESS
FOR SCHOOL TO HAVE TO GO
THROUGH. ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING
THE FACT THAT WE ARE ALREADY
TALKING ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE A SHORTAGE OF NURSES AND
CERTAIN AREAS. I DON'T KNOW IF
THE BOARD HAS EVER CONSIDERED
BEING A LITTLE BIT MORE PRO
ACTIVE IN THIS ARENA. BY
LOOKING AT CERTAIN AREAS THAT.
YOU SHOULD ALREADY KNOW BY YOUR
DATA AND A LOT OF THAT
INFORMATION YOU SHOULD PROBABLY
ALREADY HAVE FROM. YOU KNOW
THEIR PREVIOUS APPLICATION THIS
FAR AS WHAT. I WHAT HOW MANY
FACULTY THEY HAVE IN. TECHNO
AND SENIOR I MEAN ALL OF THAT
STUFF YOU ALSO ALREADY HAVE. I
WOULD THINK THAT IT BE- PRETTY
EASY TO JUST. LOOK AT YOUR OWN
DATA AND LOOK THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO SEE
WHERE SHORTAGES ARE. AND
STARTED PRO ACTIVELY TARGET
CERTAIN SCHOOLS TO SAY HEY. WE
THINK THAT SHE WOULD BE A GREAT
CANDIDATE FOR AN ENROLLMENT
INCREASE. YOU KNOW IS IT
POSSIBLE FOR YOU TO DO THAT
RATHER THAN PUTTING THE BURDEN
ON THE SCHOOLS ESPECIALLY SINCE
WE HAVE ON A SHORTAGE OF NURSES
ALREADY. THIS IS SOMETHING TO
CONSIDER BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE
A VERY- EXPENSIVE AND ARDUOUS
PROCESS FOR SCHOOL TO HAVE TO
GO THROUGH. WHEN WE ALREADY
KNOW THAT THERE IS A NEED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT THE BOARD CAN CONSIDER WE
CAN LOOK AT THAT PROCESS THE
ONE THING THAT I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT IS THE CLINICAL
PLACEMENT ISSUE. THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING DOES NOT
HAVE ANY JURISDICTION OVER A
LICENSED HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES. THE LICENSE
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES ARE
OPERATED UNDERNEATH CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH. THANK
LICENSE HEALTHCARE FACILITIES
HAVE NO- HEY. REQUIREMENTS
REPORT TO US THAT THEY HAVE
CLINICAL SITES AVAILABLE- THAT
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT'S IN
STATURE REGULATION ACT. SO WHEN
WE CAN LOOK AT OUR DATA BASED
ON- WE KNOW HOW MANY STUDENTS
ARE IN THAT AREA. WE CAN LOOK
AT OUR DATA TO SEE HOW MANY
FACULTY HERE AVAILABLE IN THAT
AREA THAT IS THE DATA THAT WE
OWN WE ALSO OWN YOU KNOW THE
LICENSEE WHO HAS A- A RESIDENCE
THAT THEY PUT ON THEIR LICENSE
APPLICATION WERE. IN THAT AREA
WE HAVE THAT DATA THE DATA THAT
WE DON'T HAVE IS THE CLINICAL
PLACEMENT DATA- WHY THEY
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES. THE
LICENSE HEALTHCARE FACILITIES
DO NOT HAVE A REQUIREMENT IN
THE STATUTE OR RAPES REPORT
THAT DATA HOW- AND AGAIN TO
THEIR GOVERNMENT THROUGH C. P.
H. SO THAT WE WOULD. DEFINITELY
WANT TO PURSUE THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING WE CAN DO BUT WE NEED
TO HAVE THAT DATA. FROM THE
LICENSE HEALTH CARE FACILITIES
THAT TELL US WHICH SCHOOLS
THEY'RE CONTRACTED WITH HOW
MANY STUDENTS THEY HAVE. AND
WHAT SPECIALTY AREAS THOSE
STUDENTS BELONG TO OUR THE
RESPIRATORY THERAPIST MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE ARE THEY PHYSICIANS
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS NURSE
PRACTITIONERS. ARE THE NURSES-
LICENSE VOCATIONAL NURSES YOU
KNOW WHO WAS IN YOUR FACILITY
AND WHAT CAME YOUR STAFF IN
YOUR FACILITY A COMEDY- AND
THAT'S DATA THAT'S NOT OWNED BY
THE B. R. MAN AND WE HAVE NO
JURISDICTION OVER THAT. RIGHT
YEAH I'M SURE THAT THAT DATA IS
INFORMATION THAT THE SCHOOLS
WOULD BE MORE THAN WILLING TO
GIVE ABOUT THE CLINICAL
PLACEMENT- AND IT YOU KNOW AND
NOW WITH CODE RED AND THE USE
OF- SIMULATOR MORE- I KNOW IT'S
ALWYS IMPORTANT TO HAVE AT
LEAST SOME HANDS ON EXPERIENCE
WHEN YOU'RE GOING THROUGH
TRAINING IN THE HEALTHCARE
PROFESSION- BUT EVEN MEDICAL
SCHOOLS UTILIZE I. YOU KNOW
STIMULATE AT THIS. SO I'M GLAD
THAT THE IS THE- IN SO SOMETIME
WE DO HAVE TO THINK OF. THE
WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO PROVIDE
MORE ACCESS AND MORE CARE MORE
PEOPLE. AND START LOOKING AT
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES AND-
CHANGING AROUND LIKE WHAT KIND
OF ROTATIONS IN IMPLEMENTING
NEW THINGS IN THEIR SELF. BUT
I'M I'M SURE THAT THE SCHOOL TO
BE MORE THAN WILLING TO GIVE
YOU THAT KIND OF INFORMATION
AND LIKE I SAID WE CAN START
THINKING OUTSIDE THE BOX TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE. STILL
TRAINING VERY QUALITY NURSES
THAT ARE ABLE TO PASS THEIR
EXAM ONCE HE FINISED- BUT ALSO
INCREASING THE AMOUNT IN THE
ACCESS HERE INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DR WEBER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DOLLY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MY QUESTION IS FOR MISS MEL B.
I'VE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH TWO
OF THE NURSING- COLLEGES IN MY
DISTRICT BECAUSE OF THE
SISKIYOU AND SHASTA NURSING
PROGRAM THEIR ADMINISTERS EVERY
MINISTER TO REACHED OUT ON
BECAUSE THEY'RE HAVING A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME RECRUITING AND
RETAINING FULL TIME FACULTY FOR
THEIR PROGRAMS. BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T BE COMPETITIVE OUTSIDE OF
THE JUST WORKING INSIDE OF THE
SCHOOL SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE R. AND HAS THREE-
REGULATIONS THAT MAKE IT
DIFFICULT TO HIRE PART TIME
FACULTY. AND THAT I- THAT'S
NOT JUST IN MY DISTRICT BUT I'M
HEARING THAT STATEWIDE AS WELL
SO MY QUESTION IS. WHAT ARE THE
EXISTING RESTRICTIONS ON HIRING
PART TIME FACULTY AND WHY ARE
THEY NECESSARY- JUST AN AREA OF
CLARIFICATION WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY ANGRY ANY REGULATION ANY
STATUTE. THAT LOOKING AT. PART
TIME FULL TIME PER DIEM
FACULTY- AND SO JUST TO PROVIDE
THAT CLARIFICATION I AM AWARE
THAT THERE ARE- SOME
DIFFICULTIES IN GETTING
FACULTY. I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
THAT HERE. WHERE WE HAVE THREE
DIFFERENT PATHWAYS WITH THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING ON
GETTING- APPROVAL FOR FACULTY.
YOU CAN HAVE AN ASSOCIATE
DEGREE IN NURSING ONE YEAR OF
EXPERIENCE- IN A SPECIALTY AREA
AND APPLIED FOR- FACULTY
APPROVAL WE WOULD THEN APPROVE
YOU AS A- CLINICAL TEACHING
ASSISTANT. CLINICAL TEACHING
pCLINICAL ROTATIONS CAN ASSIST
IN THE LAB- AND CANNING YES
TEACH- OCCASIONALLY AND ASK BE
REBASED CLASSROOM. THE NEXT-
AVENUE THAT WE HAVE FOR FACULTY
IS A BACHELOR'S PREPARED NURSE.
WITH ONE YEAR EXPERIENCE AT THE
BEDSIDE. THAT VOUCHERS- NURSE
CAN THEN APPLY TO BE FACULTY.
AND THAT FACULTY MEMBER. CAN BE
REACHED AT SYSTEMS INSTRUCTOR
BETTER SYSTEM INSTRUCTOR CAN
HAVE DIRECT OVERSIGHT OF THAT
CLINICAL GROUP. THEY CAN ALSO
ASSIST IN THE LAB AS WELL AS
ASSIST IN- THE THEORY AS LONG
AS THEY HAVE A LEAD INSTRUCTOR.
OVER THEM. FINALLY THAT LAST
HALF WAY FOR FACULTY THAT THE
BEER AND HAS IS A MASTER'S
DEGREE PREPARED NURSE. THE
MASTER'S DEGREE PREPARED NURSE
HAS- EDUCATION AND CURRICULUM
ONE THEORY. ON THE CLASSROOM
DEVELOPMENT CLASSROOM
MANAGEMENT CURRICULAR DESIGN-
AND WE'VE BEEN APPROVED THEM AS
A FACULTY MEMBER THAT FACULTY
MEMBERS APPROVED AS AN
INSTRUCTOR. WHERE YOU RUN INTO
SOME ISSUES IS CREDITING BODIES.
ONLY LOOK AT MASTER DEGREE
PREPARE NURSES ABOVE AND IN
FACT HAD- SOME OF THEIR
GUIDELINE WHERE THEY WILL TO
TERMINAL SERVER YOU WANT THAT
TO BE A TEACHER. IN P. AND THEY
WANT THAT 2 DEGREES FOR FIVE-
BAGGY. HARD BECAUSE AS WE KNOW
IN CALIFORNIA THERE'S A DEEP
CREASE NUMBER TERMINAL DEGREE
PREPARED NURSES THERE IS A
DECREASE NUMBER OF SCHOOLS THAT
OFFER OFFERED TO THE TERMINAL
DEGREE- SO WITH THE B. R. AND
AVENUE TO FACULTY WE ACTUALLY
ENCOMPASS THE ASSOCIATE DEGREE
NURSE. WHICH IS A TWO YEAR THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES A FOUR YEAR
AND THEN A MASTER'S DEGREE OR
GRADUATE LEVEL NURSES THAT CAN
ACTUALLY SERVICE FACULTY- IT IS
DIFFICULT THOUGH BECAUSE AS YOU
HAVE POINTED OUT WHICH IS
ACTUALLY CORRECT IS THE ABILITY
FOR FINANCIALLY SUPPORTING THE-
FACULTY MEMBER. WHAT HAPPENS HE
IS AT THE BEDSIDE NURSE THAT
DIRECT PATIENT CARE NURSE
THEY'RE GOING TO MAKE MUCH MORE
MONEY IN THAT ROLE THAN THEY DO
IN- AND EDUCATION WALL- AND
THAT'S WHERE OU GET A SALARY
DIVIDE AND THAT IS PROBLEMATIC.
YOU KNOW BECAUSE IF. THEY
USUALLY REQUIRE. REIST EXPIRY-
DEGREE. BUT THEN THEY DON'T
HAVE TO CALL PAY WHEN THE OUT
TO ACADEMIC IT'S TO. SOON
KNOWING THAT THAT THE CHALLENGE
TO HOLD THOSE QUALIFIED- NURSES
INSTEAD OF HIGHLY QUALIFIED IN
ORDER TO CONSTRUCT FUTURE
NURSES OF COURSE WOULD. MAKE
SENSE BUT IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT THE BEER AND IS LOOKING
OUT ON HOW WE'RE GOING TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN BECAUSE IF
WE DON'T HAVE INSTRUCTORS. IT
WON'T IT DOESN'T MATTER IF WE
OPEN UP MORE SLOTS THROUGHOUT
SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT THE STATE IF
WE DON'T HAVE INSTRUCTORS SO.
FOR INSTANCE OF THE CALLS AT
THIS YEAR'S WE HAVE ONE
INSTRUCTOR AND THEY DIDN'T
GRADUATE ONE NURSE THIS WHOLE
YEAR. SO YOU HAVE A PROGRAM
THAT'S ACCREDITED WAITING FOR
PEOPLE TO APPLY TO BUT THEY
CAN'T GET IN BECAUSE YOU ONLY
HAVE ONE INSTRUCTOR SO I THINK
IT'S- DEFINITELY SOMETHING
THAT. IF WE CAN PARTNER WITH
YOU TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN SPECIFICALLY
INSTRUCTORS I THINK OF THE ALL
OF US HERE. WOULD AGREE THAT
THAT'S HIGHLY IMPORTANT. YES IT
IS IN ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I'M DOING TO ADDRESS THAT IS I
AM WORKING WITH THE C. A. S. I.
I. T. TO CREATE A FACULTY
DATABANK. AND SO WHAT WE ARE
DOING WITHIN THE BRN IS WE WILL
PUT IN EVERY SINGLE PROOF
FACULTY. AND THE LOCATION WITH
THEIR LICENSE ON TO WHERE THE
ACT AND WILL BE ABLE TO GO IN
TO THIS DATA BANK ONCE IT'S
COMPLETED AND- PUBLISHED TO OUR
WEBSITE- TO FIND OUT WHERE
FACULTY ARE SO THAT THEY CAN
TRY TO FIND THEM SO THAT'S A
SERVICE THAT I THINK THAT WE
CAN OFFER- I HAVE EXPLORED
THAT- I WAS A FACULTY MEMBER
MYSELF- AND I WAS THE DIRECTOR
OF NURSING MYSELF AS WELL
PREVIOUSLY. COMING INTO THIS
ROLE SO I KNOW THAT THE
SHORTAGE WAS REAL- AND I WISH I
KNEW WHERE I COULD FIND FACULTY
SO- BY PROVIDING THIS SERVICE
WILL BE WITH. THIS YEAR'S START
CONVERSATIONS AND WE'RE WORKING
ON THAT- WE'RE HOPING TO TIE
THAT BACK UP TO YOU. IT IS A
BREEZE SYSTEM AND HAVE THAT PUT
OUT AS PART OF THEIR LICENSE
AND THEN REPORTED OUT THROUGH
TABLEAU ON TO OUR WEBSITE.
THROUGH AN INTERACTIVE- STATE
MAP THAT WILL SAY WEIRD THAT
NURSING FACULTY ARE WHERE THE
PERCENTAGES OF NURSING FACULTY
OZARK AND THEN WHAT THEIR
SPECIALTY IS AS WELL. SO I'M
HOPING THAT. THAT'S A SERVICE
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE VERY SOON.
THANK YOU MEMBERS. CALLING THE
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CAN. LET ME- LET ME ASK TWO
QUESTIONS JUST TO PERHAPS TEE
IT UP FOR OUR NEXT- NEXT PANEL
DISCUSSION I MAY HAVE MISSED
THIS- AND BY THE WAY MS BOBBY
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH FOR
BOTH OF YOU FOR PARTICIPATING
IN FOR THE- THOROUGHNESS OF
YOUR RESPONSES MUCH
APPRECIATED. WITH RESPECT TO
APPLICATIONS FOR ENDORSEMENT
MAYBE YOU MENTIONED THIS BUT
HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE TO SECURE
A TEMPORARY LICENSE ASSUMING
THAT. THAT VERSION OF LICENSES
AVAILABLE UNDER THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES. AS SOON AS WE
GET FINGERPRINTS BACK FROM D.
O. J. WE PROCESS THEM THAT DAY
PERFECT AND THEN THAT THAT
COMPLETELY LEADS INTO MY SECOND
QUESTION BUT WE'VE HAD THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT FINGERPRINTS
FINGERPRINT CARDS AND- AND THAT
THOSE ISSUES- DURING OUR LAST-
ONE OF OUR HEARINGS IN ANY
EVENT. WHAT- HAS THE BOARD
BEGAN TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
FIND WAYS TO EXPEDITE THIS
FINGERPRINT PROCESS ASSUMING
THAT IT CAN BE EXPEDITED I
REALIZE THAT IT'S COMPLETELY
OUTSIDE OF THE CONTROL OF THE
BORDER REGISTERED NURSES. IT'S
OUTSIDE OF THE CONTROL I THINK
A DOJ AS WELL- SO BY CALIFORNIA
LAW IT IS REQUIRED THAT YOU
HAVE TO HAVE PERMISSION TO
SHARE YOUR FINGERPRINTS AND SO
THAT PERMISSION COMES FROM WHEN
THAT PERSON IS SENSE IN THERE
ARE CARD OR DOES THEIR LIVES
AGAIN. AS I'M SURE YOU GUYS ARE
VERY WELL AWARE THE LIVE SCAN
PROCESS CAN ONLY BE COMPLETED
IN THE STATE THAT YOU DO THE
LIVE SCAN ACT SO WHEN YOU'RE
INDOORS THING IN CALIFORNIA.
THE INNATE PROBLEM THERE IS
YOU'RE COMING FROM OUT OF STATE
AND UNLESS YOU TRAVEL IN THE
CALIFORNIA AND TAKE YOUR LIVES
GABBY IN CALIFORNIA IT CANNOT
BE SAID TO A CALIFORNIA ENTITY.
SO THAT IS- PROBLEMATIC FOR OUT
OF STATE ENDORSING NURSES AND-
SOME DO YOU TRAVEL HERE AND
THAT'S GREATLY APPRECIATED AND
WE GET THOSE RESULTS BACK
WITHIN A FEW DAYS- NOW WHEN WE
HAVE EIGHTY AT. OUT OF STATE
PERSON THAT SUBMITS A HARD CARD
THAT IS THEN MAILED IN THAT IS
THEN SUBMITTED TO DOJ IT IS
THAT PROCESS CLEAR DIRECTLY I
AM THAT CAN TAKE UP DID YOU
KNOW THREE MONTHS THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT THEY WANT IN DOT
DOES WORK WITH US THEY TRY TO
TURN THESE THINGS AROUND IN
JUST A COUPLE WEEKS- IN ORDER
FOR US TO EXPEDITE BACK WHAT WE
DO IS RUN A REPORT. EACH
MORNING AND AS SOON AS WE
RECEIVE THAT ARE APPLICANTS
HAVE A FINGERPRINT RESULTS BACK
THOSE APPLICANTS ARE PULLED TO
THE FRONT AND PROCESSED
IMMEDIATELY SO WE PROCESS ALL
OVER A TEMPORARY LICENSE
REQUIREMENTS REQUEST- BASED ON
FINGERPRINTS BACK. BECAUSE
THAT'S USUALLY THE HOLD UP. I'M
NOT GONNA BE. BELABOR THIS WITH
QUESTIONS ON THAT WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE HAVE THE DISK- IN. IS
LIVE SCANS STATE BY STATE OR IF
I'M LIVE SCAN IN THE STATE OF
GEORGIA AND HAVE A GEORGIA.
LICENSE AS A REGISTERED NURSE-
FROM TWO YEARS AGO THAT'S AN
ACTIVE LICENSE MAY I AUTHORIZED
THE STATE OF GEORGIA TO
TRANSMIT MY FINGERPRINT CARD
INFORMATION. TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT HAVING TO DO
ANOTHER LIVE SCAN. IS THAT
SOMETHING MS WELL BE THAT
YOU'VE ENCOUNTERED. I HAVEN'T
KEPT THAT THAT'S ACTUALLY ON
THE DOJ WEBSITE WHERE THEY CAN
ONLY DO CALIFORNIA LIKE SCANNED
TO CALIFORNIA ENTITY- AND THEY
STATE AS A STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT NEXT TO IT I DON'T
KNOW THAT NUMBER AT THE TOP OF
MY HEAD BUT I CAN FIND THAT FOR
YOU WELL THAT'S OKAY WE- WE
HAVE SOME PLANS TO HAVE SOME
CONVERSATIONS WITH A NEW
ATTORNEY GENERAL ON THAT POINT.
AND I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOUR
INTEREST IN IN CHECKING AT TO
TRY TO EXPEDITE THE FINGERPRINT
PROCESS WHERE POSSIBLE SO WE'RE
GOING TO TRY TO HELP YOU OUT A
LITTLE BIT TO WHERE WE CAN. I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU MAYBE
SEEING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS LET'S MOVE
ON TO OUR NEXT PANEL IT'S THE
OVERVIEW. OF NURSE LICENSURE
COMPACTS TEMPORARY LICENSURE
AND RECIPROCITY AND I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME REBEKAH OF REBEKAH
BLETSCH. THE DIRECTOR OF STATE
ADVOCACY AND LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS AT THE NATIONAL COUNCIL
OF STATE BOARDS OF NURSING THEM
I HOPE I PRONOUNCED YOUR NAME
CORRECTLY WELCOME. HI THANK YOU
YES WHAT TRENDS WITH SCRATCH.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE
HERE TODAY- I AS AS YOU
MENTIONED MY NAME'S RECORD
BOTCHING THE DIRECTOR OF STATE
ADVOCACY AND LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS AT AND C-SPAN- ARE AND
YES BEYOND WHICH IS THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF STATE
BOARDS OF NURSING IS A
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION-
COMPRISED OF THE BOARD OF
NURSING AND- EACH STATE- SO-
ADLER TO HEAR ANY MENTION
CALIFORNIA IS A MEMBER OF AND
THAT'S THE END AND WE WORK WITH
THEM. ROUTINELY I'M I AM
HEARING AN ECHO ARE YOU HEARING
AN ECHO ON YOUR END AS WELL.
MAYBE IF YOU'VE TURNED YOUR OR
YOU WANT ME TO ON YOUR COMPUTER
SYSTEM IN. I'M NOT SHOULD I BE
YES MA'AM. ONCE WHAT THE
SPEAKERS NOT YOURS NOT YOUR
VOICE THE SPEAKER- AB WOULD YOU
WANT TO HEAR YOU. YEAH I KNOW I
SAID I WAS LIKE OH REALLY- I'M
NOT SURE I DIDN'T THINK I WAS
BUT I'LL TRY TO SPEAK SLOWLY IF
THAT HELPS. SO I WANTED TO TAKE
A MINUTE AND NOT TALK FIRST
ABOUT THE NURSE LICENSURE
COMPACT SO. THE NURSE LICENSURE
COMPACT- WAS DRAFTED BY AND YES
BEYOND SO AGAIN OUR OUR MEMBERS
THE BOARDS OF NURSING. AND THE
AND I'LL SEE BASICALLY ALLOWS
OWNERS TO HAVE A LICENSE AND
THE STATE THAT THEY RESIDE IN.
AND THEN USE THAT LICENSE IN
ANY OF THE OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE ENACTED THE COMPACT-
WITHOUT HAVING TO GO THROUGH
ANY ADDITIONAL- APPLICATIONS
OR- REGULATORY HURDLES IF YOU
WELL. IT OPERATES VERY
SIMILARLY TO ALTHOUGH VERY
DIFFERENT OPERATIONALLY IT
OPERATES SIMILAR TO BE AT.
DRIVER'S LICENSE CONTACT. SO
LIKE YOU CAN DRIVE ACROSS THE
BORDER WITHOUT HAVING TO YOU
KNOW NOTIFY LET'S SAY NEVADA
THAT YOU'RE THERE OR HAVE A
NEVADA DRIVER'S LICENSE- YOU'RE
ABLE TO USE YOUR CALIFORNIA
DRIVER'S LICENSE BECAUSE IT'S
RECOGNIZED IN EACH OF THE
STATES THAT I DON'T SEE IS.
SIMILAR AND THAT WAY. THERE ARE
CURRENTLY OUR THIRTY FIVE
STATES AND JURISDICTIONS GUAM-
DID ENACTED THIS YEAR SO NOW I
HAVE TO GET USED I DID OR NOT
EXCUSE ME STATE AND TERRITORY
THAT TO GET USED TO SAYING
STATES AND TERRITORIES AND NOT
JUST STATE NOW- AND WE HAVE-
ABOUT THREE STATES THAT WE ARE.
CONFIDENT WILL BE PASSING-
BEFORE THE SUMMER BEFORE THAT
THEY GO ON THEIR SUMMER BREAK
ON THE SESSION. SO IN THE- AND
I DON'T THINK IT'S GROWING VERY
MUCH- AND- I- WELL I COULD STOP
THERE ON THE AND I'LL BE AND-
ASK IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS OR
IF THERE'S ANYTHING
SPECIFICALLY THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL IF I TOUCHED UPON. I'M
OR I CAN MOVE ON TO THE-
TEMPORARY LICENSURE IN THE
RECIPROCITY AS WELL FROM WHAT
WE HAVE YOU FINISHED YOUR
PREPARED- COMMENTS AND THEN-
WILL OPEN IT UP TO QUESTIONS.
SURE THEY'RE NOT OUR TEMPORARY
LICENSURE WHICH I KNOW WAS
DISCUSSED- A BIT BY THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD- ABOUT 50% OF
THE STATE'S OFFER- THE
TEMPORARY LICENSE OR WHETHER
THAT'S FOR- NEW APPLICATION SO
LICENSURE BY EXAMINATION. OR HI
LICENSURE BY ENDORSEMENT- AND
IT TYPICALLY THAT TEMPORARY
LICENSURE IS- IT'S PROVIDED ME
WHILE YOU'RE THERE WAITING FOR
A CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CHECK
FOR- AND CUT THE DAMS WORDS
AGAIN AS WAS ALREADY MENTIONED.
THERE ARE ALSO SOME TEMPORARY
LICENSES ARE JUST KINDA LICENSE
OR EXCEPTION- EXEMPTIONS THAT
ARE IN STATUTES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY FOR SPECIFIC ISSUES SO-
DURING TIMES OF DISASTER-
SOMETIMES- FOR INSTANCE IF RATE
DURING CASE MANAGEMENT EFFORT
NURSES FOLLOWING HER PATIENT
ACROSS THE STATE LINE SHE WOULD
BE. HAVING SOMETHING TO
LIGHTEN- DURING THAT TIME- SO
AGAIN MUCH MORE SPECIFIC ABOUT-
AND THEN RECIPROCITY AND
GENERAL. THERE ARE REALLY THE I
CAN I CAN THINK OF ONE OUR
RECIPROCITY AGREEMENT. IT'S
BETWEEN MINNESOTA AND SOUTH
DAKOTA THAT'S MORE REGIONAL
BUT- THERE THE REALITY IS THAT
MOST STATES DON'T HAVE- SMALLER
REGIONAL LICENSURE- SURPRISE
THE AGREEMENT SIGNED I THINK
PROBABLY DUE TO THE COMPACT NOW
THAT THE CONTACT HAS GROWN
ACROSS THE COUNTRY- THE NEED
FOR THOSE REGIONAL CONTRACTS
JUST AREN'T THERE YOU KNOW
QUITE AS MUCH. THERE IS A NEW.
OUR PROPOSAL I NOT JUST
PROPOSAL AND HAS BEEN ENACTED
IN SOME STATES THAT IS. KIND OF
THE- HERMAN THIS UNIVERSAL
LICENSURE- IT WAS FIRST ENACTED
IN ARIZONA AND WE HAVE SEEN IT-
I BELIEVE MISSISSIPPI ADOPTED
IT HAS BAD- FILE IS BUILDING
MANY STATES OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS- IT'S DIFFERENT
FROM THE COMPACT AND THAT
TYPICALLY WELL FIRST OFF IT'S-
THERE'S NO MODEL LANGUAGE EACH
STATE IS DOING IT. WHO IN YOUR
THAT ARE INTRODUCING BILLS ARE
DOING IN A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
WAY- I KNOW AT LEAST WITH
ARIZONA'S WHICH WAS AGAIN THE
FIRST AND FULLY FUNCTIONAL NOW-
BEFORE THAT. WHAT UNIVERSE LIFE
AND THE PEOPLE CAN BE ISSUED
THEY THEY'RE STILL NEED TO BE A
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CHECK DONE-
AND THEY'RE STILL NEEDS TO HEAD
THERE ARE STILL BEING- KIND OF
REQUIREMENTS THAT NEED TO BE
MACRO FOR THAT LICENSE CAN BE
GRANTED SO. WELL IT'S A ONE WAY
FOR- ARIZONA TO. HOW DO WE
STREAMLINED SOME THINGS IT'S
NOT GETTING PAST SOME OF THE
BIGGEST HURDLES AS WERE ALREADY
MENTIONED WHICH IS- THIS TIME
CONSUMING CRIMINAL BACKGROUND
CHECKS- AT THAT TRUST SO. AND
THAT IS NOT AGAIN I KNOW THAT
THAT HAS BEEN ENACTED IN
ARIZONA I BELIEVE THERE MAY BE
THREE OR FOUR STATES NOW BUT IT
HAS NOT- NEED NOT IN THE
MAJORITY OF STATES BY ANY MEANS.
AND WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. COLLINGS ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG.
THANK YOU CARE I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PERSPECTIVE AND
I WILL A LOT OF TO- AS THE FULL
TRANSPARENCY I AM AN ADVOCATE
FOR CALIFORNIA ENTER INTO THE
NURSE LICENSURE COMPACT BUT%
FROM YOUR NATIONAL PERSPECTIVE
HOW IS THE NLC HELP CONTACT
STATE. AND HOW COULD HELP
CALIFORNIA DURING THE DURING
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN
PARTICULARLY HE COULD ADDRESS
HOW A RULE REGION'S OR RULES
STATES HAVE ADDRESSED. SHORTAGE
ISSUES THROUGH THE CONTACT.
SURE SO EXTRA FIRST I'LL START
WITH COALBED- AS I'M SURE
YOU'RE WELL AWARE AB I BELIEVE
EVERY STATE PASSWORD NOT
COLORADO BUT ALMOST EVERY
STATE'S GOVERNOR ISSUED SOME
SORT OF A LICENSURE WAIVER OR
EXEMPTION IN ORDER TO BRING
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS INTO THEIR
STATE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
AND I'M REALLY WHAT THE IN
THOSE STATES WERE DOING IS
IMPLEMENTING THEIR OWN KIND OF
FAST TRACK COMPACT BECAUSE IF
YOU ARE A MEMBER OF THE CONTACT
NURSES ARE READY ABLE TO COMMON
PRACTICE IT IMMEDIATELY YOU
DON'T NEED TO HAVE ANY SORT OF
A LICENSURE EXEMPTION OR WAIT
FOR THAT DISASTER DECLARATION.
ONE OF THE REASON THE I'LL BE
REALLY HELPED THOSE STATE
DURING COLD READ IS THAT. IT
WILL WORK NUMBER ONE ONE OF THE
BIG GRIEVANCES THERE WAS NO
WAITING SO. EVEN THOUGH
ULTIMATELY ALL OF THE GOVERNOR
DID ISSUE THOSE LICENSURE
EXAMINATIONS IT WASN'T
IMMEDIATE- THERE WERE SURGES AT
DIFFERENT TIMES AND GOVERNOR'S
TOOK ACTIONS AT DIFFERENT TIMES
SO. IT WASN'T AS THOUGH YOU
KNOW- IMMEDIATELY WHEN THE
FIRST COALBED. CASE HENCE. THE
LICENSES WERE IN A LIFE CHANGER
WITH EXAM TODAY IT TOOK A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME. AND THEN
ALONG THOSE SAME LINES THOSE
LICENSURE. EXECUTIVE ORDERS AS
EXTENSION NEEDED TO BE- RENEWED
IF YOU WELL MOST OF THOSE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS LASTED FOR A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF MONEY. AND
THEN THEY WOULD BE EXTENDED
HOWEVER THE NURSES WHO ARE
PRACTICING UNDER THOSE LICENSE
OR EXEMPTIONS DIDN'T. KNOW FOR
SURE WINNER IF THOSE. EXEMPTION
WOULD BE EXTRA. OFTENTIMES I
KNOW THAT THIS IS JUST AN
EXAMPLE FROM NEW YORK BUT THERE
WERE NURSES AND HOSPITAL THAT
WE'RE FINDING OUT THE DAY
BEFORE. THAT THE THOSE
EXEMPTIONS WOULD BE EXPECT
EXTENDED AND THEREFORE THEY
COULD KEEP TREATING PATIENTS
ADMITTED IT WAS JUST A VERY.
STRESSFUL TIME ON TOP OF AN
EXTREMELY STRESSFUL TIME DURING
THE PANDEMIC- SO THAT STABILITY
WITH THEIR- THE OTHER REALLY
IMPORTANT THING TO HIGHLIGHT
ABOUT THE COMPACT IS THAT THERE
IS A REQUIREMENT OF CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECK REQUIREMENTS.
SO WHEN CONTRACTORS HAS COME TO
PRACTICE IN YOUR STATE THEY ARE
ABLE TO IMMEDIATELY PRACTICE
AND YOU KNOW THAT THEY'VE
ALREADY BEEN CRIMINAL BACK
CRIMINALLY BACKGROUND CHECKS
BECAUSE THEY HAD TO DO THAT. IN
ORDER TO ATTAIN THEIR COMPACT
LICENSE. SO DURING THE PANDEMIC
WHEN THE GOVERNOR'S DID EXEMPTS
LICENSURE. THEY YOU KNOW THERE
WAS NO TIME TO DO CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS OF COURSE SO.
I DON'T MEAN TO NECESSARILY
IMPLIES THAT. A LOT OF THE
NURSES CROSSING STATE LINES
WERE DOING ANYTHING CRIMINAL OR
WORK ANY KIND OF BAD ACTORS BUT
YOU KNOW AS YOU KNOW IT IT DOES
HAPPEN. RIGHT AND THIS IS ONE
KIND OF WAY TO MAINTAIN THAT
PUBLIC PROTECTION- BY. KNOWING
THAT THE CRIMINAL BACKGROUND
CHECKS HAVE BEEN DONE IN THOSE
NURSES DO NOT HAVE A CRIMINAL
PAST. BUT WE GOT HE SAID THAT
SO THE NLC. PROVIDES SOME
CERTAINTY AND STABILITY- BUT MY
SECOND QUESTION IS THE B. R.
AND HAS CITED CONTINUING
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS AS A
REASON FOR WHY. CALIFORNIA MAY
NOT BE FIT FOR PARTICIPATING IN
THE CONTACT. IN YOUR OPINION
HAVE DISCREPANCIES IN
CONTINUING EDUCATION LEAD TO
ANY. PROBLEMS OR ISSUES- WITH
ANY PARTICIPATING STATE. NOW IT
HASN'T- IT HASN'T AND IT YOU
KNOW WITH THIRTY FOUR STATES
AND TERRITORIES PARTICIPATING
NOW THEY THE C. E. REDACTING
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS ARE
VARIED ACROSS THOSE STATES- I
THINK ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS
WHY THIS HASN'T BECOME AN ISSUE
IS THAT TYPICALLY EMPLOYERS
REQUIRE TEACHING EDUCATION AND
PACKAGING EDUCATION AS MUCH
MORE SPECIFIC TO- THAT NURSE'S
EMPLOYMENT AND YOU KNOW WHAT
HERE SHE IS DOING ON A DAILY
BASIS SO. I THINK THAT'S PART
OF THE REASON IT'S NOT AS IF
THE STATE DOESN'T REQUIRE SEED
IT'S NOT AS IF THE NURSES ARE
DOING SEE IT'S JUST THAT IT'S
NOT REQUIRED. BY THE BOARD OF
NURSING FOR RIGHT NOW ALL- OKAY
I GOT THAT AND THAT THAT
CERTAINLY- A VERY INTERESTING
POINT AND WHAT NOTING- IN TERMS
OF- I CERTAINLY OF AN I'M MORE
OF A NATIONAL EXPERIENCE BUT
CERTAINLY FOR I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'VE EVER BEEN TO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN CALIFORNIA OR OTHER
REAL REGIONS- WE HAVE-
CHALLENGES AND STAFFING. AND
I'M SURE YOU'RE AWARE OF OTHER
PARTS OF THE UNITED STATES TO
HAVE SIMILAR- CHALLENGES. HOW
HAS THE NLC BENEFITTED RULE
REGIONS- AND THEN. IS THERE A
IS THERE TIED TO- TELEHEALTH
AND WOULD BE IN ENTERING INTO
AN L. AND L. C. INTO THEM AS A
CONTACT. HAS IT HELPED EXPAND
TELEHEALTH AND IN THE COMPACT
STATE. YEAH ONE OF THE BIG WAYS
THAT IT HELPS IN RURAL AREAS
IT'S FILLING- GAPS IN CARE SO
FOR YOU KNOW THERE IS A WIDE
NURSING SHORTAGE OF GENERAL
NURSING SHORTAGE THAT. A LOT OF
AREAS AND A LOT OF STATES ARE
EXPERIENCING. BUT SOME OF THE
MOST- URGENT NEED IS WITH
SPECIALTY NURSES SO WHEN I SEE
YOU NURSES AS EASY NURSES- IT
IT'S NURSES THAT HAVE THESE THE
SPECIALTY TRAINING AND YOU
CANNOT JUST HOSPITAL CAN'T
RECRUIT. ANY ARE AND TO FILL
THOSE SPOTS. SO WE'VE SEEN
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AREAS THAT
MAY HAVE A HARDER TIME
RECRUITING IS SPECIALTY NURSES
WITH THE I DON'T SEE IS
EXTREMELY HELPFUL- HELPING-
HEALTHCARE INSTITUTIONS IN THAT
AREA GREEN AND TRAVEL TEMPORARY
ITS SPECIALTY NURSES. TO KIND
OF FILL THOSE GAPS AND KERR. AS
FAR AS TELEHEALTH- IT HELLO HOW
HAS BEEN EXPANDING NOW FOR
YEARS BUT THE PANDEMIC HAS
REALLY. REALLY- MADE A LOT OF
OUR LOT OF CONSUMERS BECOME
MUCH MORE COMFORTABLE WITH
TELEHEALTH BECAUSE THEY'VE
THEY'VE USED IT OVER THE LAST
YEAR THEY'VE BEEN FORCED TO AND
REALIZE THAT THIS IS- WELL I
DON'T KNOW SOME MAY HAVE
REALIZED THAT THIS IS A GREAT
JANET PARTICULARLY FOR RURAL
AREAS. SO I THINK THAT WE'RE
GOING TO ONLY SEE MORE
EXPANSION I KNOW THAT ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THEY'RE BAD MORE
AND MORE LAWS- TO EXPAND THE
TELEHEALTH ITS COVERAGES
REIMBURSEMENT. AND THE COMPACT
FACILITATE THAT IN THE SENSE
THAT A NURSE COULD BE IN ONE
STATE TO THE OWNERS CAN BE IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT COULD BE
PRACTICING ON TELEHEALTH ON
PATIENTS- IN ANY CONTEXT STATE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY SO A IN ONE
WITH HER ONE LICENSE WHEREAS
RIGHT NOW IF THAT NURSE WANTED
TO PRACTICE TELEHEALTH IN. FIVE
DIFFERENT STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY HE WOULD NEED TO BE
LICENSED AND- HEY LOOK LICENSE
OR FEES FOR NEW THE LICENSE AND
THOSE FIVE STATES. SO- SO I A I
JUST WANTED TO DIVE A LITTLE
DEEPER EASY SPECIALTY NURSES
AND WE AS IT WAS EVERYWHERE IN
THE COUNTRY BUT A LOT OF US IN
CALIFORNIA UNDERSTOOD THE
IMPORTANCE OF AN ICU NURSE.
WHICH IS VERY DISTINCT FROM
ANOTHER NURSING IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE PANDEMIC THAT WAS KIND
OF WHAT WAS DRIVING A LOT OF
OUR STAFFING CAPACITIES. SO
WHEN YOU SAY SPECIALLY ORDERED
NURSES ICU NURSES ARE INCLUDED
IN THAT CORRECT. CRACKED AND
ICY YOU EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
NURSES- OBGYN NURSES YEAH.
PERFECT I THINK THAT'S THE ONE
OF THE I GUESS TO ME IS A
COMPELLING REASON FOR
CALIFORNIA TO ENTER INTO THE
CONTRACT IS THAT WELL WHEN WE
NEED THOSE THOSE SPECIALTY
NURSES ESPECIALLY IN THE RURAL
REGIONS AND WE CAN'T HAVE THEM
MAKING IT EASIER FOR NURSES TO
COME INTO OUR REGION TO PROVIDE
THAT CRITICAL. SAFETY NET AND
HEALTHCARE ACCESS IS- ESSENTIAL
AND THEN MY LAST QUESTION IS IN
A TIGHT TO THE POINT WHERE THE
NLC HELP UNDERSERVED HOSPITALS
MAINTAIN A STABLE SUPPLY OF
NURSES IN THEIR FACILITIES IN A
MORE COST EFFECTIVE MATTER IN
YOUR OPINION. YEAH AND IN MY
OPINION YES BECAUSE AGAIN
THERE'S JUST NO.WAITING PERIOD
TO BRING NURSES AND- SO I THINK
THAT IS WHERE. THE EXACT KIND
OF STABILITY KNOWING THAT YOU
WILL YOU HAVE A POOL OF NURSES
THAT CAN BE USED- IT IS HELPFUL
FOR. EMPLOYERS AND- IT REDUCES
LICENSURE FEES FOR NURSES AS AS
WELL AS FOR EMPLOYERS OF
EMPLOYERS ARE PAYING. TRIBUTE
GREAT THE AND THEN I AM JUST A
CIRCLE BACK AND I APPRECIATE
THE PATIENCE OF THE CHAIR AND
IN BACK TO THE DISCREPANCIES
AND CONTINUED EDUCATION AND
PROBABLY ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY. MANY WOULD ARGUE
CALIFORNIA ISN'T FIT FOR
PARTICIPATING AS YOU MENTIONED.
AS EMPLOYERS REQUIRE THEIR OWN
CD THERE ISN'T HAVE YOU HAVEN'T
SEEN ANY PATIENT SAFETY ISSUES.
WITH WITHIN THE CONTACT STATE
DUE TO THE TO THE LC. NO NO WE
HAVE AN NORGES IN REGARDS TO A
CONTENDING EDUCATION PERIOD WE
HAVEN'T SEEN PATIENT SAFETY
ISSUES. GREAT SO I BY
APPRECIATE THAT- ESPECIALLY
ACTIVITIES I THINK YOU MAKE A
COMPELLING ARGUMENT I
CALIFORNIA SHOULD ENTERTAIN
ENTERING INTO THE L. C. AND I
HOPE MY COLLEAGUES WHICH WOULD
WOULD ALSO FIND ARGUMENTS
COMPELLING AS WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU A MEMBER
FONG ASSEMBLY. THANK YOU MISTER
CARE GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE WITH US TODAY I
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS-
REGARDING THE J. LACK AUDIT AND
THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS. WHAT IS
THE STATUS OF THE STATUS OF THE
G. LACK RECOMMENDATIONS AND ARE
ADDITIONAL STATUTORY CHANGES
NEEDED. ALSO HOW DOES THE B. R.
IN NOTIFY SCHOOLS THAT ARE WEEK
THAT WE'RE GOING TO LIMIT OR
STOP THEIR ABILITY TO ENROLL
STUDENTS. WHAT OPTIONS TO THE
SCHOOLS HAVE FOR APPEALS AND IS
LIMITING ENROLLMENT HAVE ANY
IMPACT ON THE STUDENT CURRENTLY
ATTENDING THAT SCHOOL. FOR LET
SOME IF- MISS MEL B. IS STILL
ON THE- VIDEO MAYBE- WILL TAKE
JUST THE DON'T GO ANYWHERE
MEMOS NEED TO ASK YOU SOME
QUESTIONS IN A BIT BUT MAYBE WE
CAN ASK MS MEL B. TO RESPOND TO
THOSE QUESTIONS ON THE ORDER OF
THE BOARD. I'M SORRY MR CHAIRED
AYE LEN AT THE WRONG JOKER
THAT'S FINE WE CAN WE'RE ALL OF
THIS IS ONE BIG. HAPPY FAMILY
YEARS SO YOU BEST CAN MOVE UP
AS MEL. B. TRY TO ANSWER THEM
THANK YOU. I WILL I'LL TRY TO
ANSWER- I JUST WANT
CLARIFICATION THE FIRST ONE IS
YOU WANTED TO KNOW WHAT WAS ON
THE G. LACK AUDIT
RECOMMENDATIONS WHERE WE WERE
ON THAT IS THAT CORRECT.
CORRECT AND THEN- WHAT HOW WE
NOTIFIED THE SCHOOLS THAT WERE
GONNA LIMIT OR STOP IN MOMENTS
CORRECT. AND THEN YOU ASKED
ABOUT AN APPEAL PROCESS IS THAT
CORRECT THAT IS CORRECT. THEY
THEY MISSED ANYTHING ABOUT ONE
LAST ONE DOES LIMITING
ENROLLMENT HAVE ANY IMPACT ON
THE STUDENT WHO IS CURRENTLY
ATTENDING. THAT SCHOOL. OKAY I
WILL ANSWER ALL FOR THOSE
THANK- A GROUP BE A ROLE MEANT
ONCE TOGETHER FIRST AND THEN
I'LL GOING TO THE GYM LACK ONE
WHICH IS. OVERSEES ALL OF THAT
SO LIMITING ENROLLMENT ON THE
CURRENT ISSUE STUDENTS HAS ONE
EFFECT- IF WE LIMIT IN ROMANCE
OR I WOULD WANT TO SEE LIVING
COSTS IF WE- MONITORING ROLEX
OF THE OTHER SCHOOLS IN THAT
REGION. IT HELPS ENSURE THAT
THAT STUDENT WHO IS ALREADY
ENROLLED CAN COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATION PROCESS AND COMPLETE
THE CLINICAL REQUIREMENTS OF
THAT EDUCATION PROCESS IT HAS A
POSITIVE EFFECT ON THAT
STUDENTS. THAT IS CURRENTLY
ENROLLED IT DOES NOT HAVE A
NEGATIVE EFFECT. THE NEXT
QUESTION IS HOW DO WE NOTIFY
OUR SCHOOLS IF WE'RE GOING TO
LIMIT OR STOP ENROLLMENT. WHEN
A SCHOOL HAS A COMPUTING
APPROVAL VISIT WHERE WE GO OUT
AS THE NEC'S AND THEY VERIFIED
THAT THE SCHOOL IS IN
COMPLIANCE WITH ALL RULES AND
REGULATIONS- THAT INFORMATION
IS BROUGHT TO THE BOARD. IF
THERE IS ANY TIME THAT THERE IS
A NON COMPLIANCE WITH THE
REGULATION THAT IS BROUGHT
FORTH TO THE BOARD IF IT IS
EGREGIOUS THE BOARD CAN MAKE A
DECISION TO DO TWO THINGS. THE
ONE THING THAT THEY CAN MAKE
THE DECISION IF THEY'RE NOT IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS TO DEFERRING
ACTION- BETTER- AG COMMON- STAG
DECISION THE BOARD MEMBERS
MAKE. IS DEFERRING ACTION AND
THAT ALLOWS THE SCHOOL TIME TO
BRING THEMSELVES BACK INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THAT REGULATION
IT DOES NOT AFFECT ENROLLMENT.
AND IT DOES NOT AFFECT- THE
CONTINUATION OF THAT SCHOOL. IF
THE BOARD SEES THAT THERE IS
SOMETHING THAT IS ANGRY JESS IF
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN
GOING ON WHERE THEY HAVE TO
STEP IN IS THERE A MATTER OF
PUBLIC PROTECTION BIG COULD
VOTE. TO- PUT THE SCHOOL ON A
WARNING STATUS AS PART OF THAT
MORNING STATUS THEY HAVE
CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS THEY PUT
OUT TO THE SCHOOL THEY CAN
REQUIRE. TO HALT ENROLLMENTS
BACON REQUIRED TO DECREASE THE
ENROLLMENT NUMBERS OR THEY CAN
DO NOTHING ABOUT ENROLLMENT AND
REQUIRE THEM TO COME IN AND
JUST CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
NEC AND PROVIDE PROGRESS
REPORTS TO. THE SCHOOL AND THEN
GIVE THEM A TIMELINE OF WHEN
THEY HAVE THIS COMPLETED BY-
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS AND THAT'S
THE ONLY WAY THAT THAT IS
COMMUNICATED IS THROUGH A BOARD
VOTE IT HAS TO BE UNANIMOUS
VOTE. AND THEN A BOARD ACTION
LETTER IS- SENT OUT THAT
DISCUSSES THAT BOAT IN THAT IS
NOTIFIED TO THE SCHOOLS. THE
SCHOOLS ARE PRESENT DURING ALL
OF THOSE DISCUSSIONS- AND
TYPICALLY IT'S NOT JUST THE
DEAN OR DIRECTOR OF ITS OVER
THE NURSING PROGRAM BUT THAT
PRESIDENT VICE PRESIDENT-
SOMETIMES- THE CHANCE OR
WHATEVER WILL SHOW UP AT THOSE
MEETINGS. AND- PROVIDE INPUT AS
WELL. I'M THE NEXT QUESTION WHY
DO WE HAVE AN APPEAL PROCESS.
WE DO NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL
APPEAL PROCESS. BUT WHAT WE DO
HAVE IS THAT EVERY EDUCATION
LICENSE COMMITTEE EVERY BOARD
MEETING THAT NURSING PROGRAM
CAN ASK THEIR NURSING EDUCATION
CONSULTANT TO BRING THEM FOR TO
THE BOARD- WE DO HAVE A SCHOOL
RIGHT NOW THAT'S ON WARNING
STATUS THEY DID JUST HAVE THEIR
ENROLLMENT- NUMBERS AFFECTED-
AND- THEY WILL BE COMING BACK.
TO THE NEXT EDUCATION LICENSE
COMMITTEE MEETING WHICH IS HELD
IN- JUNE. AND THEY WILL COME
BACK TO THE NEXT BOARD MEETING
IN AUGUST- SO THAT THEY CAN
SHOW WHERE THEY'RE AT AND
POTENTIALLY GET CHANGES- MADE-
BUT THATIS SOMETHING THAT THEY
CAN DO. WITHOUT AN APPEAL
PROCESS THEY CAN COME TO ANY E.
L. C. IN ANY BOARD MEETING AND
REQUEST TO BE REEVALUATED
ANYTIME SO THERE'S NO OFFICIAL
PROCESS NEEDED WE HAVE THAT
PROCESS OF COMMUNICATION AND
REQUEST. ALREADY VETTED INTO
OUR CURRENT PROCESSES. THE.
LAST ONE IS THE G. LIKE AUDIT.
THE G. LIKE AUDIT GAVE NOT
RECORD. FIVE OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED THERE ARE FOR THAT
ARE PENDING THOSE FOUR ARE
INTERRELATED- AND THAT IS WHERE
WE HAVE TO CREATE A DATA BANK-
THAT REQUIRES- SORRY COLLECTS
ALL OF THE CLINICAL PLACEMENT
DATA THAT OUR SCHOOLS ARE
USING- IT AND PUT THAT DATA
BANK INTO SOME KIND OF FORMAT
THAT CAN BE SHARED ON OUR
WEBSITE. AND THEN OBVIOUSLY-
THAT DATA TO AUSTIN YEAH. WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF THAT
WE'VE COLLECTED ALL OF THE
UPDATED FORMS FROM OUR SCHOOLS
WE ARE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE AND
PULL THE DATA FROM OSPINA- WE
HAVE GONE THROUGH THE TESTING
ENVIRONMENTS AND IT SHOULD BE
READY TO INPUT DATA AS SOON AS
NEXT WEEK- AND SO WE WILL HAVE
THAT OUT ONTO OUR WEBSITE- BY
THE OCTOBER DEADLINE. THAT IS
OUR GOAL. AND THEN THAT SHOULD
CLEAR UP THOSE FOUR REMAINING-
REQUIREMENTS REQUEST THAT THEY
HAVE BECAUSE- THEY'RE ALL
INTERRELATED AND BASED ON THAT
DATA BANK BE PUBLISHED. THANK
YOU A COUPLE QUICK FOLLOW UPS
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU. SO ON
THE DECREASE IN ENROLLMENT IF
THE BOARD VOTES TO DECREASE THE
ENROLLMENT THAT WOULD BE FUTURE
STUDENTS NOT CONSIDER CURRENTLY
ATTENDING. YES THAT'S CORRECT
OKAY AND SINCE THERE IS NO
OFFICIAL APPEAL PROCESS DOES
EVERY SCHOOL KNOW THAT THEY CAN
COME AND BE RE EVALUATED. YES
AND THEY ARE ANY SEIZE
COMMUNICATE WITH THAT ALREADY
SEES OUR SITE EACH SCHOOL ONE
ON ONE. AND I MEET WITH MY THE
NEC'S ON A WEEKLY BASIS AND
WILL GO OVER ANY OF THESE
DISCUSSIONS AND THEN THEY CAN
BRING THAT INFORMATION BACK TO
THE DEANS AND DIRECTORS THE
DEANS AND DIRECTORS ARE ALSO.
AVAILABLE TO YOU- COULD JUST
BEAT ANY OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEETINGS AND THEY HAVE WHAT WE
CALL A DIRECTOR'S HANDBOOK- IN
THAT DIRECTORS YOU CAN BOOK
ALSO TALKS ABOUT HOW YOU CAN
REQUEST YOU TO. GET FROM THERE
AND YOU SEE. TO ANY PART OF
THEIR SCHOOL. THE HELPFUL ONE
MY QUESTION IN THE AUDIT THERE
WERE SOME SERVICES THAT WERE
CONSIDERED DUPLICATIVE. AND CAN
ANY OF THESE DUPLICATIVE
SERVICES BE REDUCED. YES YEAH-
THE ONE THING THAT IT TALKED
ABOUT WAS LOOKING AT
ACCREDITATION VERSES APPROVAL-
NCSP AND IS ON THE LINE THIS IS
THE PANEL SAYS SHE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO ANSWER THIS- BUT NCSP
AND REQUIRES ALL OF THE SCHOOLS
STUDENTS THAT WILL SIT FOR THE
ENTRANCE EXAM TO COME FROM
ABORTED HER SCHOOL. SO THE
APPROVAL PROCESS HAS TO REMAIN
BUT WE NEED TO SEE HOW COME.
WORK BETTER WITH ARE CREDITING
THE CHECK OFF- BODIES AND SO
THERE'S TWO MAIN ACCREDITING
BODIES IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S THE
A. C. E. N. M. C. C. M. E. AND
ABOUT 50% OF OUR SCHOOLS HAVE
THAT ACCREDITATION- THE OTHER
50% DO NOT AND THAT MOST OF
THOSE THAT ARE ACCREDITED RBS
AND PROGRAMS AND NOT OUR ATM
PROGRAMS- BUT IN THAT PROCESS.
BE HAVE- EIGHT CONTINUING
APPROVAL. I HAVE ESTABLISHED A
WORKGROUP WITH FOUR DEANS AND-DIRECTORS AND MYSELF AND MY
CHIEF OF LICENSING WHO OVERSEES
OUR NEC'S. AND WHAT WE'VE DONE
IS MET EVERY OTHER WEEK AND
WE'RE DOING OUR VERY FIRST
COMBINE B. R. IN APPROVAL AND
ACCREDITATION VISIT THIS FALL I
BELIEVE IS SCHEDULED FOR AUGUST
AND IT WILL BE AT SAN DIEGO
CITY SCHOOL ALL THE COLLEGES
DOWN IN SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA.
AND SO WE'LL SEE HOW THIS GOES
WE WILL SUBMIT ONE REPORT IT
WILL NOT BE A DUPLICATED
PRODUCT REPORT TO CATCH YOU
COULD BE OUR AND- IN ANY ITEMS
THAT THAT DOESN'T ANSWER WITHIN
THEIR CREDIT D. SAN REPORTS-
BILL HAVE EIGHTY ADDENDUM THAT
THEY WILL USE TO ANSWER B. R.
AT. AS WELL ON THE NCSP AND
WEBSITE THERE'S A LOT OF
INFORMATION ON HOW TO CONDUCT
THESE VISITS IN A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY- AND WHO FOCUSES
ON WHAT AND WHICH ONE AND WE
HAVE THAT UP I HAVE THAT TOOL
BOX AND I AM UTILIZING IT. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT ARE DUE TO
DIRECTORS COMPLAIN ABOUT IS ON
THE FACULTY APPROVAL AND SO
LIKE I SAID WHEN I LOOKED
WORKING ON GETTING BACK
DATABASE HOW IS IT WOULD
REQUIRE A ONE TIME FACULTY
APPROVAL VERY MUCH LIKE A
TEACHING CREDENTIAL- AND WITH
THAT TEACHING CREDENTIAL YOU
CAN KIND OF GO ANYWHERE YOU
WANT YOU DON'T NEED TO BE RE
APPROVED FREE SCHOOL. AND SO
THAT'S WHAT WE PLAN TO DO WITH
THE B. R. READ IS TO PROVE THE
FACULTY MEMBER ONCE I'VE BEEN
OUR DATA BANK AND ESSENTIALLY
THEY WOULD HAVE A TEACHING
CREDENTIAL TO TEACH NURSING-
AND THAT CAN GO FROM SCHOOL TO
SCHOOL NOT REQUIRE RE APPROVAL
WOULD JUST BE THE INITIAL
APPROVAL. AND IT'S JUST LIKE A
TEACHING CREDENTIAL. THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE A SINGLE SUBJECT
TEACHING CREDENTIAL OR MULTIPLE
SUBJECT TEACHING CREDENTIAL
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD
DO IS THE BOARD TO IS WE HAVE
FIVE SPECIALTY AREAS OF
NURSING. AND IF YOU WANT TO
TEACH IN MORE THAN ONE IN
VERSUS A SINGLE SUBJECT FOR
SOME MULTI SUBJECT TEACHING
CREDENTIAL WE CAN APPROVE IT
FOR MULTIPLE AREAS HAVE THAT ON
OUR WEBSITE THAT YOU GUYS CAN
ACCESS AND. IT WOULD BE VERY
MUCH LIKE GETTING A TEACHING
CREDENTIAL WITH THE SINGLE. OR
MULTIPLE SUBJECT. SO WE'LL
FOLLOW SUIT WITH THE EDUCATION.
WITH WILL BE THANK YOU SO MUCH-YOUR THREE AND THOROUGH AND OF
THE IT THAT MUCH APPRECIATED
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU AND- AS WELL WE
THANK YOU FOR A FEELING OF
FLYBALLS- LET'S RETURN TO-
NURSE LICENSURE COMPACT SO LET
ME JUST ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS
UNLESS I WILL I WILL POINT OUT
TO MY COLLEAGUES REMEMBER WE
HAVE THREE MORE PANELS. PLUS
PUBLIC COMMENT WE ARE HAVE WE
HAVE NO IT OF NEXT WE HAVE
NURSING WORKFORCE SUPPLY FOR
THE OF YOU WHO HAVEN'T SEEN THE
AND WE HAVE AT PLACED SO- WE
MAY WANT TO SORT OF SLIDE OR
CLOSE IN WITH THE PANELS IS THE-
AS- APPEAR PROPRIA. WITH CHRIS
TO NURSE LICENSURE. AS FAR HOPE
YOU'RE STILL THERE. I AM. LET
ME JUST ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS
THAT WITH THE. NURSING LICENSE
COMPACTS WHILE. IF. IS THAT IS
THAT IN FACT A RESTRICTION AND
IF SO IS THE RESTRICTION THAT
CAN BE ADJUSTED. YES THAT IS
THAT IS A REQUIREMENT THERE ARE
A LOT OF IN LICENSURE
REQUIREMENTS THAT A NURSE MUST
MEET BEFORE SHE COULD BE
ISSUED. A COMPACT LICENSE AND
THAT WOULD BE IN ADDITION TO
WHATEVER IS REQUIRED FROM THE
STATE THAT SHE'S APPLYING FOR
LICENSURE AND- ONE OF WHICH IS
A SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER AND-
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE MOST OF
THE THINGS NOT EVERYTHING BUT
MOST OF THE COMPONENTS OF THE
COMPACT- CANNOT BE CHANGE.
BECAUSE THAT CONTACTED US
ESSENTIALLY A CONTRACT THAT ALL
THE STATES ARE JOINING
TOGETHER. SO STATES CAN
UNILATERALLY DECIDE WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO KIND OF TAKE
OUT AND YOU KNOW OR ADD AN
ADDITIONAL BECAUSE EVERYONE HAS
TO BE OPERATING UNDER THE SAME
RULES. I'M SO FOR IT SO SINCE
THE SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
REQUIREMENT IS IN SPECIFICALLY
IN THE STATUTE- THAT WOULD NOT
BE SOMETHING THAT COULD BE
CHANGED TO UNILATERALLY BY
CALIFORNIA. ONE OF THE THINGS
CERTAINLY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT AROUND HERE IS.
WHAT ASPECT OF OUR POPULATION
OF THE NURSES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ARE OPERATING WITH
AYE TENS AS OPPOSED TO
SOMETHING ELSE TO DETERMINE-
WHAT PORTION OF OUR NURSE
POPULATION WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF PARTICIPATE IN
THIS NURSE COMPACT. AS OPPOSED
TO THE POPULATION PERCENTAGE
THAT WILL NOT LET ME ASK
ANOTHER QUESTION I WANT TO MAKE
SURE I'M CLEAR ON THIS THE
BACKGROUND PAPER THAT WE WERE
PROVIDED. CONTAINS A STATEMENT
THAT THE MULTI STATE LICENSES
ISSUED IN THE STATE WHERE THE
REGISTERED NURSE OR LICENSED
VOCATIONAL NURSE LEGAL GROUP
LEGALLY RESIDES NOT IN THE
STATE WHERE THEY WANT TO
PRACTICE. SO FOR EXAMPLE- UNDER
THE NURSE COMPACT- A- WHITENERS
LICENSED IN THE STATE OF NEVADA
WOULD HAVE A MULTI STATE
LICENSE AND COULD COME TO
CALIFORNIA TO PERFORM WORK.
ORDER FOR A NURSE INSTEAD OF
COMING TO CALIFORNIA TO PERFORM
WORK FOR THREE MONTHS OR FOUR
MONTHS OR FIVE MONTHS ON
ACCOUNT OF A NATURAL DISASTER
OR SOME OTHER I WORKFORCE NEED
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
NURSE DECIDED THAT DECIDES TO
MOVE HIS HER OR THEIR FAMILY-
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WOULD THAT REQUIRE THEN THAT
NURSE TO OBTAIN LICENSURE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA UNDER
THE NURSE COMPACT. YEAH CORRECT
WIDE. AGAIN SIMILAR TO WHEN YOU
CHANGE YOUR RESIDENCE AND YOU
MOVE TO A NEW STATE YOU NEED A
NEW DRIVERS LICENSE. IT'S THAT
SAME PRINCIPLE- SO. YOU CAN
CONTINUE PRACTICING UNDER YOUR
CONTACT LICENSES WHILE YOU
APPLY AND GET THAT NEW STATE
ISSUED LICENSE BECAUSE YOU KNOW
UNDER YOUR- OUR PREVIOUS
LICENSE YOU HAVE THE PRIVILEGE
OF PRACTICE CONTINUE PRACTICING
IN CALIFORNIA BUT THE- YOU
MIGHT YES YOU MUST APPLY AND
GET A NEW LICENSE AND- THAT'S
WHERE YOU NOW RESIDE. SO IT
WOULD EASE THE PROCESS AND THAT
THE NURSE COULD CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE SERVICES AS
THE CALIFORNIA LICENSING
PROCESS- TAKES ITS COURSE.
CORRECT AND FOR THOSE SO I KNOW
THE MILITARY COMMUNITY IS VERY-
ANXIOUS TO SEE CALIFORNIA
EXPLORE THIS NURSE COMPACT-
ISSUE FOR THOSE- NURSES THEY
THEIR LEGAL RESIDENCE DOESN'T
CHANGE IF THEY MOVE FROM SIDE
TO SIDE FROM STATE TO STATE
PURSUANT TO MILITARY ORDERS SO
THE NURSE CONTACT WOULD PROVIDE
A CONTINUING AUTHORIZATION TO
PERFORM NURSING SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA DURING THE PERIOD OF
TIME THAT THE- I PRESUME THE
NURSE OR THE FILES OF THE
NURSES ASSIGNED HERE. THAT THAT
IS CORRECT. AFTER. OKAY MEMBERS
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. I SEE NONE MISFORTUNE
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR THOROUGH RESPONSES. THANK
YOU OUR NEXT PANEL WILL FOCUS
ON NURSING EDUCATION APPROVAL
WE WILL HEAR FROM CAN MARLBORO
VICE PRESIDENT FOR THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING AND MISS MEL
B. RETURNS TO US AND AGAIN MISS
FUTCH YOU'RE GOING TO BE HERE
WITH US THE NATIONAL COUNCIL OF
STATE BOARDS OF NURSING. PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON IT'S A
GOOD TO BE HERE. BOB FINALLY
WHAT HE WAS DOING IT MARLBORO
AND I WAS APPOINTED TO THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING BY
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE AS A
PUBLIC MEMBER BACK IN APRIL OF
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. I WAS
ALSO ELECTED A VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE BOARD IN JUNE OF THIS
PAST JUNE- AND I CURRENTLY
SERVE WHEN YOU EDUCATION AND
LICENSED COMMITTEE AND I'M
HONORED TO BE HERE TOO. SO I
HAVE A LITTLE BIT INFORMATION
OF SHORT BACKGROUND ABOUT WHAT
THE EDUCATION LICENSE COMMITTEE
DOES SOME OF HIS INFORMATION
HAS ALREADY BEEN MENTIONED
BECAUSE OF THE. YES QUESTIONS
TO. BUT I'LL TRY TO GO THROUGH
THIS FOR QUICKLY. SAUDITA LAST
COMMITTEE THE L. C. S. WE CALL
IT IS A NON STATUTORY COMMITTEE
WHICH THE ADVISES THE BOARD ON
MATTERS RELATED TO NURSING
EDUCATION. APPROVAL OF PRE
LICENSURE PROGRAMS. ADVANCE
PRACTICE NURSING PROGRAMS THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL LICENSURE
EXAMINATION OF REGISTERED
NURSES NO ONE ELSE CAN
COLLAPSE. ANY AND ALL SCHOOL
STATE ANNUAL SCHOOL SURVEY DATA
AND REPORTS ALSO LICENSE UNIT
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES AND OF
COURSE CONTINUING EDUCATION.
THERE'S THREE TYPES OF PRE
LICENSURE NURSING PROGRAM. THE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE PROGRAMS AND A
BACCALAUREATE DEGREE PROGRAMS
AND ALSO ENTRY LEVEL MASTER'S
DEGREE PROGRAMS CURRENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE NINETY ONE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE PROGRAMS AND
FORTY SIX. BACCALAUREATE DEGREE
PROGRAMS AND TWELVE ENTRY LEVEL
MASTER'S DEGREE PROGRAMS THAT
YOU CAN FIND ALL THAT
INFORMATION ON OUR WEBSITE AS
WELL. SO JUST A LITTLE
BACKGROUND ON HOW BILLS OF
PEOPLE'S FREE LICENSE PROCESS
WORK FIRST AND FOREMOST A PRE
LICENSURE NURSING PROGRAM WAS
FIRST. LETTER OKAY. AND THEN
THE REQUIRED SPEED TO THE B. R.
YEAH. THE NEXT STEP IS FOR
LOCALS PRE LICENSURE NURSING
PROGRAM TO COMPETE A
FEASIBILITY STUDY WHICH MARKS
MUST BE APPROVED. BY THE BOARD
OVERALL. THE FEASIBILITY STUDY
DOCUMENTS THE NEED FOR THE
PROGRAM AND THE PROGRAM
APPLICANTS BILITY TO DEVELOP
IMPLEMENT SUSTAIN. A VIABLE
LICENSORS REGISTERED NURSING
PROGRAM. IT JUST SOME FACTS ON
THAT YEAH THIS YEAR WE SAW CRAB
ACCEPTED BY. THE STUDY'S BEEN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE ACCEPTED TO
AND TWENTY NINETEEN WEEK.
SEPARATELY WAS WELL. SO NEXT
STEP IS APPROVAL. USED IN THE
APPROVAL. IS THAT THIS. BUT TO
BE OUR IN SELF STUDY. I KNOW
AND COMES KNOWN AS UNIONS ARE
ANY C. WORK FOR TO BE INTERESTS
FIVE IS THE LATEST ON WITH THE
BOARD AND THE FOOTBALL THREE
LICENSE OR NURSING. ONE DID YOU
SEE VERY THE SELF STATUS.
ADDRESSES THAT THAT IS NOT A
STARK ADDRESS. RULES AND- IN
THE STATE THEN PER THE- PROGRAM
TO EAGLE SPEAKER. ADD TO THE
BOOK OF THE B. BOARD MEETING.
BOB SO- THE BOARD GRAN- OF NEW
LICENSE PROGRAMS TO START I'M
SORRY I MISSED WHEN THE STATE
THAT. SO WE WOULD HAVE YEAH WE
HAVE A STUDENTS ON BOARD IT'S
IN THE WEBSITE AS WELL BUT I
ALSO WANT TO LET YOU KNOW WE
ALSO DO- IN ROME INCREASES SO
JUST TO GIVE YOU SOME FACTS WE
HAVE INCREASED IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. SEVENTY ROLE IN ROLEX.
SEVEN I'M SORRY SEVEN ROMAN
CREASES INTO NINETEEN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND FOUR IN A
ROW INCREASES IN TWENTY TWENTY
AND JUST SO FAR THIS YEAR
REVIVED APPROVES SIX ROLAND
CREASES. THAT IS WHY REPORT I
AM HAPPY TO BE HERE TO ANSWER
SOME QUESTIONS BUT I WILL BE
HONEST WITH YOU I'M GOING TO
USE OUR EXECUTIVE OFFICER
LORETTA MILBY FOR MAJORITY. OF
THOSE QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. ANY OTHER CAR
ROOM- THIS FORTY SEVEN A COMMA.
BUT I DON'T HAVE ANY SPECIFIC I
JUST- WANTED TO BE HERE TO HELP
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT MIGHT
BE MORE FROM MORE OF A NATIONAL
PERSPECTIVE. GROWING CITY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
I THINK YOU HAVE A I THINK YOU
WILL ANSWERED THEM DURING THE-
HER QUESTIONS THAT WERE RAISED
IN OTHER PORTIONS OF THE
PROGRAM SO. I SEE NO QUESTIONS-
THEN LET'S- SO THANK YOU.
PERHAPS SOMEBODY WILL THINK OF
ONE AS WE GO ALONG SO IF YOU
ALL CAN STAY WITH US THAT WOULD
BE GREAT. YOU HAVE TO DO LET'S
NOW DISCUSS NURSING WORKFORCE
AND SUPPLY. JOINING US IS GARY
CHAN PRESIDENT CEO OF HEALTH
IMPACT B. J. BURLESON VICE
PRESIDENT NURSING AND CLINICAL
SERVICES. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION. AND AB
BLOOMBERG DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES. PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
MISTER CHAIR YES EUROPE THANK
YOU. TRYING TO TURN MY VOLUME
DOWN SO CHAIR ROTH SURE LOW AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY. PLEASE GUARD CHAD AND I
AM THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
HEALTH IMPACT WHICH IS THE
CALIFORNIA NURSING WORKFORCE
AND POLICY CENTER. I AM ALSO
CURRENTLY IN PRACTICE AS A
NURSE PRACTITIONER AND HAVE
BEEN SEEN PATIENTS AND WORKING
IN OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH. DURING
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. I
HAVE ALSO BEEN ADMINISTERING
KOBE NINETEEN VACCINES TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. AND IT'S AN HONOR TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PANEL WITH
MY DISTINGUISHED COLLEAGUES
TODAY. SO I WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT- THE PERCEIVED OR REAL
NURSING SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO REPORT FIRST PROJECTIONS
FOCUS ON SUPPLY AND DEMAND
SUPPLY IS EASIER TO UNDERSTAND
THE NUMBER OF GRADUATES
ENTERING THE WORKFORCE THE
NUMBER OF NURSES ENDORSING FROM
OUT OF STATE STATE AND THE
NUMBER OF RETIREES OR PEOPLE
LEAVING THE STATE. BUT WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT THE NURSING
SHORTAGE WE ALSO THINK ABOUT
THE DEMANDS. AND DEMAND ON THE
OTHER HAND IS MUCH HARDER. IF
WE LOOK AT THE MAN'S FACTORS
SUCH AS THE PARK PERCENT
OCCUPANCY OF ACUTE CARE
INSTITUTIONS REVENUE AND
REIMBURSEMENT TO PAY FOR THE
WORK FORCE AND RATIOS PLAN
IMPORTANT PART IN DETERMINING
THE DEMAND FOR WORKFORCE. WE
KNOW THAT THEIR REGIONAL
SHORTAGE OF NURSES AND THE
SEVERITY OF THE SHORTAGE
DEPENDS ON THE METHODOLOGY OF
CALCULATING SUPPLYING DEMANDS.
BOTH UCSF WORKFORCE CENTER AND
ALSO HAD PROJECTIONS ILLUSTRATE
REGIONAL SHORTAGES DESPITE
DIFFERENCES IN METHODOLOGIES.
AS AN EXAMPLE WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE US HAD TO BALANCE THIS FROM
LAST YEAR SOME OF THE MARKETS
THE LISTS ARE VERY SMALL AND WE
KNOW THAT NURSES OFTEN COMMUTE
ACROSS CITIES AND COUNTIES. AND
THAT IS REALLY SPECIFIC AND
THEY DID A GREAT JOB. TRYING
TO. ANALYZE SENT FORTY MILLION
NUMBER OF. EIGHT THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED AND AREAS- THE OSHKOSH
METHOD ASSUMES HOWEVER THAT THE
CORRECT LEVEL MAN'S IS THE
NATIONAL TWENTY FIFTH
PERCENTILE WHICH IS THE LEVEL
OF DEPLOYMENTS WE'VE EVER HAD
IN CALIFORNIA. WE DON'T KNOW IF
EMPLOYERS REALLY WANT OR NEED
THAT NUMBER OF NURSES TO MEET
THE CARE NEEDS OF OUR
POPULATION. SO IN SUMMARY ABOUT
THE STATE WIDE OPEN REGIONAL
UNDERSINK SHORTAGE WE DO HAVE
NURSING SHORTAGES THAT ARE
REGIONAL- AND THAT IN SOME
PLACES ARE PRETTY SIGNIFICANT.
I ALSO WANTED. I TEND TO BUY
SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES THAT
WERE RAISED TODAY- AND TALK
ABOUT HOW YOUR RENDON AS IT
RELATES TO WORKFORCE. SO IN MY
OPINION THE R. AND PLAYS A ROLE
IN THREE DISTINCT AREAS.
LICENSING YOU GRADUATE NURSE
VERSES AND ARCING INTO
CALIFORNIA. PROVIDING JANAK
REPORTS AND THREE BURSTING
EDUCATION PROGRAM A COUPLE
OFFICES. SO AS PREVIOUSLY
DISCUSSED AROUND LICENSING WE
DID NOTE THAT IN THE NOVEMBER
EIGHTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY B. R.
AND NEEDING THE BEER AND
REPORTED ON THE AVERAGE
PROCESSING TIMES SIX IN TERMS
OF THE TIME THAT THEY SEE THE
APPLICATION TO MOVING THE
APPLICATION ON TO ITS NEXT STOP.
WE SAW A DECREASE THE FIRST FOR
EXAMINING YOUR SMITH PROCESSING
TIMES AND STILL HERE NINETEEN
AND FISCAL YEAR TWENTY- IT WENT
FROM FOR EXAMS IT WENT DOWN
FROM SIXTY FOUR POINT SIXTEEN
TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SCHOOL YEAR. DOWN TO
NINE POINT FOUR DAYS FOR EXAMS
IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN YEAR. AND FOUR DOOR
SEDAN IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN YEAR IT WAS
SIXTY POINT TWO DAYS. AND IT
WENT DOWN TO EIGHTEEN POINT
FOUR DAYS IN THE TWENTY WORKING
NINE TO SCHOOL YEAR- AS OF.
TODAY OR AS OF THE REPORT IN
NOVEMBER HE DIDN'T SEE AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF DAYS
FOR EXAMS SUDDENLY FROM- FROM
THA POINT FOR UC'S TWENTY SIX.
AND FORTY FOUR CENTS FROM
EIGHTEEN POINT FOUR INTO TEAM
SIXTY FOUR DAYS. IN THE.
202-020-2020 TWENTY ONE FISCAL
YEAR. SO EXOTIC EXECUTIVE
OFFICER MEL B. DEVOTED APPS
WEEK YOU KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SOME LIVE SCOTT PROSTATE
ISSUES- AND WHAT IT CALLS THEM
DELAY. WE WOULD ASK YOU AROUND-
CREATE A PROCESS FLOW MAP
IDENTIFY AREAS FOR IMPROVEMENT
TO CONTINUE. A REDUCTION IN
LICENSING TIMES. ALSO WE DON'T
HAVE THE- ALEX IN RECORDS.
ABOUT THE MEAN MEDIAN AND
STANDARD DEVIATIONS ABOUT TOTAL
PROCESSING TIMES OF LICENSES
EXAMINING YOUR STUDENTS KNOW WE
WOULD. ENCOURAGE THE PARENTS TO
CONSIDER- DOING SOME
STATISTICAL ANALYSES ON THOSE-
PROCESSING TIME SO THAT WE CAN
FIGURE OUT WAYS TO REDUCE THE
DELAY. IN TERMS OF THE- WHAT'S
THE B. R. AND HAS A STRONG
HISTORY OF CONDUCTING PERIODIC
SAMPLE SURVEYS OF THE NURSING
WORKFORCE ON A VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THEIR WORK IN THIS
AREA- WE'RE WAITING FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY SURVEY DATA
BECAUSE THERE WAS A DELAY DUE
TO. A BAD IS COMPLETE LINE OF
THE UNDERSTAND OF ALL. AND SO
WHEN WE SEE THE RELEASE REPORT
WE CAN THEN START INTERPRETING
THE DATA- WE DO NEED A MORE
ROBUST MINIMUM DATA SET UP ALL
LICENSE USED TO UNDERSTAND THE
RACIAL AND ETHNIC MAKEUP OF THE
PROFESSION. AS WELL AS
UNDERSTANDING ZIP CODE
SOMEWHERE LICENSEES LIVE AND
WHERE THEY WORK. AND THEN THE
THIRD AREA OF THE EDUCATIONAL
CRUCIAL PROCESSES WHICH HAS
BEEN ROBUSTLY DISCUSSED IN THE-
HEARING TODAY- THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMPROVEMENT.
OF IN THE PRE LICENSURE PROGRAM
APPROVAL STATUTES AND
REGULATIONS AND- AT HEALTH
IMPACT WE SUPPORT THE REDUCTION
OF DUPLICATIVE ADMINISTRATIVE
OVERSIGHT ODDS SICKENING THAT
ADDS. LAYS THE PROCESS YOU
WHERE THE B. R. AND OTHER
NATIONAL AGENCIES ARE OVER
OVERLY DUPLICATIVE AND SURELY
CAN BE STREAMLINED WHILE
MAINTAINING HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS THAT
STUDENTS CAN BE CONFIDENT ABOUT
A TEN DAY AND- NIGHT THANK. YOU
SIR MELBY. FOR SOME OF OUR
PILOT WORK IN THIS AREA. MANY
COMMUNITY AGENCIES AND
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING HEALTH
IMPACT ARE WORKING ON ISSUES
SUCH AS FACULTY ELEMENT
INCREASE THE NUMBER. HELP
SCHOOLS AND THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY
DISCUSSED HEARING. AND I WANT
TO THANK CHAIR ROTH ENSURE LOW
AND THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. THE
CHEN BEFORE I'D TURN IT OVER TO
THE NEXT THE PANELISTS TO SORT
OF UNUSUAL BUT LET ME JUST ASK
A QUESTION MAYBE YOU REFERENCE
THIS. UP WHAT IMPACT ARE YOU
ABLE TO ASSESS THE IMPACT OF
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC ON
OUR NURSING WORKFORCE MOVING
INTO THE FUTURE. IN OTHER
WORDS. INCREASED RETIREMENTS
SEPARATION FROM THE CAREER
FIELD IT'S CENTER OR IS IT TOO
EARLY TO TELL. IT'S A BIT TOO
EARLY TO TELL AND THE OTHER-
CONSIDERATION WITHOUT A MINIMUM
DATA SITES. AROUND WHAT'S-
STATUSES OF WORK WORK
INDIVIDUALS IT'S HARD TO TELL-
WE ALSO KNEW THAT THERE ARE
PERIODIC OR TEMPORARY ISSUES
THAT. HAVE COME INTO PLAY LIKE
BOOKING LEAVES OF ABSENCES
WHICH SCREAM SOMEBODY FROM THE
WORK FORCE THAT IS FEDERALLY
PROTECTED UNDER LAW. AND SO YES
WELL THAT VACANCY IS NOT
OFFICIAL THE OFFICIAL. OFFICIAL
VACANCY. IN THE HEALTH CARE AND
THAT AT WORK. A DECREASE IN THE
AVAILABLE WORKFORCE AND SO-
IT'S REALLY TOO EARLY TO TELL
AND MANY PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS NATIONALLY ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
GATHER THE DATA SO THAT WE CAN
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT OF COVER
NINETEEN ON THE WORK FORCE AND
I. WONDER IF- BJ BOTTLES OF THE
MACALLAN HOSPITALS IS PATIENT
AND ON THE OTHER STATES MIGHT
HAVE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
WELL THANK YOU FOR TAKING A
SWING AT THAT WITH THAT LET'S
TURN IT OVER TO THE NEXT
PANELISTS- JUST BROKE. YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIRMAN ON CHAIRMAN
ROSTAND'S COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
CSKA FOR SIXTY OUR TEACHERS
PRESENTS ON THIS EXTREMELY
CRITICAL ARE IN WORK FORCE
ISSUE. I WAS ASKED TO TALK
ABOUT- THREE THINGS AND I'M
GOING TO GIVE YOU MORE HIGH
LEVEL INFORMATION AND- THERE IS
A- FULL DETAILED INFORMATION IN
A LETTER I WROTE TO THOSE
COMMITTEES ON APRIL TWELFTH- SO
THE FIRST TIME THAT TO TARGET.
WAS WHY IS THERE NURSING
WORKFORCES HOSPITALS. AS YOU
MOST OF THE MOST OF YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS THE
STATION REPRESENTS OVER FOUR
HUNDRED WORLD URBAN SUBURBAN
PUBLIC NONPROFIT AND INVESTOR
OWNED FACILITIES WHERE OVER 60%
OR APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIA'S
FLOYD ARE AND WORK. RN'S THE
OPERATIONAL LIFELINE IN ACUTE
CARE FACILITY AND HOSPITALS AND
HEALTH SYSTEMS RELY ON THEM TO
MEET THE EVER CHANGING NEEDS
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. AND YOU
ALL KNOW THIS WAS CLEARLY
DEMONSTRATED LAST YEAR SINCE
THE PANDEMIC. AND IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT THE ACCURATE
NUMBERS IS STILL MAKES IT FAR
AND STASHING IS MAINTAINED SO
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE QUALITY
ACCESS PATIENT SAFETY. TWENTY
FOUR HOURS A DAY SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK. EVERY HEALTH CARE OR- IS
THERE. SO YOU HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT ALL THE DIVERSITY AMONG
STAR ORGANIZATIONS AND NURSES
THAT MUST CAREFULLY EVALUATE
COMPLEXITIES. AND NEEDS OF
THOSE PATIENT POPULATIONS AND
STRIVE TO EXECUTE AN
APPROPRIATE ARE AND WORK FORCE.
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION
MULTIPLE THINGS ARE IN STAFFING
RATIOS ARE IN SKILL NEXT
PATIENT ACUITY HOSPITAL SERVICE
LINES ECONOMIC FACTORS ETCETERA.
ZIJIN ARE AND STAFFING ISSUES
CALL EDUCATION CARE REDUCES
ERRORS REDUCE PATIENT MORTALITY
MORBIDITY AND NUMBER OF
PREVENTABLE ON SORT OF DANCE.
SO WHY IS THE PRECISE
COMPOSITION OF THE R. AND
WORKFORCE PORTANTINO. OUR AND
CARE MUST BE MATCHED TO PATIENT
NEEDS AND ARE IS THAT THE LIVER
CARE VERY AND EXPERTISE AND
THEIR SCOPE OF PRACTICE YOU
LOCKED IN HERE IS TALKING ABOUT
NOVICE AND EXPERT R&D FOR NEW
NURSES AND SPECIALTY OR EXPERT
NURSES AND THERE THERE IS ALL
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE THERE AND
HAVING THE RIGHT COMPOSITION.
OF THOSE NEW OR NOVICE TO
EXPERT NURSES IS IMPORTANT SO
THAT PATIENTS CAN BE PROVIDED
THE RIGHT CARE AT THE RIGHT
TIME FOR THE RIGHT AROUND AND
TEACHING ORIENTATION OF NEW
GRADUATES BE ACCOMPLISHED. OF
HOSPITALS NURSING WORKFORCE
NEEDS TO BE CONFIDENCE TO MEET
STAFFING RATIOS COMEDY HAJNAL
ACUTE INPATIENT CARE DEMANDS
WORKS- CAN'T ACCES ASTERS AS
WE'VE SEEN AND MEDICINE
MEDICATION REQUIREMENTS AS WELL
AS ONLINE SCHEDULING NEEDS OF A.
DYNAMIC- AND WORK FORCE. WITH
THE WIND. OF CALIFORNIA NURSING
WORK FOR HEADING WEST THAN FIVE
YEARS NURSING. IT A HERITAGE
THE NEW YORK. TO THE PERSON.
YOUR FIRST. ASIAN EXPERT HELPED
THEIR SKILLS MAINTAINERS
WORKFORCE WILDERNESS HI. AND
THIS IS AS WHY HOSPITALS
CLINICAL PLACE RAINING SLAPS
AND THEIR AVAILABILITY HIRING
PRACTICES DICTATED. AND LEVEL
OF IRAN'S THAT INDIVIDUAL.
HOSPITALS TENANTS COMEDY. AND I
ONE OF TO WORK ON FLORIDA'S
COMMON ABOUT SPACE WE DO OFFER
CLIENTS PLACEMENT MEDICINE TO
THE IRAN IT'S NOT A REGULATION
BUT THAT IS A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT ALL THAT STARTED ON
BEHALF OF THE ARE IN. THE
HOSPITAL SALAS. I STILL NEED TO
HAVE A SUBTLE PIPELINE OF NEW.
AND X. ARE A STUFF A CALL STYLE
RATIO REQUIRE. MAINTAIN THEY-
HE THEY ARE ASKED ME A VITAL
SOURCE OF EXPERIENCE ARE AND
WORK FORCE OUT OF STATERS
NURSE- BUT JUST. YOUR SECRET IS
EXTREMELY CRITICAL SUPPORTING
OUR RURAL AND CRITICAL ACCESS
HOSPITALS AND THIS IS THE
PRODUCT DURING THAT PANEL
DISCUSSIONS HERE WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT A WRONG
CRITICAL ACCESS HOSPITALS. AND
HER ABILITY TO NURSES. TO THAT
YES AND AS MANY OF OUR HEALTH
SYSTEMS GROWN EXPAND ACROSS
STATE BOUNDARIES MULTI STATE
LICENSURE IS BECOMING- MORE
CRITICAL EASIER THIS PROCESS IS
THE TIME HONOR TIMELIER WE CAN
PROVIDE ACCESS TO CARE QUALITY
CARE FOR PATIENTS. SO WITHOUT
AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY OF OUR MEN'S
HOSPITALS CANNOT STAFF THAT IS
FOR CARE OF PATIENTS AND. I
THINK ZERO. TRYING TO MEET
EARNED IT. THAT IS GOING. A
DOUBLING OF OUR AND WE TRY
BETWEEN THE AGES FIFTY IT'S
FOUR CENTS THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
MORE RACK YOUR PLEASE HANG OUR
X. R&S. ALSO WERE AT NEW S. T.
Y. ESTá MEANT THAT THE STATE
OR INSPIRED WILL BE SIXTY DOT
ARE IN SLOW. PROJECTED THOUSAND
NINETEEN THAT'S WHEN THE HEALTH
WORKFORCE CENTER- DOCTORS YES.
UNDER THE OLD WE CAN NOT AFFORD
SIGNIFICANT DELAYS WITH
REGULATORY LICENSING PROCESS
PARTICULARLY WITHOUT A STATE.
PERSONNEL RESOURCE FOR H. AND
WORLD. AREAS SILICON WHAT'S
NEEDS TO. BEFORE OUR TO DO. BOB
PRISON HOSPITAL BEDSIDE
STAFFING IS DEPENDENT ON A
REGULATORY BODY IS NATURAL AND
PROACTIVE IN KEEPING A NURSING
SUPPLY PIPELINE CRIMES OR
TIMELY LICENSING. AFFECTED
DISCIPLINARY INTERVENTION.
REGULATORY REFINEMENT. SOME OF
OUR RECORDS WOULD BE OUR OR TO
REDUCE ON FUNCTIONS AND
MANAGEMENT ACTIVITIES FULLY
FOCUSED ON THOSE THREE
COMPONENTS OF A REGULATORY
BOARD. AND THIS WOULD INCLUDE
SUCH THINGS AS RANDY HEARING
OUTDATED PROCESSES INCREASING
USE OF TECHNOLOGY IN GOVERNANCE
WHICH CAMERA IS WORKING ON THE
BORDER YEAH EXAMPLES. TODAY AND
BREEZES. SOME OTHER EXAM
REMOVING US AND DUPLICATIVE IN
THE ACADEMIC SCHOOL APPROVAL
PROCESS AND NOT SPENT DISCUSS
ALL ON THE FIRST OF A- AND SHOW
HIM THAT LATER- REMOVING ISSUES
WITH WORKFORCE PLANNING. WE
HAVE EXPERTS ACROSS THE STATE
IT'S METHOD GARRETT HE IS AN
EXPERT IN NURSING FROM HEALTH
HELP FOR- HEALTH IMPACTS ON
HEALTH IMPACT AS AN ANIMAL NEW
GRADUATE SURVEY AND WORKS
CLOSELY WITH US C. A CHANGE BUT
I DON'T FIND IT PERCENT OF NEW
GRASS WORKING. WHERE THEY WORK
TIME TO EMPLOYMENT ETCETERA
ETCETERA HEALTHCARE CENTER AS
YOU ALL KNOW DOES THE ANNUAL
SUPPLY AND DEMAND STUDIES ALL
WORKFORCE DATA COLLECTION.
MY
NAME ONLY ONE BURKE AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HEALTH FACILITIES OR CALF. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE COMMENTS REGARDING THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING IN
THE NURSING WORKFORCE
CHALLENGES LONG TERM CARE. CALF
WAS FOUNDED IN NINETEEN FIFTY
AND IS A NONPROFIT TRADE
ASSOCIATION WHOSE MEMBERS LED
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES
FOR THE DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED AND PEDIC'S ACUTE
DISABILITIES. THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN HUNDRED
FREESTANDING SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA THAT
SIR FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
PATIENTS A YEAR AND HAVE
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
YLIDES ARSONISTS I'M IN THE
MIDST FRAIL ELDERLY IN THE
STATE. AND ARE PIECE ON THE
LONG TERM CARE CAN.
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY SEVEN OF
OUR PATIENTS ARE ON MEDICAID.
BETWEEN KAREN MEDIKAL ARCUS ARE
ALMOST AND GOVERNMENT FUNDED.
OUR SKILLED PERSON FACILITY
CONSISTS OF REGISTER NURSES
LICENSED VOCATIONAL NURSES AND
CERTIFIED NURSE ASSISTANTS.
FINISHED A STAFFING
REQUIREMENTS S. THREE PER FIVE
TWO POINT. THAT MEANS EACH PAGE
THROUGH THREE POINT FIVE HOURS
OF NURSING. AND POINTS THOSE
HOURS NEED TO BE FOR HER FOR TO
BIASED NAY A- LIKE OTHER
DOCTORS. WE ARE A SEPT-
SINGSTAR. THERE WAS A SIX SURE
FOR TO THE NINETEEN OF THEM
NEXT AND THE WORK FOR SHORTAGE
INTENSIFIED OF THE NINETEEN THE
STAFF BURNER. ILLNESS LEAVE. TO
FAN AND OTHER CAN. FEAR OF
GETTING SICK. OR LEAVE OF CARE
FOR TOGETHER. IN TERMS DURING
OUR WORKFORCE OUR MEN ARE CAN
ABOUT SHORTAGES AND THE AND THE
QUALITY TO PAY AS CAN WITH AS
GROUPS THE AS HOW. THAT A
DIFFERENT PAIR MIX I CAN HIRE
JUST TO THE NURSES HOUSE PET I
THINK FACILITIES OFF HIGHER
BONUSES AND OFFERINGS
CONCESSION THEY WERE OTHER
NURSES AT THEIR AT THE FACILITY
FOR CERTAIN LENGTH OF TIME. THE
SEVERE NO SHORTAGE LET CACTUS
ON REST OF. WHICH WE'VE ALREADY
BEEN DISCUSSED. AND WE
SUPPORTED THE MY- BILL EIGHTY
FOUR TO. AT TWO YEAR OVER TO
NURSE MY COMPACT. REST WITH
STATES HELLO- AND WE LIKE TO
SEE AN B. SINCE FREQUENTLY
BECAUSE OF STATE NURSES ON TEN
LIKE. JUST THAT WHEN HE-
UNFORTUNATE WE FIND THAT- AT
THE LEAD TO BECOME TROUBLING
NURSES OR GO TO NURSING. WHERE
THEY EARN MONEY. MR USE AS A
CRITICAL TRAINING SITE OUR ARE
TO HIRE S. ARE AN AND BE R. AND
GRADUATE. NURSES THANK YOU NEED
TO SKILLS WELL HOW AND SO. AND
SEVEN DAYS WORKING WITH THE
JERRY POPULATION. ARE FOR IS
JOHN HOW GET. ARE THE STATE WE
DETERMINE AREAS WITH THE Q.
HOSP. WHERE HOUSE ARE. IT IS
KIND PRACTICE TO OR I KEEP LOS
AND HIRE ARE IN WITHOUT A- MANY
ARE AND BUILDINGS INSTANCE NEXT
AND THEN MOVE ON TO AN EX
SETTING. HERE'S INSTRUCTORS THE
INCREASE AND HAS NOT KEPT PACE
WITH THE MARKET PLACE. HAVE A
SELECTIVE ONLINE TRAINING
PROGRAMS RECOGNIZED A THREE AND
A GREATER DEGREE AND IT'S CLEAR
THAT THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT NEW
INVESTMENT. I'M MORE BRIDGE FOR
ALL THE END TO BSN PROGRAMS.
CASH STRONGLY ENCOURAGES A
BREAK THIS AUDIT GERIATRICS THE
NURSING CURRICULUM WHETHER THAT.
RECCHI RESIDENCY GERIATRIC
SPECIALTY OR BUYING IT TIETJENS
OF THAT NURSING STUDENTS ARE
MORE COMFORTABLE AND GAIN
ADDITIONAL EXPOSURE AND
INTEREST AND LONG TERM CARE.
THESE ARE JUST A FEW WAYS WE
CAN ENCOURAGE MORE OR NURSES TO
WORK IN THE LONG TERM CARE
SETTING. FINALLY AFRICAN THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
EXPAND ITS MEMBERSHIP THAT
HAPPENED ONE LONG TERM CARE
POST ACUTE TO WRECK. ON THE
BORDER. GIVEN OURSTATE'S
RAPIDLY GROWING AGING
POPULATION AND THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT AND ISSUES SUCH AS
THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING THERE
NEEDS TO BE SOMEONE ON YOUR AND
THAT WAS LACKS WHAT IS GOING ON
IN THE COMMUNITY. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE CAST
PERSPECTIVE I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. FORGIVABLE
BURKE. JUST ONE QUICK QUESTION-
AND THEN. MAYBE WE COULD MOVE
INTO MY EARLIER DATA QUESTION
WHAT YOU AND THE OTHER
PANELISTS BUT- DOES THE OF THE
BEER IN STAMFORD LICENSE
PROCESS. MITIGATE CALIPHATE
ANYWAY CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT
FAILURE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
LICENSE CONFESSIONAL ICING'S
LICENSE COMPACT FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE. AND I THINK THAT
HAS SOME I'M NOT AND- AN EXPERT
I COULD CHECK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ON AND PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
BACKGROUND. A LOT OF OUR- AND-
NURSING SHORTAGE FOCUS HAS BEEN
CERTIFIED NURSE ASSISTANTS
WHICH ARE OUTSIDE OF THE
PURVIEW OF. AMITY AND- BUT I
COULD GET YOU A LITTLE MORE
DETAIL. OKAY THANK YOU- WITH
RESPECT TO PANELISTS WITH
RESPECT TO MY EARLIER QUESTION
ON THE DATA. MR CHEN PERHAPS
YOU ADDRESS THIS BUT I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS THE DATA THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE. THEY WERE
TRYING TO USE TO BALANCE THE-
OUTPUT WITH WORKPLACE NEEDS
SUFFICIENTLY DETAILED CURRENT-
AND CERTAIN TO DO THAT SORT OF
PLANNING AND- IF SO FINE AND IF
NOT WHAT IS IT AGAIN THAT WE
NEED TO DO. YES THANK YOU CHAIR
ROSS FOR THE UESTION- TWENTY
EIGHT BECAUSE MY VOLUME HERE-
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE DO
GET FROM THE B. R. AND IS AN
EVERY TWO YEAR- SAMPLE SURVEY
OF NURSES AND PRACTICE AND THE
SAMPLE SURVEY IS DONE PERRANCE
SCIENTIFICALLY MEANING THAT- IT
THE TRYING TO REPRESENT ALL
NURSES IN. DIFFERENT PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA- I AM AWARE OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE THIRTY SIX
BYE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANG WHO IS
LOOKING TO CREATE A MINIMUM
DATA SETS- FOR LICENSE FEES
BECAUSE WE DO NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THE WHOLE OF THE
WORK FORCE AND AS THEY RENEW
THEIR LICENSES- AND SO I THINK
THAT THAT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL
TO CREATE A MINIMUM DATA SET.
OF FOR NOT JUST NURSING BUT ALL
OF THE HEALTH PROFESSIONS SO
THAT WE CAN UNDERSTAND WHERE
PEOPLE ARE WORKING HOW MUCH
THEY'RE WORKING WHERE ARE THEY
LIVING AND WORKING. FOR
MIGRATION QUESTIONS- AND SO I A
AM HOPEFUL THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TEAMS THE BILL AB TWELVE THIRTY
SIX WILL CONTINUE TO- GAIN
TRACTION THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND WITH LICENSURE RENEW
ALL OF THE INFORMATION THAT WE
NEED TO ADEQUATELY PROJECTS
WORKFORCE SUPPLY AND DEMAND.
THEN YOU MAY HAVE ANSWERED MY
NEXT QUESTION OR TWO. YOU KNOW
WE KNOW- WE KNOW BECAUSE THE
VARIOUS DISCUSSIONS THAT WE'VE
HAD. IN THIS CHAMBER IN THE
LEGISLATURE GENERALLY OVER THE
LAST EIGHT NAY HALF YEARS OR SO
THAT. PHYSICIANS FOR EXAMPLE
GENERALLY WORK WHERE THEY
TRAINED FOR EXAMPLE PHYSICIANS
WHO ARE ENROLLED IN RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS AND- IN INLAND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE
STATISTICS SHOW WILL TYPICALLY
STAY IN PRACTICE IN INLAND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. I ASSUME
WE- DO NOT HAVE THAT SORT OF
DATA WITH RESPECT TO THE
NURSING. GRADUATES IS THAT A
FAIR STATEMENT. YES THAT'S A
FAIR STATEMENT AND I THINK WITH
THE- GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
LOOK AT- THE REORGANIZATION
ACOSTA HAD- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WORKS WELL IS- GROW WHERE
YOU LIVE PROGRAMS SO TAKING
PEOPLE FROM THE COMMUNITY AND
HELING THEM GO THROUGH A
PROGRAM- THAT CAN HELP THEM
STAY WHERE THEY ACTUALLY. ARE
COMING FROM WE KNOW THAT IN
GENERAL BIERCE'S ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. LIVE ABOUT I'M SORRY
40% OF ALL NURSES LIVE WITHIN
FIFTY MILES OF WHERE THEY WENT
TO HIGH SCHOOL. YOU SIT IN THE
BACK OF THE NUMBER SO WE NEED
TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE SUPPORT-
RURAL AREAS AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT NURSING SHORTAGE-
THERE WAS A SENATOR. ON THE FAR
NORTH IN THE FEES YOU KNOW AND
SISKIYOU COUNTY. THAT SPOKE
EARLIER AND WE DO NEED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW THIS WORKS. THE
GROWTH OF THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE IN THESE RURAL AREAS-
THROUGH CLINICAL FACULTY
TRAINING- RETENTION PROGRAM
SCHOLARSHIP. AND LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAMS TO HELP PEOPLE STAY
WHERE THEY- I GREW UP- THE AREA
IS ONE OF THE HIGHEST HE'D
AREAS OF NURSING HOME TREE AND
SO IT'S A GREAT DRAW FOR PEOPLE
TO COME TO THE AREA AND- WORK
AND THEN GO BACK- HOME. AFTER
THEY FINISH A FEW CHEFS AND SO-
SUPPLY AND DEMAND ESPECIALLY
AROUND VALERIE TO. ANY
BLOOMBERG'S EARLIER COMMENTS
ABOUT. THE WORK FORCE IF YOU
NURSING FACILITY THERE ARE A
LOT OF FACILITIES- IS REALLY A
GREAT ISSUE WHEN WE LOOK AT-
SUPPLY AND. AND RT- SO REGION'S
DID YOU SAY THAT NURSES TEND TO
TEND TO WORK WITHIN FIFTY MILES
FIFTY MILES OF WHERE THEY
ATTENDED HIGH SCHOOL. YEAH SO
40% OF NURSES NATIONWIDE- WORK
WITHIN FIFTEEN MILES WHERE THEY
WENT TO HIGH SCHOOL. HAVE THERE
BEEN ANY SURVEYS TO TRY TO
DETERMINE WHAT MIGHT INCREASE-
MOBILITY WITHIN THE POOL OF
AVAILABLE NURSES WHAT WOULD
INCENTIVIZE THE NURSES FOR
EXAMPLE WHO TRAIN IN THE BAY
AREA OR TRAIN AND- THE LOS
ANGELES AREA TO RELOCATE TO
MEDICALLY UNDER SERVED- AREAS
TO PERFORM- HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. YES THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME SMALL STUDIES AND
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS TO HELP
PEOPLE INTEGRATE INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND IT'S REALLY A
SENSE OF BELONGING WHICH IS THE
STRONGEST- PROTECTOR OF PEOPLE
STAYING IN A COMMUNITY WHERE
THEY CAN GROW UP IN SO. I MEAN
IT IS SUCH AS- OPPOSE THE COUNT
AND SIERRA FOOTHILLS ARE REAL
TRYING TO. PEOPLE TO HELP THEM
FEEL LIKE THEY'RE A PART OF THE
COMMUNITY SO THAT THEY- SET
DOWN ROOTS IN THAT COMMUNITY
AND STAY FOR THE LONG TERM. AND
SO THE MORE THAT WE CAN HELP
CREATE THESE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE TO FEEL LIKE THEY BELONG
IN THE COMMUNITY AS JUST
SUPPOSED TO. BE SPENT TWO YEARS
IN THE- UNDERSERVED AREA FOR MY
LITTLE MAKE LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM- THINKING ABOUT ONE OF
THE SUPPORT FROM THE COMMUNITY
TO HELP PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY
BELONG. VERY GOOD THANK YOU AND
FOR THE HEALTH FACILITIES HAVE
YOU HAVE YOUR FACILITIES BEEN
ABLE TO- ENGAGE IN PRACTICES
BEST PRACTICES FOR EXAMPLE
THAT. ASSISTED NURSES COMING OF
TO CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE- THE
OUT OF STATE PROCESS. INDOORS
WHEN I THINK WE CALLED IN
DIVERS BEEN PROCESS- TO ASSIST
THOSE NURSES AND MOVING TO
CALIFORNIA AND QUICKLY MOVING
THROUGH THE BOARD OF- OF
REGISTERED NURSING PROCESS. YES
CENTER OFFICES CJ FROM CJ THANK
YOU AND- HE YEAH I THINK. NOW
I'M ON THE HEAD WITH A
FINGERPRINT ISSUE THAT SEEMS TO
BE LESS IF YOU WERE A KID AND-
ANY HELP WE MIGHT HAVE THEIR IN
SOME RESPECTS WOULD. PROBABLY
FACILITATE ENDORSEMENT
TIMEFRAMES BUT THAT. THEY HAVE
TO RELY STANDING CALIFORNIA I
MEAN IF YOU LIVE IN VIRGINIA
YOU'RE COMING HERE. YOU HAVE TO
MAKE A TRIP. THAT I WILL SAY
THAT IT IS A- LITTLE STATE-
WHEN TO TRY. COME MANY THEM
RETURN- HAVING THAT ENDORSE
PROCESS EASIERAND IT'S THE
FINGERPRINT ISSUES THAT IS ONE
OF THE BIG BARRIERS. AND
WHATEVER WE ALL CAN DO TO BREAK
DOWN THAT BARRIER- I THINK
WE'RE ALL. WAYS TO RAISE HELP
LORETTA THE BEER AND DO IT. WE
INTEND TO CERTAINLY EXPLORE THE
HAVING IF THE QUOTE AND HAVING
RECEIVED THE INFORMATION SO
WE'RE WE'RE ON IT. PANELS
ANYTHING FURTHER BEFORE WE MOVE
TO OUR NEXT PANEL. OKAY
COLLEAGUES ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS I
SEE NONE. OUR FINAL PANEL WILL
HELP US UNDERSTAND NURSING
CLINICAL EDUCATION AND
PLACEMENTS WE'VE COVERED THAT
SOME BUT I'M SURE THERE'S MORE
TO COVER. ON THIS CRITICAL
TOPIC WE WILL HEAR. FROM DR
ELLIS MARTIN NICK MARTIN THE
GARA ASSOCIATE DEAN DIRECTOR OF
NURSING GOLDEN WEST COLLEGE.
MESCALINE O'LEARY KELLY
DIRECTOR AND PROFESSOR VALLEY
FOUNDATION SCHOOL OF NURSING
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY SAN
JOSE. MRS RENEE SWEITZER VICE
PRESIDENT UNIVERSITY RELATIONS
WEST COAST UNIVERSITY AND MS KT
WAXMAN DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA'S
SIMULATION ALLIANCE HEALTH
IMPACT PANELISTS PLEASE PROCEED.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ME TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE-
JUST A LITTLE BIT ABOUT- OUR
BACKGROUND- I'M ASSOCIATE DEAN
AND DIRECTOR OF NURSING- FOR TO
COMMIT COLLEGE AT GOLDEN WEST
COLLEGE WHICH IS LOCATED IN
ORANGE COUNTY SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IT'S SOMETHING THAT
BEACH. I'VE I'VE BEEN ASKED
TODAY TO SPEAK ON CLINICAL
EDUCATION AND PLACEMENT. SO I
CAN JUST SHARE WITH YOU A STORY
THAT IS REALLY NEAR AND DEAR TO
MY HEART I'M A PRODUCT OF
GOLDEN WEST COLLEGE AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROGRAM AND
THIS PROGRAM OPEN THE DOOR TO
ME AS A SINGLE MOTHER SIMPLER
KIND OF. JOURNEY OFF THE SMOKE
TO YEAH SO CAME OUT OF MY
SHORTLIST RETIREMENT DURING THE
MIDDLE OF THIS PANDEMIC TO
RETURN BACK TO ACADEMIA. TO
ADDRESS- ASSISTANCE. AS WELL AS
MICHAEL AND COLLEGE SAYS.
SHOULD NOT BE THROUGH THIS
TANDEM M. IN PARTICULAR AND- TO
ADDRESS THE CLINICAL PLACEMENT
ISSUES- YOU KNOW THE TOPIC OF
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS HAS BEEN
ONGOING SINCE MICHAEL PAYER IN-
NURSING ACADEMIA. I COULD SAY
BECAUSE OF- CLINICAL CONCERNS
THAT'S BEEN OVER LOOMING OVER
THE YEARS IT'S REALLY PARTLY-
OUR ANALYSIS IS THE CHANGES AT
THAT THE TWO CHANGES THAT
IMPACT US. SO NUMBER ONE THE
CHANGES IN THE HOSPITAL STAY
AND THE CENSUS GREATLY GREATLY
IMPACT THE ACCESS TO PATIENTS
AND NURSING STUDENTS. WHEN DOES
HAPPENS THE INCREASE A
PROPRIETARY NURSING PROGRAM
ALSO CAME INTO PLAY AND IS ALSO
GREATLY IMPACT THE AVAILABILITY
AND ACCESS TO PATIENTS IN THE
MIXING CORPORATE. AND SO WITH
THE COME OF THE TWO AND A
CHALLENGE FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
NURSING BE INCENTIVE RECTORS WE
ARE. BASICALLY TRYING TO
CONTINUE TO PUSH UP BLUNTING
THE NURSING PROGRAMS WITH VERY
LIMITED RESOURCES AND FOR THE
STATE FUNDED PROGRAMS I CAN SAY
MEDIA VERY STRETCH WITH A
NURSING- CLINICAL PLACEMENTS
AND EVEN THE REPLACEMENT OF
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS AS
DEMONSTRATED DURING ECONOMIC
COLUSA MALAYSIAN. WE HAVE A
BEAUTIFUL ACCESS TO- NICE
BUILDING GREAT. HOWEVER THE
EQUIPMENT AND THE TRAINING FOR
FACULTY TO USE WITH THIS
CUSTOMER RELATION AND THAT.
WITH A STATE YOU ACCESS WHEN I
CAN WALK IT'S MY OLD COLLEGE I
WAS REALLY SURPRISED AT HOW
MUCH OF A- HOW MUCH FAR BEHIND
THAT OUR COLLEGE IS IN
COMPARISON TO PROPRIETARY. I'VE
WORKED BOTH SIDES OF THE FENCE
WHERE I'VE WORKED FOR
PROPRIETARY ACADEMIA SETTING
AND I'VE WORKED ALSO FOR PUBLIC.
STATE FUNDED PROGRAMS. I YOU
KNOW I BELIEVE AS- MUCH AS WE
WILL LIKE DO WE WANT. THE
COMMUNITY THE STATE THEY DO AND
SAY THAT THEY HAVE SHARED
DUTIES THESE RESEARCH SAYING-
YOU CAN GO TO THE CLINICS WELL
GUESS WHO GOALS AND KNOCKING ON
THE DOOR IT WOULD BE US THE
NURSING TEAMS WE DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF FOR THE MANPOWER AS WE
DO- IF I'VE HAD WORK IN A
PROPRIETARY AND I HAVE A
CLINICAL PLACEMENT COORDINATOR.
THE CONTRACT AND LOOK FOR ALL
OF THESE CLINICAL PLACEMENTS WE
ARE SO FAR BEHIND AS A STATE
FUNDED FACILITY THAT NOT ONLY
WE NEED RESOURCES PROBABLY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO NOT HAVE OR
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS BE TAKEN
AWAY BY OTHER SCHOOLS WHO CAN
BE A LITTLE BIT AHEAD OF US
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE MANPOWER
AND RESOURCES. TO LOOK FOR
THESE ALTERNATIVE CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS AND AS FAR AS
COMMUNITY BASED CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS OF CLINICS AS MISS
MEL B. HAS- GENTLY SAID IN THE
FIRST REPORT. OF HER- FRAZIER
HEARING MEETING- THESE CLINICS
SOME SO HAVE LARENZ AND ARE PRO
IS A LOT OF ROOM. WHERE WE NEED
A MARIN SUPER THE SUIT. NOW
WITH AS MUCH FIVE AS WE HAVE. I
HAVE BE IN DIFFERENT AT ONE
GIVEN TIME. THE JUST. IT IS
ALMOST AND- SO HOW AND I AM FOR
TO STAFF ONE FACULTY. TO
STUDENTS IN THE CLINIC. AND BE
ABLE TO USE THAT AS CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS WHAT A NORMAL
TYPICAL CLINICAL GROUP IS TEN
STUDENTS. THAT IS WHAT I'M
TRYING TO TELL YOU WHAT THE HOW
WE ARE WORKING AT THE BOOTS ON
THE GROUND- THE BRN HAS BEEN
VERY SUPPORTIVE. BUT THEY COULD
BE BETTER. YOU KNOW WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SOME OF THE
INNOVATION THAT MISS MOBLIE IS
LOOKING FORWARD TO BRINGING
INTO THE PRM TO AUTOMATE SOME
OF THE PROCESSES SHE SPOKE
EARLIER ABOUT- UP STUDENTS
APPLYING FOR AND FLEX WELL MY
COLLEGE IS A PUBLIC INSTITUTION
TAKES ABOUT FOUR WEEKS TO
PROCESS. THE TRANSCRIPTS
BECAUSE I CANNOT MAKE A
REGISTROS GO ANY FASTER THE
TIME FOR A DEGREE SNS THAT
TRANSCRIPT IS AVAILABLE WE
UPLOAD THEM RIGHT AWAY BECAUSE
WE KNOW OUR GRADUATES A LADY.
IN THE. MEANTIME I. HAVE FOR
HER STUDENTS. THE APPLY TO MY
PROGRAM I CAN ONLY TAKE FORTY
FIVE STUDENTS ONE SEMESTER.
AND
NOW FORTY FIVE STUDENTS. ONE
NOT AS OPEN TO HAVING THAT
DISCUSSION WITH THEM- COMMIT
COLLEGE WE HAVE A CONSORTIUM OF
NEED DISCUSSED WITH EACH OTHER
IF WE HAVE A CONFLICT WE WILL
ONE OF US WILL MAKE ROOM SO THE
OTHER ONE CAN PASS THEIR
STUDENTS TO PROVE. WE WORK IT
OUT BUT WE DO NOT SEE THAT
BECAUSE I AM ALSO THE CO CHAIR
OF THE CONSORTIUM IN ORANGE
COUNTY LONG BEACH. AND I KNOW
FOR A FACT I CAN TELL YOU WHO'S
BEEN ATTENDING DOES. DOES
CONSORTIUM MEETINGS AND WE DO
NOT HAVE PROPRIETARY SCHOOLS
WORKING IT OUT WITH ANOTHER
COMMUTER STATE FUNDED SCHOOL.
SO I WANT SHARE THAT STORY TO
YOU AND ANYTHING YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ASK. THANK YOU. YEAH. LET ME
ASK A QUESTION IS IT. SO IS IT
A SHORTAGE OF PLACEMENTS IN A
CUTE. CARE FACILITIES THAT'S
THE ISSUE. YES THAT THE
SHORTAGES THE IN THE
SPECIALTIES ESPECIALLY IN THE
QUEUE CARE SETTING WE HAVE
TRIED THE COMMUNITY SETTINGS
AND IT'S JUST IMPOSSIBLE TO
STAFF IT WITH OUR FACULTY.
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT ENOUGH
THEY'RE NOT ENOUGH
OPPORTUNITIES TO PUT A
SUFFICIENT NUMBER OF STUDENTS
IN THERE TO MAKE THE FACULTY
ASSIGNMENT. EFFECTIVE SAYS
SOFTLY. THE LICENSURE STUDENTS
THEY'RE NOT LICENSE SO WE
CANNOT JUST LEAVE THEM ALONE
WITH THE PATIENT. HELLO OTHER
OF THE OTHER PARTICIPANTS WILL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN
HERE BUT LET ME WHILE I HAVE
YOU LET ME JUST ASK ONE. ONE
QUESTION HAVE YOU HAVE YOU
DETECTED BECAUSE OF THE IN THE
ACUTE CARE HOSPITAL SETTING THE
PRESSURE FROM THE ACCREDITING
AGENCIES TO FOR MAGNET STATUS
AND HIRING BACHELOR'S DEGREE-
NURSES OR STUDENTS WHO ARE
PURSUING BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
STATUS HAVE YOU HAVE YOU
DETECTED. THAT AS AN ISSUE IN.
HOSPET DECIDING WHETHER TO.
PROVIDE YOUR STUDENTS WITH
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS WERE NOT.
WELL IT'S YES AND NO I CANNOT
SPEAK FOR ALL HOSPITALS I CAN
JUST TELL YOU THAT. FOR US IT'S
BUILDING THAT RELATIONSHIP
HOWEVER AND OUR STUDENTS I CAN
TELL YOU 90% OF MY STUDENTS ARE
MOVING ON TO A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE BY THE TIME THEY FINISH
THE THIRD YEAR OF SEMESTER. AND
THIS IS A FOUR SEMESTER-
PROGRAM IT'S A TWO YEAR
PROGRAM. SO THE HOSPITAL'S
PREFERRED AT SOME OF THE
PROPRIETARY BECAUSE WE CANNOT
PROVIDE ANY TYPE OF
COMPENSATION WE CAN'T EVEN
PROVIDE C. USE FAR NURSES WHO
WORK WITH OUR STUDENTS BECAUSE
THAT WOULD BE THE RIGHT THING
TO DO. BECAUSE TECHNICALLY DAY
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE PRECEPT
THING AND TRAINING OUR
STUDENTS. SO THIS IS NOT A C.
E. U. TYPE OF THE CLASS DOESN'T
NEED TO SEE YOU AS A QUIET. AND
SO DOES WHERE OUR- THEY SAY
IT'S MAGNET MAGNET MEANS YOU
HAVE TO HAVE AN EDUCATION PLAN.
TO GO TO XPS THAT. FOX IT
DOESN'T SEND YOU OR ME AS- AN
INDIVIDUAL- IN GAUGE WITH A BSN
PROGRAM. AND SOME WE DO FAILED.
AS AN ATM CARD AS AN ASSOCIATE
DEGREE PROGRAM ESPECIALLY THE
STATE FUNDED PROGRAM WHO DO NOT
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO PROVIDE
TO THE HOSPITAL'S FOR A LOT OF
THINGS I WE BARELY COULD EVEN
AFFORD PP. DURING THIS CALL
WITH PANDEMIC. AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO AS IT APPEARS BY THE
BOOK. DIMENSIONAL I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THE ROOF I AM I
DIDN'T RECOGNIZE IT SEE SEE YOU.
YES THAT'S A THING EDUCATION
UNITS THAT YOU SPOKE OFF THE
LOBBY AND THE POLICY OF
PRESIDENT OF. YOU JUST NEED A
THANK YOU ANYTHING ELSE MEMBER
FOR I'VE YOU DON'T LEAVE ME YOU
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS I'M SURE.
ANYTHING ELSE THANK YOU OKAY. I
DO SUPPORT IMPOR FULL OF OUR B.
AND TO BE ABLE TO LEAD US INTO
WHAT WE HOPE AND WISH WHICH IS
A STANDARDIZED CURRICULUM
ACROSS THE STATE. I BELIEVE
STEP AND ESCORT COLOGNE FOR ALL
PARTIES WHETHER YOU'RE PUBLIC
FUNDED OR YOUR PROPRIETARY WILL
ASSIST WITH ALL OF THE-
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS AT LEAST.
THE PLAYING FIELD WILL BE LEVEL.
EACH RIGHT NOW IT DEPENDS ON
HOW MANY UNITS YOUR CLINICAL
CLASS IT'S HOW LONG YOU STAY IN
THE HOSPITAL. BECAUSE SECURE
UNITS OF THREE UNITS AND I'M
OFFERING WILL BE ONE MINUTE
CLASS. FIRST MY ONE UNIT IS
ONLY SO MANY HOURS AND YOUR
THREE UNITS WILL TAKE UP ALL
THE ROOMS IN THE HOSPITAL. SO
STANDARDIZED CURRICULUM WITH
THEIR SUPPORT AND ASSISTANCE OF
THE BRF AND HEALTH CLASS.
FORWARD AND ALSO THEIR
FLEXIBILITY AND LOOKING AT
SIMULATIONS AS COMING THEM S.
CLINICAL HOURS. WHEN WE CAN
PROVIDE THAT. RESOURCE AND THAT
SUPPORT. I THINK IT IT IT
LISTENERS POSSIBLE OF THIS
FOCUSED THAT'S BEEN ALL ACROSS
THE- THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM. I
GUESS MRS CILLER KELLY.
RAPTURED AFTERNOON. I'LL LET ME
MUTE MY SPEAKER. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY NURSING DIRECTORS. I
WILL BE ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
CRITICAL ISSUES WERE FACING
RELATED TO DECREASE CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS. I AM THE DIRECTOR
OF THE BALLOT FOUNDATION SCHOOL
OF NURSING AT SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY. WE HAVE A THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE PRE
LICENSURE STUDENTS IN THE
BACCALAUREATE PROGRAM. THIS CSU
ROLES APPROXIMATELY FORTY SEVEN
HUNDRED AND GRADUATES OVER
SIXTEEN HUNDRED PRE LICENSURE
BSN STUDENTS EVERY YEAR. AND AS
EDUCATORS WE ARE COMMITTED TO
PROVIDE THE FINEST EVIDENCE
BASED LEARNING EXPERIENCES THAT
PROMOTE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
CLINICAL JUDGMENT THE STATE
PRACTICE IN OUR GRADUATES.
DURING A PANDEMIC SEVERAL
ISSUES HAVE COME TO THE
FOREFRONT WHICH IMPACTED OUR
ABILITY TO MEET STUDENTS
ACADEMIC AND PERSONAL GOALS. IN
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY STUDENTS
WERE DISPLACED FROM CLINICAL
SITES WHERE PARTNER HOSPITALS.
NOW OVER A YEAR LATER CLINICAL
DISPLACEMENT CONTINUES TO BE A
SERIOUS PROBLEM. ALTHOUGH SOME
CLINICAL SITES HAVE A LOT OF
STUDENTS TO RETURN MANY HAVE
CUT THE PRETTY PANDEMIC NUMBERS
OF CLINICAL DAYS ALLOWED IN
ORDER TO MAKE ROOM FOR SEVERAL
SCHOOLS OR THEY LIMITED THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS ALLOWED ON
THE UNIT PER SHIFT. A CLINICAL
GROUPS NORMALLY TEN STUDENTS
PER INSTRUCTOR. SO WITH THE
DECREASING CLINICAL SITES
FACULTY WERE REQUIRED TO TAKE
LARGER GROUPS OF STUDENTS. BUT
ONLY ROTATE A SMALL GROUP
THROUGH ITS ISSUE ISFOUR TO
SIX STUDENTS EVERY OTHER WEEK.
THE NURSING PROGRAM INVOLVES
THE SEQUENTIAL PROCESS OF
STUDENT COHORTS COMPLETING A
COURSE OF STUDY EACH SEMESTER.
AND ALTHOUGH WE PLANNED OUT THE
ROTATIONS FOR GROUPS THE
CLINICAL SITES EACH WEEK THE
LACK OF PLACEMENTS OFTEN
DELAYED STUDENTS ABILITY TO
FINISH CARE HOURS AND PROGRESS
TO THE NEXT SEMESTER. THE
INITIAL EMERGENCY WAIVER FROM
DCA ALLOWED UP 250% OF
SIMULATION FOR DIRECT CARE
HOURS. PASSAGE OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
PROVIDED ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY
FOR SCHOOLS OF NURSING TO MEET
DIRECT CARE HOURS WITH
SIMULATION. WE HAVE CONTINUED
TO PROVIDE UP 250% CLINICAL
SIMULATION. I MERRILY USING
VIRTUAL AND ONLINE DIRECT
PATIENT CARE HOURS HAVE BEEN
HELD A 50% H. FACULTY
DOCUMENTED THE NUMBER OF DIRECT
CARE AND SIMULATION HOURS FOR
EACH STUDENT. DESPITE OUR BEST
EFFORTS THE LACK OF CLINICAL
SITES AND STATE REQUIREMENT FOR
SMALL GROUPS OF STUDENTS
ROTATING THROUGH HAS COST
APPROXIMATELY FORTY OF OUR
STUDENTS WHO WILL NEED TO
COMPLETE HOURS AFTER THE END OF
THIS SEMESTER. HOPEFULLY
COMPLETING THEIR DIRECT CARE
HOURS BY JUNE THIRTIETH. OTHER
CSU PROGRAMS ARE EXPERIENCING
SIMILAR ISSUES. THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING HAS NOT
SHOWN INTEREST TO CONTINUE THE
INCREASE IN SIMULATION IN FACT
EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC THE
BOARD RESISTED REQUESTS FOR
INCREASING CLINICAL SIMULATION
IN OUR PRE LICENSURE PROGRAMS.
THIS IS UNFORTUNATE AS
SIMULATION IS A BEST PRACTICE
THAT HAS BEEN SHOWN TO BE
EFFECTIVE IN HEALTH CARE
EDUCATION INCLUDING MEDICINE
FOR SEVERAL YEARS. IT SOUNDS A
STATE WE'VE USED TO STANDARDIZE
PROGRAM OF CLINICAL SIMULATIONS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN. OUR
FACULTY ARE EDUCATED IN THE
PRINCIPLES OF SIMULATION BASED
EDUCATION. AND WE USE ESTABLISH
STANDARDS AS A MEANS TO ENHANCE
THE DEVELOPMENT OF CLINICAL
JUDGMENT AND SAFE PRACTICE.
USING EVIDENCE BASED SIMULATION
PRACTICES IS A SOUND TEACHING
STRATEGY THAT IS WELL SUPPORTED
IN THE LITERATURE. BACK UP HERE
ABLE TO ASSESS STUDENT NURSES
COMPETENCY USING PERFORMANCE
BASED INDICATORS IN CRITICAL
AREAS OF NURSING PRACTICE. ANY
INCREASE IN SIMULATION AS
CLINICAL PRACTICE HOURS IT'S
PART OF THE SOLUTION TO
MITIGATE CALIFORNIA'S STATEWIDE
REDUCTION IN CLINICAL PLACEMENT
CAPACITY. WHICH CONTINUES TO BE
A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM WITHOUT
ANY SIGNS OF. GOING AWAY. THE
CSU NURSING DIRECTORS
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM AGREE
WITH THE NATIONAL COUNCIL STATE
BOARD OF NURSING GUIDELINES A
50% SIMULATION. CRITERIA FOR
DIRECT PATIENT CARE AND
STIMULATION CLINICAL HOURS MUST
BE DATA DRIVEN AND THE S. U. S.
B. N. PROVIDED RESEARCH
FINDINGS THAT SUPPORT
SIMULATION AS PART OF CLINICAL
PRACTICE EXPERIENCES. THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL ALSO REPORTED
THAT 34% OF BOARDS OF NURSING
THROUGHOUT THE NATION. USE 50%
SIMULATION AS GUIDANCE FOR
CLINICAL PRACTICE. OF NOTE OUR
SCHOOLS FIRST TIME PASS RATE
FOR THE AND CLICKS ARE AN EXAM
HAVE REMAINED GREATER THAN
EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT. DESPITE
THE DECREASE CLINICAL HOURS AND
INCREASED STIMULATION TIME
DURING THE PANDEMIC. IT IS IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME I WON'T GO
INTO DETAIL BUT I WILL MERELY
NOTE THAT. EXAMINATION OF OTHER
AREAS RELATED TO REGULATION
WOULD ASSIST IN THE TIMELY
PLACEMENT OF STUDENTS. IN
CLINICAL SITES- SPECIFICALLY
LOOKING AT THE- REQUIREMENT FOR
THE BEER INTO APPROVED CLINICAL
SITES. AND THE REQUIREMENT FOR
CONCURRENCY. INCREASING ELATION
EXPERIENCE IS GRANTED THROUGH
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
ALLOW THE MAJORITY OF CSU
NURSING STUDENTS TO PROGRESS IN
A TIMELY MANNER THIS HELPED TO
ADDRESS THE BOTTLENECK THAT WAS
CREATED WHEN CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS EAST. EVERY PRE
LICENSURE. NURSING CAMPUS
REQUIRED AND WAS GRANTED
WAIVERS TO REDUCE DIRECT
PATIENT CARE HOURS. THE VALLEY
FOUNDATION SCHOOL OF NURSING
AND THE OTHER STUDENTS TO
SCHOOLS OF NURSING CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE CLINICAL
DISPLACEMENT FROM SEVERAL
CLINICAL PARTNERS. SINCE MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY. WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE DIFFICULTY IN SECURING
CLINICAL SITES ESPECIALLY IN
PSYCHIATRIC MENTAL HEALTH
DESPITE ALLOWABLE 75%
SIMULATION WAIVER. THIS NEEDS
TO BE REMEDIED QUICKLY TO
REDUCE THE BOTTLENECK IN
PROGRESSION OF OUR STUDENTS. IF
IRAN REGULATIONS RETURNED 275%
DIRECT PATIENT CARE HOURS THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS PROGRESSING
TO GRADUATION ON TIME WILL
DECREASE EXPONENTIALLY. MEDICAL
SURGICAL CLINICAL NURSING
EXPERIENCES ARE NOW 250% DIRECT
PATIENT CARE HOURS. PEDIATRICS
OBSTETRICS AND MENTAL HEALTH
ARE AT 25% SOME CLINICAL
PLACEMENT OPPORTUNITIES HAVE
OPENED BUT NOT TO THE EXTENT
THAT WOULD ALLOW 75% OF DIRECT
PATIENT CARE AND MEDICAL
SURGICAL PLACEMENTS AT ALL
CLINICAL SITES. IN CLOSING SOME
CLINICAL PLACEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES HAVE OPENED UP
BUT NOT TO THE LEVELS WE SAW
PRE PANDEMIC. AS A RESULT AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THERE
REMAINS A BOTTLENECK IN THE
SYSTEM. I WOULD ENCOURAGE THIS
BODY TO EMPHASIZE THE NEED FOR
GREATER FLEXIBILITY. IN THE
PROGRAM WHICH PROPERLY STRIKES
A BALANCE BETWEEN THE NEED TO
DELIVER QUALITY EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS AND THE NEED TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THAT YOU PROVIDED
ME TODAY. AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. PROFESSOR
BEFORE I MOVED TO THE NEXT
PANELIST JUST TO. THE FOCUS ON
THE PRE PANDEMIC PRIOR TO MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY DID YOUR PROGRAM
HAVE ANY DIFFICULTY SECURING
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS PRIOR TO
THE COVER NINETEEN. A PANDEMIC
SITUATION. NOW WE DID NOT DO
YOU KNOW WHETHER THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE NURSING PROGRAMS
ASSUMING THERE ARE SOME- IN
YOUR AREA HAD ANY PRE PAN
PANDEMIC PROBLEMS SECURING
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS. YES I AM
AWARE OF A FEW OF OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PARTNERS TO- HAD
DIFFICULTY FINDING CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS. JUST TO. HAVE A
FRAME OF REFERENCE PRIOR TO THE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC. IN
YOUR AREA WAS THERE ANY EFFORT
TO TRY TO GET TOGETHER OF YOUR
PROGRAM THE PROPRIETARY
PROGRAMS AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO ATTEMPT TO. COORDINATE THE
CLINICAL PLACEMENT EFFORT.
PREPEND DEMI. MAKE IT A WE DID
NOT SPECIFICALLY MEET TO
COORDINATE OUR CLINICAL SITE
PLACEMENTS- WE MET TO SHARE
FACULTY AND WE ALSO MET TO
DISCUSS- THE RN TO BSN PROGRAM
SOME OF THE CHANGES THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT AROUND
CONCURRENT ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS
THAT WE DIDN'T NEED TO.
CONSOLIDATE AT CLINICAL SITES.
IN ONE FINAL QUESTION ON
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY I SHOULD AS THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES INVOLVED BUT
TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU KNOW DO
YOU KNOW WHY WHAT THE
DIFFICULTY WAS THAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE NURSING
PROGRAMS WERE. WERE HAVING IN
SECURING CLINICAL PLACEMENTS
THOSE IN YOUR PARTICULAR AREA.
I CAN ONLY SPEAK FOR ONE. THAT
WAS IN OUR AREA AND- IT WAS
BECAUSE THE HOSPITAL WAS
SEEKING THE BACHELOR'S PREPARED
STUDENTS. OKAY WELL THANK YOU
DON'T LEAVE WE PROBABLY WILL
HAVE SOME MORE QUESTIONS AND
GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO JUMP
BACK IN. COLLEAGUES IN THE- ICY
NONE SO LET'S MOVE TO OUR NEXT
PANELIST RENEE SCHWEITZER VICE
PRESIDENT UNIVERSITY RELATIONS
WEST COAST UNIVERSITY THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ARE YOU ABLE TO HAR
ME. PERFECTLY WITH ROUGHLY
CRAIG- MY NAME IS RENEE
SCHWEITZER AND I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF UNIVERSITY
RELATIONS. FOR WEST COAST
UNIVERSITY THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
BEFORE YOU TODAY. LITTLE BIT
ABOUT OUR UNIVERSITY WCU HAS
OFFERED EDUCATION AND HEALTH
CARE SINCE NINETEEN OH NINE.
AND TODAY WCO IS A MAJOR
SUPPLIER OF THE STATE'S
BACHELOR. BACHELOR CREDENTIALED
NURSING WORKFORCE WE HOLD
NATIONAL REGIONAL ACCREDITATION
FROM LOS SENIOR. AND THE
COMMISSION ON COLLEGIATE
NURSING EDUCATION. AND OUR
GRADUATES CONSISTENTLY PLACE IN
THE NINETIETH PERCENTILE FOR
AND COLLECTS POSTAGE RATES. WE
HAVE THREE CAMPUSES LOCATED LOS
ANGELES ANAHEIM IN ONTARIO. 70%
OF OUR STUDENTS IDENTIFY AS
PEOPLE OF COLOR MANY OF OUR
STUDENTSSPEAK A SECOND
LANGUAGE LIVE IN MULTI
GENERATIONAL HOUSEHOLDS AND
ENTER OUR PROGRAMS LATER THAN
IN TRADITIONAL SETTINGS THE
AVERAGE AGE ACTUALLY FOR OUR
STUDENTS FOR ON GROUND CAMPUSES
IS BETWEEN TWENTY SIX AND
TWENTY NINE. WCU IS PROUD OF
THE RICH CULTURAL DIVERSITY OF
OUR STUDENTS ESPECIALLY GIVEN
THE DISCUSSIONS THAT OUR STATE
IS HAVING RIGHT NOW REGARDING
EQUITY IN HEALTHCARE AND
INCREASING THE DIVERSITY IN OUR
NURSING WORKFORCE. IN MY ROLE
AS VICE PRESIDENT OF UNIVERSITY
RELATIONS I'M RESPONSIBLE FOR
OVERSEEING ALL CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS AS WELL AS
PERFORMING ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNCTIONS NECESSARY. FOR B. RN
ACCREDITOR CLINICAL SITE
COMPLIANCE. I DO WORK CLOSELY
WITH OUR CAMPUS SCENES OF
NURSING TO ENSURE THAT EACH OF
OUR CLINICAL EXPERIENCES ARE
ABLE TO MEET COURSE OBJECTIVES.
AND ARE WITHIN THE ARE IN SCOPE
OF PRACTICE THAT YOU HEARD
ABOUT. I BRING WITH ME TO THIS
ROLE MY EXPERIENCE AS A FORMER
STUDENT. MY I'M THE FIRST IN MY
FAMILY TO GO TO COLLEGE I
EARNED MY ADN DEGREE AT
ANTELOPE VALLEY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE MY MASTERS AND FMP
DEGREES AT CSU DOMINGUEZ HILLS.
AND THEN FINALLY LOOK UP MUCH
LATER IN LIFE MY DOCTOR OF
NURSING PRACTICE AT CHAMBERLAIN.
AS A PRACTICING NURSE A
SPECIALIZED IN THE OPERATING
ROOM. I DO KNOW FIRST HAND HOW
VITAL THESE CLINICAL EDUCATION
EXPERIENCES THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING OUR FOR STUDENTS. AS
THEY TRANSITION INTO PRACTICE
TO ENSURE HEALTHY PATIENT
OUTCOMES. SECURING CLINICAL
ROTATIONS PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
WAS INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT
REGIONAL CONSORTIUM AND OTHER
THIRD PARTY SCHEDULING VENDORS.
THEY ONLY HAVE INFORMATION FOR
THE SITES THAT PARTICIPATE IN
THAT PARTICULAR PLATFORM. W. C.
DOES PARTICIPATE IN ALL LOCAL
CONSORTIUMS THAT YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT FROM MY FORMER PANEL
MEMBERS AND WE ALSO COMPLETE
THE B. R. AND REQUIREMENTS THAT
PROTECT PROGRAMS FROM CLINICAL
DISPLACEMENT. HOWEVER SCHOOL
STILL MUST ENDEAVOR TO DO THEIR
OWN RESEARCH WHICH TAKES A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME. DID
YOU SEE YOU HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
FIND OPPORTUNITIES BEYOND THE
POPULAR MOST STOCK MOST SOUGHT
AFTER CLINICAL ROTATIONS IN
ACUTE CARE SETTINGS. WE HAVE
FOUND ROTATIONS OF FACILITIES
SUCH AS HOME HEALTH- ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF HOSPICE. HAVE YOU
SEE YOU IS WERE ALSO VERY
FLEXIBLE IN SCHEDULING
RESTRAINTS- WE OFTEN TAKE
EVENING AND WEEKEND ROTATIONS
OTHER PROGRAMS CANNOT
ACCOMMODATE. ABOUT
APPROXIMATELY 30% OF OUR
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS MARTIN ON A
Q. CARE SETTINGS AND
APPROXIMATELY 35% ARE ON
EVENINGS AND WEEKENDS. AS WE
SLOWLY RECOVER FROM THIS
PANDEMIC CLINICAL SITES ARE
CAUTIOUS TO READMIT STUDENTS AS
YOU'VE HEARD I HAVE SOME DATA
ON THAT AND TO DATE HAVE YOU
SEE YOU HAS ONLY REGAIN FORTY
PERCENT. OF OUR PRE COATED
ROTATIONS HOWEVER WE'VE BEEN
THANKFUL TO USE A TEMPORARY
INCREASE IN SIMULATION AND
OTHER PROVISIONS OF AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT. BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOVE TO CONTINUE
TO PROGRESS STUDENTS FOR ON
TIME GRADUATION. WE DO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EASE EASE THE
DEMAND FOR ROTATIONS- WOULD BE
TO PERMANENTLY INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF SIMULATION- THAT IS
COOL CAN USE TO ACHIEVE THEIR
OBJECTIVES. AS YOU HAVE ALREADY
HEARD AND YOU WILL PROBABLY
CONTINUE TO HEAR FROM MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE PANEL THAT
SIN IS A PROVEN MODALITY FOR
TEACHING CRITICAL COMPETENCIES.
WCU IS A LEADER IN THE USE OF
STEM. AND IS ONE OF ONLY EIGHT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES THAT HOLDS
AN EDUCATION PROGRAM
ACCREDITATION. OUR STATUS IS
CURRENTLY PROVISIONAL AND WE
WILL APPLY FOR FULL APPROVAL
THIS DECEMBER. ONCE FULLY
APPROVED OUR STUDENT OUTCOMES
IN THE SYSTEM WILL ONTRIBUTE
SIGNIFICANTLY TO RESEARCH AND
PUBLICATIONS. TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR ALL OUR
PROGRAMS ARE TOP PRIORITY. AND
ONE MORE SOLUTION THAT COULD
SUPPORT PROGRESSION AND
GRADUATION IS TO ALIGN THE ARE
AN OVERSIGHT WITH OUR
PROFESSIONAL ACCREDITATION
REQUIREMENTS. AND THAT WOULD
INCLUDE TO THE FIRST OF SANTA
CHANGES INCLUDING A ROMAN
FACULTY APPROVALS CURRICULUM
CHANGES EXCEPT FOR TO THE
PROFESSIONAL ACCREDITOR. AGAIN
THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE TO BE
SEIZE PERSON W. C. USE
PERSPECTIVE ON THE OUTLOOK FOR
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS. AND
EDUCATION I AM PREPARED TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE FOR ME ON THIS TOPIC INTO
INVITE ALL OF YOU AND YOUR
STAFF TO ONE OF OUR CAMPUSES
ACTUALLY VIEW WHAT SIMULATION
LABS LOOK LIKE IN ACTION. AND
MEET WITH OUR FACULTY AND
STUDENTS THANK YOU. PERHAPS
JUST ONE QUESTION AND THEN
I'LL- TRY TO MAKE SURE I MOVE
ON AND THEN FOLLOW UP. WITH MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE SECOND BUT-
CAN SOMEONE. CAN SOMEONE
ADDRESS THE COST OF. ELATION
MISS WRITERS INSURER AND WEST
COAST AND IT'S A PROPRIETARY
SCHOOL- MAYBE YOU WOULD BE MORE
A QUICK TO ANSWER THAT WE'VE
GOT PUBLIC SCHOOLS BOTH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
THAT MAY HAVE A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE AND DIFFERENT
FINANCIAL OUTLOOK BUT CAN YOU
TALK TO ME ABOUT THE COST OF
SIMULATION. FOR A NEW PROGRAM I
DO NOT HAVE THE EXACT COST I DO
KNOW ONE PANELISTS WHO WILL
KNOW AND SHE'S FOLLOWING ME KT
WAXMAN WHO ACTUALLY HELPED US.
WITH THAT BUT IT ALSO DEPENDS
ON THE TYPE OF SIMULATOR THAT
ARE. METAPHYSICALLY CHEESE TWO
YEARS THERE ARE THERE ARE
MANICHAEANS IF YOU WILL THAT
ARE KNOWN AS HIGH FIDELITY THAT
HAVEN'T INCREASED COSTS AND
THEY ACTUALLY DO MORE- THEY
SIMULATE MORE OF A LIFE WITH A
LIVE PERSON. CAN DO- AND
THERE'S ALSO LOW FIDELITY
MANIKINS WHICH ARE WERE ALSO
USED UP PRIMARILY IN SKILLS
CLASS WHAT A ME TO PUT YOU ON
THE SPOT THAT THE- WHAT DOES
THAT THE- THING. INTO ME AS
WELL. IS WAXMAN. ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- FOR THE INVITATION I
AM K<c.cyan> WAXMAN I'M THE</c>
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
SIMULATION ALLIANCE WHICH IS A
PROGRAM OF HEALTH IMPACT I AM A
DOCTOR LEE PREPARED REGISTERED
NURSE PRACTICING IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR ALMOST FOUR
DECADES NOW. I BILLION
SIMULATIONS SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND FIVE. AND I AM FULL TIME
FACULTY AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO I AM ALSO A PAST
PRESIDENT FOR THE SOCIETY FOR
SIMULATION IN HEALTHCARE. THERE
ARE DECADES OF SIMULATION
STUDIES AND EVIDENCE ON THE
SAFETY AND EFFICACY ON
PREPARATION OF NURSES
PHYSICIANS FIRST RESPONDERS
FIREFIGHTERS AND AIRLINE PILOTS.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE EIGHTEEN
STATES IN WHICH BOARDS OF
NURSING HAVE APPROVED THE USE A
50% SIMULATION THERE ARE TWO
STATES THAT ARE AT 30% AND
SEVEN STATES AT 25% THE
REMAINING TWENTY FOUR STATES
HAVE NO RETURN REGULATIONS ON
THE USE OF SIMULATION. THERE
ARE STANDARDS AVAILABLE FOR
SIMULATION FROM BOTH THE
INTERNATIONAL NURSING
ASSOCIATION FOR CLINICAL
SIMULATION AND LEARNING AND THE
SOCIETY FOR SIMULATION IN
HEALTHCARE. ADOPTION OF THE I'M
AXLE STANDARDS OF BEST PRACTICE
SIMULATION DEMONSTRATED
COMMITMENT. TO QUALITY AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF RIGOROUS
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES IN
HEALTH CARE EDUCATION TO
IMPROVE PATIENT CARE BY
COMPLYING WITH PRACTICE
STANDARDS THERE ARE EIGHT.
SANDERS THAT ADDRESS THE
FOLLOWING AREAS. SIMULATION
DESIGN OUTCOMES AND OBJECTIVES
FACILITATION DEBRIEFING
PARTICIPANTE VALUATION
PROFESSIONAL INTEGRITY
STIMULATION ENHANCED INTER
PROFESSIONAL EDUCATION AND
OPERATIONS THE NINTH IS ALMOST-
AVAILABLE AND THAT'S FUNDS
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. THE
SOCIETY FOR SIMULATION IN
HEALTHCARE ACCREDITATION
PROGRAM EXAMINES SIMULATION
PROGRAMS PROCESSES AND OUTCOMES
IN ASSESSMENT RESEARCH TEACHING
EDUCATION AND SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION. AND AS MENTIONED
EARLIER WE HAVE EIGHT SCHOOLS
THAT ARE ACCREDITED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THERE'S
ALSO A CERTIFICATION THAT IS
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE SOCIETY
FOR FACULTY TO FOSTER
EXCELLENCE IN HEALTHCARE
SIMULATION AND TO PROMOTE
CONFIDENCE RECOGNITION AND
DEVELOPMENT OF HEALTHCARE
SIMULATION S. THREE STANDARDS
AND PROCESSES FOR CERTIFICATION
WITHIN THE GLOBAL HEALTH CARE
SIMULATION COMMUNITY. WITH
CALIFORNIA'S SIMULATION
ALLIANCE RECOMMENDS THAT
FACULTY LEADING AND TEACHING IN
SIMULATION WORK TOWARDS
CERTIFICATION. SOME STATES ARE
NOW REQUIRING THE CERTIFICATION
IN ORDER TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT
OF STIMULATION 250% RECENTLY A
CONSORTIUM OF FOUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
UTILIZE THE CALIFORNIA
SIMULATION ALLIANCE THROUGH A
GRANT TO TRAIN OVER THE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FACULTY IN
SIMULATION. FACULTY ARE EAGER
TO BE EDUCATED ON THIS
METHODOLOGY. SIMULATION IS NOT
ALL MANNA CAN BET BASED AND IT
IS NOT ALL EXPENSIVE.
SIMULATION CAN BE ROLE PLAY
STANDARDIZED PATIENTS HYBRID
LOW FIDELITY OR HIGH FIDELITY
MANNEQUINS COMPUTER BASED OR
VIRTUAL REALITY. WE CAN
GUARANTEE A CLINICAL EXPERIENCE
IN SIMULATION BUT WE CANNOT IN
THE CLINICAL SETTING A STUDENTS
ARE OFTEN NOT. ONLY ALLOWED TO
OBSERVE AND MAYBE MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO EVEN GIVE MEDICATIONS
FOR CHART IN THE MEDICAL RECORD.
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY A
SYSTEMATIC REVIEW OF THE
LITERATURE THAT INVESTIGATED
THE IMPACT OF IN PERSON
CLINICAL ROTATIONS ON LEARNING
OUTCOMES THE AUTHORS. COULD NOT
FIND ANY STUDIES LINKED IN
PERSON CLINICAL THAT LINKED IN
PERSON CLINICAL ROTATIONS TO
ACHIEVING LEARNING OUTCOMES
RESULTING IN AN EMPTY REVIEW.
ALSO A RECENT STUDY JUST
PUBLISHED THIS MONTH WAS ONE OF
THE FIRST STUDIES TO QUANTIFY
THE QUALITY AND SAFETY OF NEW
GRADUATE NURSES THAT WAS
CONDUCTED PRE PANDEMIC. THE
STUDY FOUND THAT 1100% OF NEW
GRADUATES MADE ERRORS AND
FAILED TO RESCUE THEIR PATIENTS
HOWEVER THE RESEARCHERS USED AN
ONLINE SIMULATION PROGRAM TO
IMPROVE THE CLINICAL REASONING
AND DECISION MAKING AND THERE
WAS SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT IN
THE QUALITY AND SAFETY OF THE
NEW GRADS. THIS IS A CONCRETE
EXAMPLE OF SIMULATION OF THE
VALUE OF SAM. IN CONCLUSION WE
NEED TO USE SCIENCE BASED
TEACHING AND LEARNING METHODS
POST PANDEMIC AND NOT GO BACK
TO THE WAY WE WERE PREPEND
EMMETT AS WE HAVE LEARNED SO
MUCH OVER THE PAST YEAR AND WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO APPLY.
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE
ACCORDINGLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM COULD YOU
MAYBE YOU MENTIONED IT AND I
MISSED TO SPEAK ABOUT THE COST
OF SIMULATION HOW DOES THAT
DOES THAT VERY AND IF SO. HOW.
FIRST OF ALL THE COST OF
SIMULATION- VARIES
SIGNIFICANTLY ON WHAT- TYPE OF
EQUIPMENT THAT YOU WOULD WOULD
PURCHASE AND SOME OF THE US I
THINK EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THE
SCHOOLS IN THE STATE HAS SOME
SORT OF EQUIPMENT. AND IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE WHEN WE BEGAN
OVER TRAINING THE REASON WE DID
THE TRAINING WAS THROUGH A
GRANT BECAUSE EVERYONE HAD
STIMULATORS AND AT THAT TIME WE
WERE VERY FOCUSED ON THIS
MANNEQUIN. OVER TIME WE
REALIZED THE MANNEQUIN IS ONLY
ONE TYPE OF STIMULATION. AND
THOSE AMERICANS RANGING IN
PRICE FROM TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
TWO MAYBE A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. WE HAVE TO ASK
OURSELVES WHAT TYPE OF. HELLO
G. MODALITY DO WE NEED FOR OUR
STUDENTS TO ACHIEVE THE
LEARNING OUTCOMES IN AN I SEE
YOU FOR AN UNKNOWN ANASTASIA
ENVIRONMENT YOU MIGHT NEED A
VERY VERY HIGH FIDELITY
EXPENSIVE AMERICAN BUT IN A PRE
LICENSURE COMMUNITY COLLEGE YOU
MAY NEED A MIDDLE LEVEL.
MANNIKIN AND SOME STANDARDIZED
PATIENTS AND IT CAN BE
DETERMINED TO BE A RESOURCE
ALLOCATION AND YOUR BUDGET AND
THE LEARNING OUTCOMES NOT BY
THE EQUIPMENT. WELL IT SEEMS
SPEAK THE STANDARDS AND TO THE
POINT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
STANDARDS- OR IF WE DO. IF WE
DON'T HAVE STANDARDS WHAT
STANDARD SHOULD BE SAID AND IF
WE DO HOW SHOULD OUR STANDARDS
BE REVISED IN WHO SHOULD DO IT.
RIGHT WELL THEY'RE ALREADY
STANDARDS OUT THERE AS I
MENTIONED AND OUR OUR OUR GROUP
WITH- HAS RECOMMENDED- TO THE
NURSING EDUCATION- WORKFORCE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. TO
RECOMMEND AND IMPLEMENT
STANDARDS AT ALL SCHOOLS WHO
ARE DOING SIMULATION. SO THAT
THEY COULD CAN- INSURE QUALITY
I'M NOT ONLY OF THE SINGING
RELATIONS THEMSELF AND SAFETY
OF THE STUDENTS WHILE THEY'RE
IN THE- SIMULATION ALL FACULTY
NEED TO BE TRAINED. AND FOLLOW.
THE STANDARDS THAT ARE ALREADY
IN IN- HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED IN
THE IN THE IN THE WORLD OR
GLOBAL STANDARDS. OKAY WELL
WE'LL THANK YOU LET ME- LET ME
JUST THROW THIS QUESTION OUT
THAN TO THE- DIRECTORS OF THE
PUBLIC NURSING PROGRAMS. A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY IF THE BOARD
CHANGED THE RULES- THE
SIMULATION RULES. ON A GO
FORWARD BASIS- WOULD YOU FACE
ANY OTHER OBSTACLES TO
INCREASED USE OF SIMULATION IF
SO WHAT OBSTACLES AND HOW CAN
WE HELP ADDRESS THOSE. MAN
DRESSED UP THIS IS A ALL THIS
MONTH IN AMERICA- AS FOR TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE YOU KNOW THE
STANDARD SO GREAT TO IMPLEMENT
WHAT ARE CHALLENGES IN OUR
BARRIERS ARE NOT JUST THE
EQUIPMENT ALONE. BECAUSE YES
THE LIST OF DOCTOR BLACKMAN IS
CORRECT THERE ARE VARIOUS TYPES
OF SIMULATORS THAT ARE TO
SIMULATORS MANICKAM BASED AND
THEN THERE'S A VIRTUAL RELITY
AT. WHERE IT'S ALL AUGMENTED
AND SO WITH THAT BEING SAID
THERE STILL IS A HOT. AND FOR
ME PERSONALLY TRYING TO UPDATE
MY PROGRAM WHICH HAS FALLEN
BACK IN TEN YEARS BECAUSE OF
RESOURCE ISSUES- THE CHALLENGE
OF TRYING TO FIND THOSE
RESOURCES AM I SUPPOSED TO
WRITE A GRANT FOR EVERY
MANNEQUIN THAT I BUY TO LIVE BY
IN LITTLE PIECES EVERY YEAR.
THAT'S ONE CHALLENGE SECOND
CHALLENGE IS TO FIND A FACULTY
QUALIFIED FACULTY WHO'S WILLING
TO BE TRAINED IN SIMULATION
BECAUSE NOT ALL FACULTY WANTS
TO DISSIMULATION ESPECIALLY THE
CONCEPT THAT YOU. SEE SO TRYING
TO RESOURCE THOSE TWO ITEMS OUR
BEAR YEARS IN OUR WORLD IN THE.
PUBLIC STATE FUNDED PROGRAM. SO
OF IT'S A IS AND SOME OF IT TO
ME ISSUE. IT IS. AND THEN JUST
OF- AND WE DON'T ASK TO. AND IF
THE TWO I KNOW I JUST TRY TO
SEND SOMEBODY. HER OF THE
CALIFORNIA SIMULATION ALLIANCE
TRAINING. AND THAT COST NINE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER PERSON SO
IF I HAVE TWENTY FIVE THAT
MEANS NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS
TIMES TWENTY. PLUS THEIR TIME
THAT THEY SPEND IN THAT
TRAINING. ZERO YES A LOT OF IT
THERE'S A LOT OF ENCOMPASSING
THINGS WE WOULD LOVE TO DO 50%
SIMULATION BUT PLEASE HELP US
WITH THE STATE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WITH THIS POLITICAL
DISPLACEMENT ISSUE HOW CAN WE
MAKE THIS HAPPEN FOR OUR
COMMUNITY STUDENTS WHO CANNOT
AFFORD A HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR TUITION BUT CAN AFFORD
ARE SIX THOUSAND DOLLAR TUITION
BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE CUTS THE
NURSES. WHO ARE LIVING IN THE
COMMUNITY AS A DOCTOR CHEN HAD
MENTIONED EARLIER STATE DUMA
FITS WITHIN FIFTY MILES OF THE
SCHOOL. EVERY DAY WILL FORGET
MY COMMUNITY SO TO ADDRESS THE
OTHER LEGISLATORS QUESTION
ABOUT THAT ONE LPN IN THE
BAKERSFIELD AREA WELL IF YOU
HAVE MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO
ENROLL STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THESE RESOURCES AND TO
TRAIN STUDENTS WITH 50% OF
SIMULATION MAYBE PERHAPS WE
WILL BE ABLE TO ENROLL MORE
STUDENTS AND ADDRESS THEM THAT
THEY'LL BE AND THAT'S TRYING TO
GET INTO NURSING SCHOOL. AND
THAT WILL OFFSET SOME OF THE
CLINICAL DIRECTOR PLACEMENTS
THAT WE HAVE AMPLE SCOPE WITH I
HAVE TALKED TO ALL THE
HOSPITALS THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
GIVE US ACCESS TO ALL THE
PATIENTS THAT WE HAD CREE COVE
IT. AND SO THE DATA LANDSCAPE
ALONE AS DIRECT CARE PATIENTS-
OF DIRECT PATIENT CARE WILL
CHANGE FOR OUR SENIORS AND
STUDENTS TO BE PREPARED AND
TRAINED APPROPRIATELY SO TO
CLOSE THAT GAP WE DO HAVE TO
HAVE SOME RELATION OF SOME
SORT. TO ADDRESS THE GAPS THAT
EVENTUALLY WILL COST A SAFETY.
ISSUE TO OUR PUBLIC. IF WE
DON'T TRAIN THEM WELL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
REST BEFORE I TURNED THE
CALIFORNIA STATE- MEMBER ME ASK
YOU OTHER ARE A POINT OF THE
ARE THERE ANY SPECIFIC
RESTRICTIONS ON YOUR CLINICAL
PLACEMENT OPPORTUNITIES AS THEY
AS A PUBLIC PUBLICLY FUNDED
NURSING SCHOOL SUCH AS-
PLACEMENT DISTANCE FROM SCHOOL
TO PLACEMENT OPPORTUNITY AT
CETERA ANY ANY ANY OTHER
BARRIERS TO. PARTICIPATING IN
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS BESIDES THE
WILLINGNESS OF THE OF THE-
TRAINING FACILITY TO HAVE
SIGNED AN AGREEMENT WITH YOU.
WELL THIS IS A TRAINING
AGREEMENT- I MEAN THE TRAINING
AFFILIATION AGREEMENT I MUST
SAY SOME OF THE BARRIERS ARE
JUST ACCESS TO QUALITY FACULTY.
AND ACCESS TO GOOD QUALITY
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS READ THE
NOT HAVE THAT RESOURCE AS SOME
OTHER SCHOOLS MAY HAVE- UP TO
HELP THE FACILITY WITH OTHER
THINGS THEN. TRAINING OUR
STUDENTS WE REALLY DULL AND.
AND RIGHT NOW. THE DOOR SORT
ARE BEING CLOSE ON US FOR BEING
VERY SELECTIVE FONG ON THE
PUBLIC STATE FUNDED ESPECIALLY
THE SOCIO DEGREE PROGRAMS JUST
BECAUSE THEY PREFER THE BADGERS
PREPARE FOR SAYS ALTHOUGH THEY
KNOW THAT OUR STUDENTS ARE
GOING INTO VENTURES DEGREE
PROGRAM. PROGRAM AND THE THIRD
SEMESTER WHEN THEY ARE STILL
VERY DISCRIMINATORY SO I MUST
SAY MY PROGRAM DIRECTOR THERE'S
A TIRED. AT THE HEART OF BOYS
BOMBING YOU HAVE TO SINK
QUALITYEDUCATION S. THE OTHER.
SCHOOLS CAN HAVE REPORTED. MY
QUESTION REAL WENT TO EXAMPLE
IF IT IT I DON'T. IF YOU WERE
ABLE TO SECURE REPLACEMENT FOR
EXAMPLE AN ACUTE PLACERS THE
PLACEMENTS OF THE CUTE CARE
FACILITY THAT WAS LOCATED
SEVENTY FIVE MILES. FROM YOUR
SCHOOL OR SIXTY MILES FROM YOUR-
CLASSROOM. IS THAT A BARRIER TO
PARTICIPATION AND IF SO HOW ARE
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
UNLESS IT IS AN OVERALL AREA
AND I'VE WORKED WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN THE RURAL AREA SUCH
AS BLYTH AND OTHER AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA BUT A FAR AWAY WHEN
DRIVING AT A HUNDRED MILES TO
THE NEAREST HOSPITAL IS A
COMMON THING. BUT IN IN THE
METROPOLITAN AREA ANYTHING
ABOVE FIFTY MILES IS A ALREADY
A STRETCH FOR ME COLLEGE
STUDENTS THESE ARE STUDENTS WHO
ARE BARELY MAKING AN INCOME AND
TRYING TO GO INTO A NURSING
PROGRAM SO THEY CAN CHANGE
THEIR LIVES LIKE IDEAS AND
BEING ABLE TO. OPEN THEMSELVES
TO A NEW CAREER TO GET TO HAVE
THAT GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT SO YES
THE HAVING ãNSPORTATION
THE LOAN IS A CHALLENGE DURING
THIS PANDEMIC OUR STUDENTS AND
EVEN HAVE COMPUTERS TO BE
ONLINE TO COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATION ONLINE THAT'S WHAT WE
WOULD DISBURSING COMPUTERS WE
WERE GIVING REFUNDS ON SEVERAL
THINGS AND WE EVEN TRIED TO
OFFSET THEIR TEXTBOOKS AND
OTHER LEARNING RESOURCES
THROUGH OTHER OPPORTUNITIES AND
MEANS. THAT THE STATE HAS
PROVIDED FOR US SO YES THOSE
ARE CHAIRED CHALLENGES AND
BARRIERS TO DRIVE TO THAT LATE
HOURS TO BE ABLE TO CALL TO
MAKE SURE FOR CLINICAL
ROTATIONS. THANK YOU WITH OVER
KELLY SAYING QUESTIONS IF THE
BEER AND CHANGE THE RULES
TOMORROW ON A GO FORWARD BASIS
WOULD THE CAL STATE FACE ANY
OBSTACLES IN YOUR VIEW TOWARD
INCREASED USE OF SIMULATION.
BEYOND WHAT YOU'RE ABLE TO DO
NOW. NO I WOULD BE JUST IT
WOULD NICE TO HAVE THAT FLEX.
ESPECIALLY IN A WERE WE HAVE
MUCH. WITH PLAY. I MEAN I'M NOT
IS A CLINICAL SIMULATION DOES
NOT REPLACE DIRECT CARE WE ALL
ARE AWARE OF THAT. BUT IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL IN SITUATIONS WHERE
WE NEED IT LIKE IT'S LIKE
MENTAL HEALTH. I DON'T THINK
I'M GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET
ENOUGH SITES FOR FALL SO IT
WOULD BE NICE TO CONTINUE WITH
THAT. 75% SIMULATION 25% DIRECT
HERE BUT OF COURSE IF WE ARE
ABLE TO- YOU KNOW I HAVE SITES
FOR MEDICAL SURGICAL NURSING WE
WOULD. WE WOULD WANT TO HAVE
THE HIGHEST THAT WE WERE ABLE
TO HELP FOR DIRECT CARE HOURS.
IN TERMS OF COST IT HASN'T
REALLY BEEN AN ISSUE IT IS
DOCTOR WAXMAN MENTION.
SIMULATIONS CHANGED OVER THE
PAST TWELVE YEARS OR SO. YEAH
IT'S NOT ALL AMERICAN BASED
AND- WHEN THE PANDEMIC FIRST
HIT IN MARCH OF TWENTY WE HAD
TO JUMP TO REMOTE. LEARNING FOR
OUR CLASSROOMS AND WE ALSO
JUMPED TO REMOTE. AN ONLINE
SIMULATION THAT WORKED ACTUALLY
REALLY REALLY WELL. AND WHICH
THOSE PRODUCTS THAT WE HAVE.
FOR ONLINE SIMULATION. WE CAN
ACTUALLY. SERVE THOSE WHO ARE
REMOTE FROM FAR AWAY- AND YOU
CAN HAVE THEM PARTICIPATE IN
SIMULATION FROM A DISTANCE SO.
THERE'S A LOT OF OPTIONS OUT
THERE THAT ARE AVAILABLE AND-
IT WOULD JUST BE NICE TO HAVE
THE FLEXIBILITY. YOU KNOW AS
EDUCATORS WE KNOW WHAT'S BEST
FOR STUDENTS. AND WE CERTAINLY
WOULDN'T WANT TO. NOT HAVE A
HAVE CLINICAL EXPERIENCE WHEN
IT WAS AVAILABLE. THANK YOU FOR
THAT THE RESPONSE MAYBE I'LL
ASK- EVERYONE TO JUMP IN AT
THIS POINT ANYONE WHO STILL ON
THE LINE LET ME ASK. ONE I
THINK FINAL QUESTION HAS TO DO
WITH CLINICAL PLACEMENTS YOU
KNOW- GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE
NEED MORE NURSES AT LEAST I
THINK THAT'S BEEN ESTABLISHED.
CERTAINLY IN SOME PARTS OF THE
STATE FOR SURE AND PERHAPS POST
COVERED IN EVEN MORE PARTS OF
THE STATE- WHAT CAN WE DO.
WHETHER IT'S THE B. R. N. OR
ANY OF THE REST OF YOU ON THE
LINE WHAT CAN WE DO TO DEAL
WITH THIS CLINICAL PLACEMENT
ISSUE. ROSS THE BOARDS SO WE
ENSURE THAT. OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE NURSING PROGRAMS IN THE
STUDENTS IN THOSE PROGRAMS THE
STUDENTS IN OUR- CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY. SYSTEM
PROGRAMS- STUDENTS AND OTHER.
PUBLIC INSTITUTION PROGRAMS IN
THE STATE AND CERTAINLY ARE- A
NOT FOR PROFIT AND PROFIT TO
THE PRIVATE SECTOR STUDENTS.
WERE ABLE TO SECURE THE
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS THAT THEY
NEED IN ORDER TO. FINISH
PROGRAMS AND- SECURE A
LICENSURE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ANY TAKERS- I'D LIKE
I'D LIKE TO MAKE A FEW COMMENTS
AND IF I MAY- I THINK ONE OF
THE SOLUTIONS WOULD BE TO ALLOW
THE SCHOOLS. THAT HAVE.
RESOURCES AND HAVE TRAINED
FACULTY- TO MOVE 250% BECAUSE
THEY ARE FOLLOWING THE
STANDARDS. IN THE MEANTIME WITH
FUNDING FOR THE OTHERS. TO GET
MORE FOLKS TRAINED AND THEN
MOVED TO THE FIFTY PERCENT. I
ALSO WANT TO REITERATE THAT THE
INS SIMULATION WE CAN GUARANTEE
A CLINICAL EXPERIENCE. IF WE
NEED OUR STUDENTS TO. LEARN
ABOUT- CONGESTIVE HEART FAILURE
AND THAT PATIENT ISN'T
AVAILABLE IN THE CLINICAL
SETTING. AND THEY DON'T GET AN
OPPORTUNITY TO- CARE FOR THAT
PATIENT WE CAN SET UP A
SCENARIO IN SIMULATION TO
GUARANTEE THOSE EXPERIENCES.
AND I THINK ABOUT WHAT'S WHAT A
BIG DIFFERENCE IS NOW AS IT WAS
TWENTY THIRTY YEARS AGO. WE
WHEN PATIENTS WERE IN FOR A
LONG TIME IN A HOSPITAL. WE CAN
NOW- GUARANTEE THAT. THAT
EXPERIENCE IN SIMULATION AND
NOT WORRY ABOUT THEM NOT
GETTING THAT EXPERIENCE IN A
HOSPITAL SETTING. SO THAT WOULD
BE MY FIRST SUGGESTION IS THAT
THE SCHOOLS AND LIKE- DOCTOR
ALERT KELLY SCHOOL WHO HAVE
TRANSACTION TO RESOURCES. ALLOW
THEM THE FLEXIBILITY TO MOVE
250% IN THE MEANTIME. WE CAN
HELP GET EVERYONE ELSE IN THE
STATE TRAINED. TO- MEET THOSE
STANDARDS ONE BEFORE I. REALLY
LOWER RIVER DEALS TO ON. PILOTA
I COULD SAY. DO WE HAVE ANY
REASONABLE ASSURANCE THAT THE
MOVE 250% SIMULATION WOULD
SOLVE THE CLINICAL PLACEMENT
ISSUE. SENATOR ROB THIS IS
LAURIE FROM THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING I CAN
PROVIDE SOME INSIGHT INTO THAT
THANK YOU- HOPING YOU JUMP IN
HERE. THANK YOU WELL I'VE BEEN
WAITING PATIENTLY I WANTED
EVERYBODY ELSE HAVE A CHANCE TO
SPEAK- YOU KNOW I STUDIED UNDER
KßT WAXMAN- BACK IN TWENTY
TEN I TOOK SUMMER COURSES AND-
WHEN I WAS ENROLLED IN A PHD
PROGRAM MY DISSERTATION IS
GONNA BE A SIMULATION. HOWEVER-MY MOM FELL ILL AND I HAD TO
DROP OUT SO I HAVE NOT YET
FINISHED WITH THAT THAT'S IN
THE FUTURE. IF WE ARE AND
ESTABLISHES MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS. RIGHT NOW THAT WE
ARE IN A SILENCE ON SIMULATION
WE DON'T HAVE ANY REGULATIONS
OVERSTIMULATION SO IN FACT OUR
SCHOOLS CAN DO WHATEVER THEY
WANT. WITH THOSE HOURS THAT ARE
NOT IN DIRECT PATIENT CARE AND
DO SIMULATION IT THE ABILITY TO
SUPPORT THAT THEY CAN ALSO DO
OTHER LEARNING MODALITIES THAT
MEET THEIR CLINICAL OBJECTIVES.
I THINK THAT WE ARE IN FROM
BIARRITZ PERSPECTIVE THE GOAL
IS TO ESTABLISH A MINIMUM
CRITERIA. RIGHT NOW NCSP AND
WHO WAS ON THAT CALL IS DOING A
STUDY. BIERSTADT WISHING
MINIMUM. DIRECT PATIENT CARE
HOURS. I BELIEVE BY. TO THE
PEOPLE C-SPAN THAT BABEL THAT
DATA OUT TO US AS SOON AS THIS
FALL. THAT DATA IF THEY STATE
THAT THE MINIMUM DIRECT PATIENT
CARE HOURS ARE FIVE HUNDRED
THEN I THINK CALIFORNIA CAN
MOVE TOWARDS ESTABLISHING A
MINIMUM DIRECT PATIENT CARE
HOURS OF FIVE HUNDRED. AND THEN
THE SCHOOLS CAN DO AS MUCH
SIMULATION ABOVE THAT AS THEY
CHOOSE TO DO SCHOOLS THAT HAVE
THE ABILITY 225% CAN BE 25%
SCHOOL THAT ABILITY TO THE 550%
CAN DO FIFTY PERCENT. SCHOOLS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO 75% CAN
DO 75% WHAT WE ESTABLISH IS A
DIRECT PATIENT CARE OUR AND WE
STAY SILENT ON SIMULATION SO
THAT THE VARIOUS PEOPLE THAT
STAND BY THEIR SIMULATION
STANDARDS. AND THEIR ABILITY TO
SUPPORT THE SIMULATION
STANDARDS CAN MOVE FORWARD AND
HAVE THEIR UNIQUE CRITERIA THAT
MEANS THAT THERE REGIONAL
NEEDS. WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
NCSP UNSTEADY ON 50% SAM BAY
ESTABLISHED SIX HUNDRED HOURS
AS THE MINIMUM HOUR REQUIREMENT
ON THAT STUDY SO IF WE COME IN
ANYWHERE NEAR THERE WE'VE GOT
THAT IF WE LOOK AT TODAY'S
CURRENT ESTABLISHED NUMBERS. WE
MEET THAT WE ARE AT. OR BELOW
SIX HUNDRED HOURS IN A
REQUIREMENT ON A RIDICULOUSLY
ELABORATE- THE EQUATION IN OUR
REGULATIONS THAT WE SHOULD
REALLY BE PROACTIVE AND FIX-
INNER APR AND RAISED IN
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WE STATE
FIVE HUNDRED DIRECT PATIENT
CARE HOURS FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS. I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT CALIFORNIA CAN
CONSIDER WHEN LOOKING AT IT IS
JUST STATE YOU KNOW FIVE
HUNDRED HOURS DIRECT PATIENT
CARE HOURS AND THEN BE DONE-
THAT ALLOWS FOR THAT
FLEXIBILITY THAT ALLOWS FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IF THEY
DON'T HAVE FUNDING FOR
SIMULATION. THEY MEET THE FIVE
HUNDRED HOURS THEY'RE DONE THEY
WALK IF YOU DO HAVE A FACILITY
THAT HAS THE ABILITY TO SUPPORT
SIMULATION THEN THEY CAN DO A
SIMULATION ON TOP OF WHAT WE
STATUS AS A STANDARD FOR
LICENSE. ANOTHER THING THAT IT
BECAME REALLY AFFECT. THE
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS. IS THE B.
R. ESTABLISHES MINIMUM OF UNITS
WE HAVE EIGHT YEAR THAT WORK.
FOR THE TOLD PROGRAM TO BE
DINING IN CLINICAL. WE ONLY
HAVE OF SMALL PORTION OF
STUDENTS OF SORRY ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS THAT MEET THAT
MINIMUM SEVERAL AND I'M I'M
TRYING TO STRESS THAT WORDS
SEVERAL GO ABOVE THE MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS WHEN WE LOOK AT
OUR AB AND PROGRAMS. THIRTY OF
THE NINETY ONE MEET EIGHTEEN
UNITS THE REST ARE ABOVE THE
EIGHTEEN UNITS IF WE LOOK AT
RBS SAID FIVE OF THE FORTY ONE
MEET OUR MINIMUM THE RESTAURANT
BOB THE MINIMUM. WE LOOK AT OUR
ENTRY LEVEL MASTER'S FIVE MEET
THE MINIMUM. OF THE TWELVE THE
REST ARE ABOVE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
ONE UNITS THAT'S IN EXCESS OF
THE B. R. IN REQUIREMENTS
THAT'S AN ADDITIONAL FORTY
EIGHT HOURS THAT THAT STUDENT
IS OUT IN THE CLINICAL SETTING.
YOU MULTIPLY THAT BY A HUNDRED
STUDENTS WHICH IS AT YOU KNOW
SOME DIFFICULT MOMENTS FOR SOME
OF OUR SCHOOLS. THAT'S FOUR
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED HOURS IN
A CLINICAL SETTING THAT IS NOT
REQUIRED BY THE B. R. AND- SO I
THINK OUR SCHOOLS. AS MENTIONED
BEFORE OKAY STANDARD CURRICULUM
WITH WE DID A INIMUM
REQUIREMENTS. AND THAT'S ALL
THAT THEY MET. THEN IT AND THEN
WE ESTABLISHED A MINIMUM DIRECT
PATIENT CARE WITH ABSENT IN
SILENT LIKE WE CURRENTLY AREN'T
REGULATIONS SILENCE ON THE
SIMULATION. I THINK WE CAN MAKE
A HUGE MOVES AND HAVEN'T AND
EQUITABLE SOLUTION FOR OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND OUR
PRIVATE COLLEGES- ARE EIGHTY
AND AS WELL AS OUR B. S. SENATE
ELN BECAUSE AGAIN WE DON'T HAVE
TO BE AROUND ESTABLISH
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS. WE
ESTABLISHED LICENSE
REQUIREMENTS WHICH IS MUCH MUCH
LESS- AND THAT ALLOWS FOR THE
DEANS AND DIRECTORS WHO ARE THE
EXPERTS IN THIS KNOW WHAT THEIR
STUDENTS NEED TO. KNOW WHAT
CURRICULA BEST SUITS THEM KNOW
WHAT RESOURCES THEY HAVE
INCLUDING THE FACULTY TO GO
AHEAD AND STAB WISH WHAT SERVES
THE BAND AND THEIR COMMUNITY. I
THINK WE CAN WORK TOGETHER ON
THIS I THINK WE HAVE SOME GREAT
DISCUSSIONS I THINK WE HAVE A
LOT OF GOOD EVIDENCE COMING
OUT. AND I THINK WHEN WE KIND
OF STICK WITH THE PERCENTAGE
WE'RE TYING OUR HANDS. I THINK
THAT WE ARE IN AS A REGULATORY
BODY IF WE JUST PUT A MINIMUM-DIRECT PATIENT CARE
REQUIREMENTS. AND THE SCHOOLS
THAT ARE ABLE TO DO WHAT THEY
NEED TO A SIMULATION WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A MINIMUM DIRECT
PATIENT CARE REQUIREMENT WHICH
ESTABLISHED PATIENT SAFETY
WHICH IS WHAT OUR FOCUS IS A B.
R. N. AND THEN BEYOND THAT. IS
SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO
GET INTO THE WEEDS ABOUT. SO
PARTICULARLY FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES OR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
NURSING PROGRAMS. THAT ARE ARE
IN A BIT OF A DIFFERENT
SITUATION- THAN THAN THE OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT ARE PARTICIPATED
TODAY. BASED ON THE FUNDING
LEVEL AND THE FEES CHARGED OR
NOT- THE FUNDING OF THE
PARTICULAR PROGRAMS THE WAY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES GENERALLY
ARE FUNDED IN THE LIMITATIONS
ON BRICK AND MORTAR AND-
FACULTY ALIKE. THOSE THAT ARE
ABLE TO GO ABOVE. THE MINIMUM
BECAUSE OF THE THERE ARE
SITUATIONS IN THE REACH IN
TERMS OF ACUTE ON. THAT ARE TO
MAKE LOTS OF A- LIKE. FOR FREE
TO SO THOSE THAT. NOT FOR SOME
REASON SECURE THOSE A DIRECT
PATIENT CARE OPPORTUNITIES
ABOVE THE MINIMUM THEY COULDMOVE TO OTHER SOURCES. IF THEY
WANT TO PURSUE ADDITIONAL
TRAINING FOR STUDENTS BEFORE
THEY GRADUATE THE- ABSOLUTELY
WE HAVE OUR PATIENTS SAFETY WE
ARE NURSING STUDENTS TAKING
CARE OF AND SAFETY AND PROVIDED
WITH AN ADEQUATE TRAINING. THAT
IS THE DIRECT PATIENT CARE
THAT'S WHAT EVERYBODY WANTS YOU
CAN'T YOU CAN'T LEARN TO SMELL
INFECTION WHEN YOU'RE STANDING
IN FRONT OF A MAN I CAN'T YOU
CAN'T JUDGE A BODY LANGUAGE
WHEN YOU WALK INTO THE ROOM YOU
NEED A SERVICE. A SOCIOLOGY I'M
SORRYA PSYCHOLOGY CONSULTATION
BECAUSE SOMEBODY FLINCHED WHEN
HE WALKED IN THE ROOM THOSE ARE
THINGS THAT ARE REQUIRED BY
DIRECT PATIENT CARE- EXPERIENCE
AND WE CAN ESTABLISH THAT
MINIMUM WE CAN ASSURE THAT
THEIR STATE. THERE'S NOT MUCH
THAT WE HAVE TO CHANGE WITH OUR
REGULATIONS TO DO THAT AND IT
OPENS THE DOOR FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS TO IMPLEMENT WHAT
THEY CAN'T AND WHAT SERVES
THEIR REACH. AND WE'RE
CERTAINLY I THINK YOU'RE IN THE
LEGISLATURE GOING TO HAVE TO
FOCUS NOT ONLY ON OUR
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
PROGRAMS BUT CERTAINLY ON OUR-
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROGRAMS TO
MAKE SURE THAT. WE PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES- THAT WE PROBABLY
HAVE NOT PROVIDED IN THE PAST
FOR THOSE PROGRAMS TO GIVE.
THOSE PROGRAMS AN EQUAL CHANCE
OF SUCCESS FOR THEIR PROGRAMS
AND FOR THE STUDENTS THAT
ENROLL IN THEM. ANYONE ELSE
WANT TO JUMP IN ON THAT LAST
QUESTION WHAT DO WE DO. WITH
THE CLINICAL PLACEMENT ISSUES.
I DON'T YES MA'AM I THINK WE
ALSO NEED TO LOOK AT SOME OF
THE OTHER REGULATIONS RELATED
TO CONCURRENCY AND- WAS REMOVED
BROWN'S OVERSIGHT WITH THE
CLINICAL CLINICAL PLACEMENT
APPROVALS I THINK THAT ALSO
NEEDS TO BE EXAMINED. WHAT
ABOUT THE COULD CURRENT ISSUE
CLINICAL TRAINING VERSUS THEORY
COURSES AND- I KNOW IN OTHER
PROFESSIONS OF. YOU'RE ABLE TO
SEPARATE CLINICAL FROM THEORY
FRONT LOAD SOME BACK LOAD
OTHERS I UNDERSTAND THERE'S
SOME ISSUES. HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA NURSING PROGRAMS
THAT FORCE THEM- WELL IT'S BEEN
DIFFICULT FOR US DURING THE
PANDEMIC. BECAUSE THE STUDENTS
WHO WERE UNABLE TO COMPLETE
THEIR CLINICAL HOURS DURING A
PARTICULAR SEMESTER THAN WE
WERE WE'RE STRUGGLING WITH- THE
CONCURRENCY OF THEIR DEGREE
COURSE IN THE SUMMER OR THE
SUBSEQUENT SEMESTER. AND IT
JUST ADDED TO THE COMPLEXITY OF
THE ISSUES WE WERE FACING WITH
HAVING STUDENTS MOVE FORWARD-
AND THEN ALSO RELATED TO- ORDER
THROUGH ALL ADDITIONAL APPROVAL
FOR CLINICAL SITES- SOMETIMES
THAT THAT LIMITS US. IN TERMS
OF GETTING ADDITIONAL SITES
ESPECIALLY SINCE NURSING IS
LOOKING MORE TOWARDS. A
POPULATION BASED HEALTH CARE
AND AMBULATORY CARE SOMETIMES
JUST THE RED TAPE AND THE
BUREAUCRACY OF GETTING
ADDITIONAL SITES APPROVED
THROUGH THE B. R. AND- IS NOT
ENCOURAGING TRUSTOR CHANNEL
SITES EVEN THOUGH THEY MAY BE
THERE SO. I JUST WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THAT THOSE THOSE ISSUES ARE
LOOKED AT AND I DID SEE THEM IN
THE REPORT SOMETHING. I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU SEE
THAT I HAVE SOME INPUT ON THAT
TOO IF YOU'LL GIVE ME A CHANCE
HERE MOBERLY OF THE DEANS AND
DIRECTORS WITH THEIR CREDITORS
AND- ONE IT IS ONE THAT WE
NOTICED IN REGULATION AS WE DO
NOT HAVE A REQUIREMENT TO RE
APPROVED CLINICAL PLACEMENTS.
SO IF WE DID ONE CLINICAL
APPROVAL FOR AN INSTITUTION-
AND THEY HAD IT IN A DAY BANK
IS SOMETHING WE'RE AT- THEY THE
SCHOOL COULD ACT THE DATA AND
STATE WAS STILL ALREADY- I
COULD SEE SCHOOLS THERE AND
THEN THAT WAY WE HAVE. THAT A
THE PROPLACE. AND ADDITIONAL
CLINICAL OF ARE NOT NEEDED- IT
COULD BE A ONE IN DONE IT IN
SCHOOL CAN YOU ONE EIGHT
CLINICAL APPROVAL- IT JUST THAT
WE DONE THE INITIAL PROBE TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S A- FOR AND
IT'S SAFE. YEAR. PERFECT
REPUBLICAN TO TOUCH A THE CAN.
ISSUE BECAUSE IT'S A REC. THAT
BUT IN THE PHYSICIAN TRAINING
FIELD AND PERHAPS OTHERS. ON
OCCASION. CLINICAL SPORTS FROM
THREE. YOU CAN FRONT LOAD ONE.
MAYBE NOT THE OTHER. HAS IT
BEEN ANY THOUGHT TO CHANGING
THE RULES ON THE CONCURRENCE
ISSUE AS IT PERTAINS TO NURSING
EDUCATION. CURRENT ISSUE IS A
LITTLE MORE DIFFICULT TO KIND
OF TOUCH ON BECAUSE- CLINICAL
BUILDS ON PIRI PIRI BILLS AND
CLINICAL IT'S A VERY SYMBIOTIC
RELATIONSHIP- AND I RECEIVED
COMPLAINTS FROM STUDENTS ON A
REGULAR BASIS SOME THAT I
FAILED OUT- AND SOME THAT ARE
HAPPEN TO CONTINUE IN SCHOOL
ONE OF THE COMPLAINTS THAT
STANDS OUT IN MY HEAD WAS A
WOMAN THAT CALLED ME AND SHE
WAS IN TEARS. SHE SAID SHE WAS
TAKING CARE OF A BABY THAT WAS
JAUNDICED WHO HAD- WHAT'S
CALLED A BILLION LIGHT ON HAND
IF SHE HADN'T HAD THE THEORY ON
IT YET. AND SHE DID NOT KNOW
THAT THAT BABY WAS SUPPOSED TO
HAVE- SOME GLASSES ON IT'S A AS
A PAPER PIECE THAT GOES OVER
THERE I. AND IT'S SO SHE CARED
FOR THE BABY SHE WAS UNDER THE
BILL THE LIKES AND IT DIDN'T
HAVE THE SUNGLASSES ON SHE
FAILED A CLINICAL BECAUSE SHE
HADN'T HAD THE THEORY ON IT.
AND SHE WASN'T NECESSARILY
CONCERNED ABOUT FILLING OUT A
CLINICAL WHICH SHE WAS CURRENT
STARTED WAS IT SHE MIGHT HAVE
BECAUSE THAT CAMPAIGN TO BE
BLIND AND HAVE VISUAL PROBLEMS
FOR THE REST OF ITS LIFE- THE
DANGER IS THERE. SO HAVING
CLINICALS CONCURRENCE WITH
EERIE IS SOMETHING THAT IS
SUPPORTED IN THE EVIDENCE-
PATRICIA BANNER THAT IS ONE OF
OUR NURSING CARE SETTINGS
COMPLETELY- WORLD RENOWNED-
TALKS ABOUT- HOW CLINICAL FEEDS
ON VERY VERY FEES AND CLICK ON
HOW TO SYMBIOTIC RELATIONSHIP.
HOW MANY DRESSES THAT THEORY
PRACTICE GAP THAT WE DO SEE
WITHIN OUR STUDENTS- AND WE DO
A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY IN A
SEMESTER. AT IT IS YOU CAN
FRONT LOAD BE COURSE THE STATE
TO SIXTEEN WEEK SEMESTER THE
FIRST EIGHT WEEKS COULD BE. A
SECOND EIGHT WEEKS CAN BE KIND
OF CALL- YOU CAN THAT YOU CAN
DO THAT THERE'S PLENTY OF
PROGRAMS OUT THERE THAT DO IT I
DO HAVE A PROGRAM THAT HAD A
SIXTEEN WEEK SEMESTER. THE
FIRST FOUR WEEKS FOR THEORY THE
SECOND TWO WEEKS FROM LAB AND
THE REMAINING WEEKS FOR
CLINICAL PRACTICE- IN SO THEY
CAN BE FLEXIBLE WITH THE IN
THAT TIME FRAME TO ALLOW FOR
THEIR SCHEDULING AND THEIR
OUTCOMES THAT GO TO SCHOOL THEY
DID THAT WERE FANTASTIC. THERE
AND CLICK PASSAGE WERE. THEY
WERE HAPPY WITH THE GRADUATES
TO BE PRODUCED AS WELL- SO
THERE ARE FLEXIBILITY BUT I
THINK WE STILL NEED BE VERY
CAREFUL WITH THAT BECAUSE WITH
THE NURSING CARE RESEARCH REST.
YOUR HUGE BREASTS THERE'S A
HUGE RISK FOR OUR STUDENTS- AND
I KNOW THAT IT'S BEEN
INTERESTING SIMULATION AND
SIMULATION IS THERE AND IT'S
ABSOLUTELY HELPFUL- AND THAT'S
WHY WHEN AB. TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT WAS WRITTEN THEY WROTE
INTO IT THAT THE SIMULATION
PART. NEEDED TO BE CONCURRENT
WITH GARY AND THEN THAT THE
CLINICAL CAN FOLLOW BECAUSE
THEY WERE VERY MUCH AWARE OF-
NEEDED TO HAVE. THAT
CORRELATION SO- THAT'S THAT'S A
DIFFICULT QUESTION BECAUSE IT
IS SUCH A RISK. THAT YOU WHEN
YOU GO TO CLINICALS AND YOU'RE
JUST HAD GARY THANK CREATES
QUESTIONS WHEN YOU'RE IN
CLINICALS YOU HAVE THOSE
EXPERIENCES YOU BRING IT BACK
TO THAT AREA SECOND SEE THIS IS
WHAT I EXPERIENCED. CAN YOU
EXPLAIN THIS AND THEN THEY GO
MORE IN DEPTH WITHOUT WITH FURY
SO I HOPE THAT THAT HELPS. AND
ALL BUT A REAL TENSOR WOMAN'S
MOBILE I GUESS- COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND THAT. THESE
PARTICULARLY AT THE- COLLEGE
CALL LEVEL THE NATURE THE
STUDENT. WHO GRAVITATES TOWARD
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE- NURSING
PROGRAM. IT IS THERE ANY
POSSIBILITY TO CONSIDER THE
SEPARATION OF THEORY AND
CLINICAL IN THAT THE THREE
COMES FIRST. BUT IF A STUDENT
IS NOT ABLE TO SECURE A- A
CLINICAL PLACEMENT BECAUSE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROGRAM CAN'T
FIND ONE. IN THAT PARTICULAR
SEMESTER IS THE STUDENT ABLE
TO. FINISH THE CLINICAL IN THE
FOLLOWING SEMESTER. HAVING
TAKEN THE THEORY FIRST. AND I
THINK WHAT WE COME INTO AN
ISSUE WITH THAT IS IT IT IT'S
KIND OF LIKE A BAD PAYDAY LOAN.
IS THEN YOUR TAKING CLINICAL
TIME FROM THE NEXT SEMESTER
THAT THAT CLINICAL IS NEEDED
AND THE STUDENTS COMING IN. SO
IT IT IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
PIPELINE OF NURSING IF YOU'RE
LOOKING AT PROGRESSION OF ALL
OF THE CLASSES THAT ARE COMING
IN AND THE CLASSES THAT ARE
MOVING OUT. YOU NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S
CLINICAL REQUIREMENTS EACH ONE
OF THOSE SEMESTERS SO IF YOU
HOLD OVER TWENTY HOURS OF
CLINICAL FROM A SEMESTER AND
ADDED TO THE NEXT ONE. YOU
STILL HAVE YOUR SEMESTER
REQUIREMENT ALREADY THERE OF
THE CLASSES YOU'RE GOLDEN AND
THEN YOU HAVE TO PICK UP THE
ADDITIONAL TWENTY AND THAT'S
ALREADY IN A CLINICAL PLACEMENT
THAT'S ALREADY HIGHLY IMPACTED.
SO IT'S LIKE YOU'RE BORROWING
FROM PETER TO PAY PAUL I DON'T
KNOW THAT THAT STEPS NECESSARY
TO SOLUTION AND THAT'S WHERE
THE BOARD IS COMING IN
REPEATEDLY WHEN WE LOOK AT
RESOURCES. IS DO YOU HAVE THE
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS TO SUPPORT
THE STUDENTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
ENROLLED IN YOUR PROGRAM. AND
IF NOT WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT- THERE ARE OPTIONS
THERE ARE ANY SEIZE WORKED
TIRELESSLY WITH THE PROGRAM
DIRECTORS WHEN THEY CALL AND
SAY HEY I LOST A CLINICAL SITE
CAN YOU HELP ME. AND WE PROVIDE
THEM SEVERAL OPPORTUNITIES- AND
OPTIONS IN ORDER TO DO THAT- I
DON'T KNOW THAT THERE'S A ONE
ANSWER FOR THIS BUT I DO
CAUTION YOU. ONLINE THE
CONCURRENCY INFERI SEPARATION
THAT OPENS UP TO A LOT OF RISK
THAT OPENS UP TO A LOT OF
DISPLACEMENT ISSUES. AND IT
TRULY WILL IMPEDE THE
PROGRESSION OF THE STUDENT
VERSUS. HELPING THEM PROGRESS
BECAUSE WHEN YOU BORROW FIFTY
BUCKS FROM YOUR NEXT PAYCHECK
IN YOUR ALREADY SHORT. YOU
SUCKED IT PAY THAT COULD BE
BUCKS BACK AND ADD THAT NEXT
PAYCHECK AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT
COMES INTO EACH OTHER CRITICAL
REQUIREMENT THAT NEXT SEMESTER.
YOU DON'T WANT TO ADD CLINICAL
HOURS TO THAT NEXT SEMESTER
BECAUSE THAT JUST. CAUSES MORE
ABOUT DEMANDS. COOPER HAS THE
ONE THAT CAN BE CAN. IN WE
ESTABLISH A- EIGHTEEN UNITS. WE
DO NOT STAY YOU HAVE TO HAVE TO
YOU OF P. YOU HAVE TO HAVE A-
UNITS OF. LIKE WE LET THE
SCHOOLS DECIDE WE JUST EIGHTEEN
UNITS SO IF THEY'RE HAVING A
DIFFICULT TIME. GETTING
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS IN SIGHT.
THEN MAYBE THEY CAN CONSIDER
THAT THEY ONLY NEED A SMALLER
AMOUNT A UNIT. IN THAT SITE TO
ADEQUATELY MEET THEIR OUTCOMES-
AND THAT AGAIN DECREASES AGAIN
EVERY UNIT IS FORTY EIGHT
HOURS. IN A CLINICAL THAT CAN
BE MOVED AROUND FROM A STUDENT.
AND THAT'S WHAT I WAS GONNA SAY
PERHAPS YOUR MOVE TOWARDS
SETTING UP. MEDICAL MINIMUM
DIRECT PATIENT CONTACT LEVEL
AND- PERHAPS THE SCHOOLS THAT
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
SIMULATION THAT'S PERMITTED IN
THEIR PROGRAMS WELL SORT OF
LEVEL OUT THIS CLINICAL
PLACEMENT ISSUE. AROUND THE
STATE IN THAT REGARD I'M I'M
HOPING THAT THE BOARD IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE VARIOUS
SCHOOLS AND MAYBE THE
ASSOCIATIONS. CAN HELP FIGURE
OUT HOW TO COLLECT DATA SO WE
CAN GET SOME IDEA AS TO WHETHER
THIS CLINICAL PLACEMENT.
SITUATION REMAINS AN ISSUE.
FOLLOWING THE CHANGES IN
MINIMUM TRAINING REQUIREMENTS.
OR NOT AND THAT WILL HELP US
ASSESS THE CURRENT SITUATION
WITH RESPECT TO NURSING
EDUCATION THANK YOU FOR THE
RESPONSE. DOES ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS BEFORE- BUT CHECK WITH
MY COLLEAGUES TO SEE IF ANYONE
HAS ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS AND
WE MOVE ON ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS. I HAVE I HAVE A
COMMENT I WANTED TO JUST
MENTION THAT THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES OF
NURSING HAS RECENTLY- REVISED
THERE EAT THERE EAST CENTRAL'S
FOR EACH OF THE LEVELS OF
EDUCATION. AND THEY ARE MOVING
TOWARDS A COMPETENCY BASED
EDUCATION OUR SYSTEM SO WHY ARE
WE FOCUSED ON OURS WHEN WE LOOK
NEED TO LOOK AT COMPETENCY. AND
AS IT'S BEEN MENTIONED EARLIER
THE FACULTY DEANS AND DIRECTORS
ARE ABLE THEIR EXPERTS THEY
KNOW WHAT THE STUDENTS NEED
ENTIRE IN TERMS OF- THE
METHODOLOGY THAT WILL BEST MEET
THE LEARNING OUTCOMES. SO IF
THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
COLLEGES OF NURSING IS MOVING
TOWARDS THIS WE SHOULD FOLLOW
SUIT IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
INTERESTING COMMENTS ANYTHING
FURTHER PANELISTS I YES I STILL
I HOLD THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT VERY CLINICAL
CONCURRENCY ISSUE BECAUSE IT
DID SIGNIFICANTLY- AFFECT OUR
STUDENTS ABILITY TO PROGRESSIVE
PROGRAM BECAUSE STOP. THEY
NEEDED TO FINISH IN SUMMER BUT
YET THEY WORK AND HAVE TEARS SO
I JUST I JUST ASK THAT WE
CONTINUE TO EXAMINE THAT IT'S
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE AND AS LONG
AS THEORY COMES FIRST I TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND DOING CLINICAL
WITHOUT THE THEORY BEHIND IT
BUT- THE POINT IS TO HAVE A
THEORY FIRST AND PERHAPS IN
SUMMER OR SUBSEQUENT SEMESTER
APPLY THAT. IN A CRITICAL
SITUATION. THANK YOU. AND FOR
SURE OF THIS CLINICAL PLACEMENT
SITUATION- IT IS NOT RESOLVED
SOMEHOW I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO CERTAINLY REVISIT-
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS IN. IN THE
ORDER OF THINGS ANYTHING
FURTHER PANELISTS I SEE MY
COLLEAGUE IN ARCHULETA WANTS TO
ASK A QUESTION- YES THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AND I AT MY
HAT'S OFF TO YOU SIR YOU HAVE
DONE A FANTASTIC JOB- WITH
ADMINISTRATORS AND EVERYONE
THAT'S BEEN INVOLVED TODAY-
REPRESENTING. AND I'D LIKE TO
JUST POINT OUT THAT- I AM SO
IMPRESSED THAT THE PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC. SCHOOLS THAT ARE
WORKING TOGETHER TO ACCOMPLISH
THE SAME THING TO DELIVER TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
BRIGHTEST AND BEST NURSES WE
CAN GET- ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I APPRECIATE
THAT AND I HOPE THAT- THE BOARD
UNDERSTANDS THAT- WE WERE VERY
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT. THE TIME
FRAME TO GET THE LICENSES- TO
THESE INDIVIDUALS UPON
GRADUATION AND RUNNING THROUGH
THE SYSTEM AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE AND ALSO THAT THE
SCHOOLS UNDERSTAND IF THERE'S
ANYTHING THEY CAN DO TO HELP
THE PROCESS GETTING THE
STUDENTS FINGERPRINTED- HELPING
THEM ALONG SO THEY CAN.
GRADUATE AND HIT THE GROUND
RUNNING TO GO AHEAD AND OBTAIN
THEIR LICENSE SO THEY CAN START
PRACTICING- BUT WITH THAT I
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PRESENTATION DAY AND- I THANK
YOU FOR- THE WORK YOU DO. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SIR
FOR. WE WERE OUR EXTRA TO FROM
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING IN
THE TOPICS COVERED IN TODAY'S
AGENDA. LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY.
SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE. TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE URBIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT ABOUT THE BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FOR
COMMENTING CUBA FOR TWO ONE
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EXCUSE ME OVER TWENTY TWENTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE NEW CHAIR
THE MEMBERS IN PERSON AT THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT. WATER NURSING
WORKFORCE AND SUPPLY THERE MAY
BE REGIONAL SOURCES CHARGES BUT
PRIVATE NURSING SCHOOL
PROPONENTS CONTINUE TO ASSERT
THAT CALIFORNIA NURSING
SORTERS. THAT MUST BE ADDRESSED
BY CIRCUMVENTING THE BORDER
REGISTERED NURSING- EVENHANDED
EVALUATION OF NURSING PROGRAMS
YOU SEE OUT THERE ARE HOPE FOR
SINNERS CREDIBLE EVALUATION
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE ARE IN
WORKFORCE NEEDS INDICATES THAT
THERE IS A SUFFICIENT SUPPLY OF
NURSES. GRADUATING FROM NURSING
PROGRAMS PROVIDE THE CURRENT
ENROLLMENT NUMBERS ARE
MAINTAINED. AREAS LIKE
SACRAMENTO LOS ANGELES AND
THEN. HIGHER THERE MAYBE. EVEN
SURPLUS. ALL OF ALSO ARE IN THE
MARKET IN THE MORE COUNTIES IN
SOUTHERN BORDER THE WELL. FOR
THE MAKING SURE AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO CENTRAL VALLEY IS THE
REGION. FIVE IN NURSING SCHOOL
WANT TO EXPAND THEIR PROGRAMS
THE EXPENSE OF PUBLIC COMMUNITY
CALL NURSING. WHICH SERVE AT
THE ENTRY INTO THE NURSING
PROFESSION FOR MANY MORE INCOME
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR IN
CALIFORNIA. ASSEMBLY VERY FIVE
THE FOR PROFIT PROGRAMS CAN
COST MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND MILES.
NATIONWIDE FOR PROFIT NURSING
PROGRAMS HAVE INCREASED FOUR
HUNDRED AND 2% BY INCREASING
THEIR ENROLLMENT UNPACKED THE
PRIVATE SCHOOLS WILL CLOSE
PUBLIC COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS OUT OF HOSPITAL
PLACEMENTS THAT PREPARE THEM TO
BE REGISTERED NURSES. IT IS
ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE THIS
CHARGES ARE EXASPERATED BY
HOSPITALS AND FACILITIES
SPEAKING FEES AND AN
EXPERIENCED NURSES ALSO SEEKING
NEW GRAPPLES NOTED BY PHH TODAY.
ALTHOUGH SOME CONTEND THAT
DURING THE NURSING LIKE YOUR
CONTACT TO BROADEN THE POOL OF
NURSES ELIGIBLE TO WORK IN
CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER THE YOU
KNOW FEE HAS BEEN AROUND FOR
THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS AND YET
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE IT HAS LED
TO GREATER NURSE MOBILITY OR
INCREASED LABOR SUPPLY. DURING
THE CONTACT WITH UNDERMINE
PUBLIC PROTECTION Y INHIBITING
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO SET SET
STANDARDS THAT APPLY TO ALL
NURSES PRACTICING HERE. IT
WOULD ALSO RESTRICT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR UPWARD
MOBILITY. NURSES WHO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF CALIFORNIANS LPN
TO RN OPTIONS FOR THE MILITARY
OPTION WOULD BE IN ELIGIBLE FOR
LICENSURE UNDER THE CONTACT.
ALSO ADMITTED MELBY INDICATED
TODAY EVEN WITH THE IN L. C.
THE B. R. AND WOULD NEED TO
ADDRESS THE LICENSING BY
ENDORSEMENT PROCESS THE NURSES
WHO WANT TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
THEIR PRIMARY STATE OF
RESIDENCE RESIDENTS OR PS- ARE.
ADDITIONALLY TO BE OUR OWN HAVE
TO DROP THE LEXINGTON
VERIFICATION PROCESS THE NURSES
WHO WANT. TO ESTABLISH A NEW
PS- ARE. ALSO CAL DIDN'T NEED
YOU KNOW THE PAST. BECAUSE WE
HAVE A- EMERGENCY MEDICAL
AUTHORITY TO WITH NURSING STAFF.
NURSING STAFF LAW. IF THE HEAD.
ELEVEN THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY ARE AND IN IN P. ACT
IS DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
THESE ARE THE MOST RECENT
FIGURES FROM MARCH. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO VERIFY THAT DURING
THE CONTACT WITH MR CALIFORNIA
BILL WHICH IS YOU KNOW
BACKGROUND CHECKS IN MARIN TO
THE CRIMINAL ACTIVITY OF NURSES
PRACTICING IN THE STATE.
ORIGINAL CONTACT LANGUAGE DID
NOT REQUIRE FINGERPRINTING OR
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND SCREENING
APPLICANTS FOR OUR AND
LICENSOR. THIS REQUIREMENT
DIDN'T TAKE EFFECT UNTIL THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN NLP MODELS ANY
NERVES WE'VE BEEN LIGHTENED IN
THE LAST SEVENTEEN YEARS IN A
CONTACT STATE THE DOES NOT
REQUIRE FOR YOU FINGERPRINTING
WILL NOT HAVE BEEN BACKGROUND.
CHECKS TO THE NOTE SEE. SHE
ENABLE IT IS IN. TO MAKE SURE
THAT PUBLIC PROGRAMS NOT WE'VE
GOT A PRINCIPLES. RABBIT IN A
REGULAR EXPANSION OR PRIVATE.
FOR PROFIT PROGRAMS- MEMBERS OF
THE PANEL SPOKE ABOUT THIS
EARLIER TODAY 72% OF CALIFORNIA
NURSING PROGRAM OUR PUBLIC
PROGRAMS AND ARE EFFECTIVE TAX
RATE LAST YEAR WITH 90% NINETY
POINT 87% TO BE EXACT. COMPARE
THAT THE FLORIDA WORK 80% OF
THEIR NURSING PROGRAMS ARE
PRIVATE IN THEIR INCORRECT
PASSCODE RATE WAS ONLY. SIXTY
EIGHT POINT 83% ORDER ONLY. NO
PUBLIC PROGRAMS THREE WELL
ABOVE THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
WE'RE OUT THE PRIVATE PROGRAM
WILL BELOW THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
IN THE MEANTIME MANY STUDENTS
ARE LEFT WITH SIGNIFICANT DEBT.
AND UNABLE TO OBTAIN OUR
ELECTIONS. IN CALIFORNIA
THIRTEEN POINT 5% OF THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY IN FACT CHECKERS WORK ON
ONE. FOR PROFIT PRIVATE SCHOOL.
WITH THE NINE POINT 6% IMPACT
TAKERS IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. LAST
WEEK CNN THE POSES SUBSTITUTION
OF CLINICAL LEARNING WITH
ACTUAL PATIENT OR LEARNING IN A
HIGH FIDELITY SIMULATION
LABORATORY BEYOND WHAT IS
CURRENTLY ALLOW. THE MOST
SOPHISTICATED MANAGING COULD
NOT REPLICATE THE HUMAN
RESPONSE THE NURSING CARE OR
INDICATE THE SUBTLE CHANGES
THAT CAN OCCUR DURING THE
COURSE OF COURSE OF THE
ILLNESS. CANNOT REPLACE MENTOR
EXPONENTIAL TIME AGENT AN
ACTUAL ENVIRONMENT OF CARE. YOU
SHOULD BE EDUCATED SO THEY ARE
ABLE TO DEVELOP SKILLS AND
CRITICAL THINKING ABILITY
RATHER THAN SIMPLY. BEING
TRAINED IN TAP. THANK YOU AGAIN
THE OP TO IN DURING THE IN A
SUSPECT ONE IS THE STUFF FOR
THE PAST. AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO GO. THANK YOU GIVEN THE OF
THE YOU MAY WISH TO SOME THAT-
STAFF SO THAT WE FULLY DIGEST
IN CA. AS PART OF THE DELIVERY.
IN THESE REVIEW PROCESS- MARK
MYSTERON RETURN NEXT TO MS
MODERATOR. THANK YOU BRING
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
AND CAN YOU HEAR ME PERFECTLY
PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY AND- I
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE TO BEGIN
I AGREE WITH- I MY NAME IS
EVELYN DRINKER I AM A FORMER
ARIENNE PH AND GRADUATE AT THE
END OF THE STATE UNIVERSITY. I
TRANSFERRED THERE FOR NINETY
DAYS AFTER MY FATHER HAD A
STROKE I WAS ON A DIFFERENT
TRACK AT UC DAVIS AND- AT THE
TIME I WAS IN THE TOP TWO OR 3%
OF. OUR STUDENTS I THE UNITED
STATES GET IN THE UC DAVIS. AND
IT HAD A VERY- IT WOULD HELP. I
THINK WE'RE GREAT WITH MY
NURSING CAREER I. UNTIL I WAS
WHITE ABOUT LIKE THREE NURSES
THAT THEY'VE NEVER DISCIPLINE.
AND I WISH THEY WOULD AND SIX
MONTHS AGO THIS HAPPENED IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN. SIX MONTHS AGO I
RECEIVED A PACKET. AN OLD
BOYFRIEND HAD COLLECTED ON ME
REGARDING WHAT THE BOARD OF
NURSING HAD DONE WITH MY CASE.
I DON'T KNOW WHY IT FEELS
RELEASE THIS INFORMATION TO HIM.
I WOULD PROBABLY USE ME AS A AS
LATE AS MONDAY CALLING THE
WORDS I DON'T REPEAT. BETTER
VERY OFFENSIVE IN TEXAS. I'M
LISTENING FOR THE LAST OVER
THREE HOURS IT IS MEETING AND
SEEING WHAT KIND O HISTORY THE
BORDERS IN AND HOW YOU CAN'T
GET NURSES OUT INTO THE FIELD
AND GRADUATE THEM BECAUSE YOU
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH INSTRUCTORS
AND- PEOPLE ARGUING OVER
MANNEQUINS WHEN I THINK.
PROBABLY THAT'S A GREAT IDEA
AND IN MANY SITUATIONS MAYBE
NOT ALL. I MEAN I WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE A JOB OF WORK REGISTERED
NURSING TO HELP STRAIGHTEN SOME
OF THIS OUT- I WENT AHEAD AFTER
GIVING UP ON THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING BECAUSE I
HAD BEEN HIT BY A CAR AND I
JUST KIND OF WALKED AWAY. AFTER
NOT GETTING DUE PROCESS READ
MINISTRATIONS MINISTERED OF
HEARING I WENT AND- TURNITIN
MINISTRATION OF JUSTICE DEGREE
OVER OPEN LIKE COLLEGE AND I
HAD YOU KNOW MULTIPLE POLICE
OFFICERS FOR WELL I'D- BETTER
THAN I WOULD BE ABLE TO TELL
THEM. HEY WE HAVE THE NURSE
THAT FALSELY ACCUSE ME. HAD
STOLEN DRUGS FROM THE STATE OF
NEVADA AND UNFORTUNATELY I HATE
TO TELL YOU GUYS THAT I AM
PRETTY SURE THIS NURSE DIED OF
AN OVERDOSE SHE IS WITH NOW AND
IT'S HEARTBREAKING. BECAUSE THE
BOARD LOOKED AWAY. YOU KNOW
THEY JUST WENT AFTER MEDIAN. WE
HAD ANOTHER NURSE CALLING
HIMSELF A DOCTOR. THE MEDICAL
BOARD KNEW ABOUT THIS IN THEIR
LETTER TO ME IS VERY EASILY
OBSERVABLE TO THE PUBLIC ON MY
FACEBOOK PAGE. BECAUSE THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
ACUTE FALSELY ACCUSED ME OF
THAT. I WOULDN'T TELL ME WHAT
IT WAS. THAT'S NOT DUE PROCESS.
LICENSING AND CERTIFICATION NO
BUT ONE OF THE DOCTORS THAT
WOULD- BACKING UP THE FAKE DOC
ONE OF THE NURSES NONE OF THESE
PEOPLE ARE DOCTORS BECAUSE THE
MEDICAL BOARD. ANYONE TO THE
DOCTOR THE NURSE DID NOT LOOK
INTO COURT DR RAY. ACTUALLY
STILL LICENSE TO BOARD A
REGISTERED NURSING HIS NAME IS
REYNALDO. RADIUS WE NEED TO GO
AFTER HIM BECAUSE HE WAS
PUSHING THE TOP OPPOSITE DOCTOR
FOR TEN YEARS. AND I KNOW THAT
FOR A FACT BECAUSE NOW I HAVE
INVESTIGATIVE SKILLS GRADUATED
MY ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE
PROGRAM WITH HONORS. BACK IN
THE DAY IN MY SEGREGATION AT
THE END OF THE STATE. I FOUND
THE SITUATION THAT HAD TO
INVOLVE THE POLICE. NOW THAT
WAS GOING THROUGH PERSONAL
PAPERS OF MINE FOR MANY MANY
YEARS AGO IN JANUARY TO TRY THE
DOWNSIZING TO SMALLER AND
SMALLER DOMICILE. I FOUND A
REALLY SWEET NOTE FROM IRENE
BURN FIVE ONE OF THE FORUM
FIELD OF PSYCH NURSING. AND SHE
WROTE ME SUCH A GREAT THANK YOU
LETTER AFTER YOU KNOW AFTER
SITUATION WHERE WE HAD TO
INVOLVED WITH THE- AND MY
SECRETASE BECAUSE THIS WOMAN
HUSBAND LEVINE OR THE DAILY.
THAT'S SHE WOULD NEED. I SHOULD
HAVE JUST CHANGED MY MAJOR AT
THAT TIME AND NOT HAVE BEEN A
PROBLEM HE GUY THAT PROBABLY
SHOULD HAVE GONE INTO THE STATE
POLICE PLAYING PROGRAMS THAT A
LOT OF COMPLIMENTS FAMILIES BUT
THEY CA ONCE A NURSE ALWAYS A
NURSE YOU CAN PLEASE LOOK AT
WHAT YOU DID TO ME. WHAT.
YOU'RE NOT DOING ABOUT THE
OTHER NURSES. I'M THE ONE THAT
PASSED AWAY HE- BE MY ABOUT.
THE ONE CALLING UNTIL THE
DOCTOR HIS BODY BEGOTTEN WITH
FEDERAL PROBLEM FOR A DANGER IN
A PATIENT. THOSE GUYS YOU CAN
GO LOOK AT. AND I DON'T EVEN
KNOW IF MY TIME IS UP I COULD
TALK TO YOU ALL DAY ALL DAY
LONG ABOUT THIS AND I HAVE
FRIENDS. THERE SHOULD NEVER
SHUT UP ABOUT IT. WELL I'M
TRYING TO BE FLEXIBLE MA'AM-
BUT IF YOU. HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO- WRAP UP WE'RE- YOU'RE FREE
TO SUBMIT- ANYTHING IN WRITING
THAT YOU HAVE PREPARED. NOW OR
WILL PREPARE IN THE FUTURE TOO-
COMMITTEE STAFF AND I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT IT WILL BE.
THOROUGHLY REVIEWED WHEN
RECEIVED. CAN SOMEBODY PLEASE
EMAIL ME AND GIVE ME THE NAME
AND ADDRESS PEOPLE THAT I CAN
TALK TO AND NOT BE KNOWN
THROUGH THE LABYRINTH. MY
ADDRESS MY EMAIL ADDRESS IS
VERY VERY VERY EASY IT EVELYN
DO YOU SWIM. AT G. MAIL .COM
BECAUSE I SWIM A LOT. WE ALSO
IN A LACK THINK WE ALSO HAVE A
COMMITTEE WEBSITE MA'AM THAT
YOU'RE FREE TO ACCESS AND WHILE
I AM NOT CERTAIN THAT YOU CAN.
SEND ITEMS TO US ALL WAIT FOR A
SIGNAL FROM MY COMMITTEE.
CONSULTANT INDICATES YES SO
FEEL FREE TO USE OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL TO. COMMUNICATE
WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF. THE
STAFF DIRECTOR AND MY- CHIEF
CONSULTANT AND- WE WILL. WE
WILL THOROUGHLY REVIEW ANYTHING
THAT YOU SENT TO US WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS- AND YOUR THOUGHTS.
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH FOR
PARTICIPATING. MODERATOR NEXT
PLEASE. ZERO NEXT OVER TWENTY
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
PERFECTLY THANK YOU COULD-
PERFECT- GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS
MICHAEL CRISTINA AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME HERE IN
THE OFFICE TODAY AND ALLOW ME
TO SPEAK MY PIECE ON THE MATTER
REGARDING THE CONTRIBUTORS
TOWARDS THIS NURSING SHORTAGE-
MY FIANCEE SHE'S A REGISTERED
NURSE WHO WAS SENTENCED TO
RIGOROUS TO- RIGOROUS
PROBATIONARY STIPULATIONS IN
THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY. FOUR
OFFENSES SHE COMMITTED NINE
PLUS YEARS AGO MARCHING TOWARD
HOMELESSNESS I WASHER ALL
THROUGHOUT COLLEGE WHILE SHE
PUSHED HERSELF WERE EXCELLENT
GRADES REQUIRED BY THE NURSING
PROGRAM AND I WASHER AGAIN AS
YOU PUSH YOURSELF FURTHER TO
COMPLETE THE RIGOROUS NURSING
PROGRAM AND THEN AGAIN BOSTON
DOOR GARLIC AFTER GAUNTLET AND
POSED BY THE PR AND
PROBATIONARY STIPULATION.
BASICALLY AT THE PROBATIONARY
NURSE I KNOW SHE HAS WORKED TEN
TIMES HARDER THAN OUR PEERS WHO
PRACTICAL THOUGHT THE
PROBATIONARY CHAINS INCURRED BY
THE DVR AND ISSUES TRIPS THAT
TREATED AS INFERIOR- THIRTY ALL
DAY DURING ALL THIS I MADE SURE
TO COVER HER FOR ALL HER TEARS
AND MAKE SURE. TO LET HER KNOW
THAT WOULD ALL GET BETTER. BUT
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT I VERY
TROUBLING WHICH TOOK ME MY CORE
DEFECTS SHAKING NOW. THE
PROBABLY AT NEWSSTAND YOU PUT
IS NEWS ME AT I STARTED
CONNECTING THE- I REACHED
LEARNED ABOUT. BOARD MEMBER
MICHAEL DEANGELO AND FORMER
EXECUTIVE OFFICER JOSEPH MORRIS
ENTERED THE ROOM CONTROVERSY TO
THE FAR OFFENSES. AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT ALLEGATIONS. OF COURSE
THIS IS OLD NEWS BUT IT IS NOT
OLD NEWS TO ME A JOSEPH MORRIS
IS THE ONE WHO HANDED DOWN THE
SENTENCE INTO MY FIANCE. OR HER
OFFENSE RECORD SHE INQUIRED AT
THE LOWEST POINT IN OUR LIFE.
ABSOLUTELY BOGGLES MY MIND HOW
THESE MEN WHO ACTED UNETHICALLY
ARE THE ONES WHO HAVE THE
AUDACITY TO TREAT MY FIANCE
LIKE A CRIMINAL. WHICH THE CBR
AND CONTINUING TO DO TODAY
BASED ON JOSEPH MOORE'S
DECISION. MY QUESTION IS. ARE
THERE ANY PLANS TO REVIEW THE
CASES OF THESE PROBATIONARY
NURSES WHO HAD THEIR DECISION
AND ORDER SIGNED BY JOSEPH
MORRIS. IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE
TO ME THAT MY FIANCE WAS
SENTENCED TO PROBATION FOR
OFFENSES THE HOBBIT NINE PLUS
YEARS AGO. AFTER EXPUNGEMENT OF
A RECORD BY NURSING BOARD WHO
ARE COMMITTING CRIME INSULT.
WHAT ACCURATE AGGRAVATE THE
FURTHER IF THAT THE
PROBATIONARY NURSES ARE HELD TO
A GOD STANDARD WHICH NO OTHER
PERSON THAT THE CORRECT. ME
ESPECIALLY THE BOARD. I
RECENTLY LEARNED ABOUT A
PROBATIONARY NURSE WHO HAD TO
TAKE A URINE TEST AS SHE WAS IN
ACTIVE LABOR WHERE SHE RISK
LOSING HER LIFE THAT SHE DIDN'T
PROVIDE THE URINE SAMPLE
REQUIRED BY THE BOARD. OF
REGISTERED NURSES. AT THE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS OR EVEN AT
THE HUMAN BEING THE TYPE OF
HUMANE TREATMENT IMPOSED BY THE
STATE. IT DOES NOT MAKE SENSE
TO ME I'M JUST WONDERING AS TO
THE DOCTOR THE CATION OF THIS
TREATMENT. I KNOW TODAY'S
MEETING IS IN REGARDS TO A
NURSING SHORTAGE. I MEAN I'M
JUST NOT SUTTER LOOKING AND BUT
I WOULD ADVISE YOU TO LOOK INTO
THE CEDAR AND- FORCE DIVISION
ONE NURSES ARE WAITING TO WORK.
WHAT THE APPLICATIONS CAN TAKE
YEARS TO BE APPROVED. AFTER
BEING APPROVED IT'S VERY HARD
TO FIND A JOB PLACEMENT TO THE-
DUE TO THE SEVERITY OF THE
RESTRICTIONS. I CAN TELL YOU
RIGHT NOW THE NURSES ARE THERE.
IN A LITTLE BAFFLING TO HEAR
ABOUT THE STATE. IS. WORRIED
ABOUT THE NURSING SHORTAGE.
WHEN IT SAME STATE THAT A BAR
TO IGNORE CONTRACT. IN THE LONG.
AND ABOUT A TRACTOR THE DELAYS.
WHICH DISK. POINT OUT. THERE'S
THIS TERRIBLE STICK FIGURE OUT
THERE THAT PROBATIONARY ARE DE
GOODS. WHICH THEY ARE NOT IN
FACT HUNDRED NURSES WHO WORK
PROBATION FOR THAT HAPPENED
BEFORE THE THOUGHT OF. A EVER
RAN THROUGH THERE MIGHT. BUT
DUE TO THE SAID IN PLAY THOSE
NURSES WHO CLOSED PASSED THE-
ARIAN OR SQUAT WITH KOBE. THE
PEOPLE. WHICH MADE THEM
UNDESIRABLE EMPLOYERS BEFORE
THEY EVER HAD THE CHANCE TO
PRACTICE. DESPITE COMPLETELY
PERFORMANCE. FELT BUT BEYOND
STATE. I WOULD CURRENTLY UP TO.
WITH FIRE AFTER KOBE HAD DIED
DOWN. FOR EMPLOYER WOULD
LOOKING FOR ANY REASON THE FIRE
HER THE BIG NO LONGER HAD TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE
FASCICULATIONS REQUIRED BY THE
BOARD. ESPECIALLY THE
OBLIGATION TO GIVE A URINE
SAMPLE DURING WORKING HOURS
WHERE SHE HAD TO WAIT AT THE
COLLECTION SITE AWAY FROM OUR
PATIENTS BUT TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
THE SITUATION OBLIGATION BAKER
BOYER FRUSTRATED ESPECIALLY
DURING THE WHILE NUMBER
SHORTAGE WE ARE ALL AWARE OF.
ANYWAY I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
PROBLEMS WITHIN THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING AND I HOPE
YOU FIND MEN AND WOMEN FIND A
WAY TO COMPLETELY REMOVE THE
TOXICITY. IN THE POCKET THE
EMBEDDED WITHIN THE BOARD THE
FUTURE NURSES OFTEN DOOR THE
UNNECESSARY SUFFERING. I'M
SORRY THAT THE NURSING SHORTAGE
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE
NURSES ARE THERE. BUT THEY
AREN'T ABLE TO WORK TO THE
STIPULATION EFFECTUALLY
STIPULATIONS ONE NINETEEN. I
HOPE YOU ALL FIND THESE NURSES
HELPING FOR THEM. ESPECIALLY
THOSE WITH CONTEMPT. BY YOUR
REPRESENTATIVE JOSEPH MORE.
THANK FOR LISTENING TO I DO NOT.
THANK YOU SIR MUST MODERATE
MEMBERS MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ABOUT HANDLED THE
BEGINNING THE AMERICAN NURSES
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT THE USEOF VALID AND
RELEVANT DATA IN TERMS OF
REGIONAL NEEDS. AND CLINICAL
PLACEMENT AND IN THE OVERALL
NURSING PROGRAMS TROUBLES ARE
MORE OVER REGIONAL SUPPLY AND
DEMAND DATA IS FUNDAMENTAL TO
ASSURING THE CALIFORNIA HAS
WELL PREPARED AND WELL EDUCATED
FUTURE NURSING WORKFORCE THAT
WILL PROVIDE CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE PATIENT CARE. WE
WELCOME B. R. AND NEWLY CREATED
WORKGROUPS FOCUSED ON
COOPERATION WITH NATIONAL
ACCREDITATION AGENCIES. PREVENT
THE BURDENSOME DOUBLING
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM APPROVAL
PROCESSES AND EXPENDITURES.
THIS MUCH NEEDED CHANGE WOULD
FREE NURSING PROGRAMS TO FULLY
FOCUS ON AND INVEST IN
DELIVERING INNOVATIVE NURSING
EDUCATION. FOCUS NOT ONLY ON
ACUTE CARE BUT ALSO ON
COMMUNITY HEALTH SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH AND
HEALTH EQUITY AS RECOMMENDED BY
THE NATIONAL ACADEMY OF
MEDICINE. THANK TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY THIRTY REPORT THAT WAS
PUBLISHED JUST A WEEK AGO. MAY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS CONSIDERED
NURSES MONTH AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO CELEBRATE AND
RECOGNIZE THE SACRIFICES AND
HARD WORK OF ALL NURSING
CALIFORNIA. AND IN THE UNITED
STATES THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR BOTTLE HEARING TODAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
PENNY WISE SMALLER AND
INSTRUCTORS AT THE SCHOOL OF
NURSING AT CAL STATE FULLERTON
HE- I'M HOPING THAT YOU CAN
HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU JUST
FINE JUST A SPEAKER LOUDLY AND
WE WILL BE- WE WILL BE ABLE TO
HEAR YOU. OKAY I'M CALLING JUST
TO- HE SAID THAT AND THE ROLE
OF SIMULATIONS. IT IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CRITICAL
THINKING. FOR OUR NURSING
STUDENTS I PLAN AND LORETTA
MELTING WITH TALKING ABOUT. THE
NUMBER OF HOURS OR- COME OUT
FROM THE NATIONAL BOARD OF
NURSING. I THINK THAT WE STILL
NEED TO LOOK AT THE IMPACT OF.
AN APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN
CLINICAL PLACEMENT THAT IS
AVAILABLE IN SCHOOL. AND
EVALUATE THAT ATED EXPERIENCES
CAN ADD IN TERMS OF- CAN FRIEND
GENE IS THAT ARE NOT READILY
AVAILABLE IN THE CLINICAL
SETTING. SO I JUST WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THAT AND MOVED DOWN
THE PATH IN ANALYZING WHAT IS
NEEDED BY SCHOOLS OF NURSING
AND BY OUR CLINICAL PARTNERS WE
REALIZE THAT. THERE IS A FINITE
CAPACITY FOR CLINICAL PLACEMENT
HOSPITAL CERTAINLY HAD TO
RETRACT THAT DURING. HELLO
THERE THEY HAVE NOT FULLY
REPLACED IT. SOME OF OUR LARGE
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS HAVE BEEN
TOTALLY OFFLINE TO STUDENT SO I
JUST WANT TO ENCOURAGE. BOB
HOPE ROACH SHOULD WHAT COULD
BEST PREPARE OUR STUDENTS
NURSES THE- CARE FALL. DILIGENT
AND CRITICALLY THINKING
PRACTITIONERS FROM A GRADUATE-
AND ARTIFICIAL- NUMBER OF HOURS.
PERCENTAGES SIMULATION ON I
THINK WE NEED TO LOOK VERY
CAREFULLY AT THAT AND PROVIDE
TOOLS OF NURSING WITH THE
CAPACITY TO EDUCATE STUDENTS IN
A WAY THAT THEY ASKED ME
LEARNING OBJECTIVES- YOU
PROPERLY CARE. I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR A VERY INTERESTING
TODAY AND I APPRECIATE. THE
THOUGHT THAT US THE KENNEDY ARE
PUTTING INTO LOOKING AT THIS
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS IN NURSING
EDUCATION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY AND BY THE
WAY THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU AND
YOUR COLLEAGUES TO FOR OUR
REGION. NEXT MODERATOR. THANK
YOU I'M SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I WANTED TO ASK FOR THE
WEBSITE AND FEDERAL. GOVERNMENT
RINKER. MA'AM I'M NOT ABLE TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY COULD YOU
SPEAK SLOWLY A LITTLE LOUDER.
AND MORE CLEARLY PLEASE. YES
THIS IS EVELYN DRINKER AND I'M
CONTINUING I CAN HEAR YOU NOW
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK I WENT
OFTEN FOR DATING WEBSITE I AM
ON THE PHONE THERE'S NOTHING
FOR ME TO SEE ONLINE. WELL
WE'LL HAVE TO- THERE'S A PHONE
NUMBER THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE I BELIEVE
IF YOU WILL DIAL THAT PHONE
NUMBER AND YOU WILL LEAVE YOUR
MESSAGE IN YOUR CONTACT
INFORMATION WE WILL RECONNECT
WITH YOU- AND GIVE YOU THE
INFORMATION AS TO HOW YOU
DELIVER YOUR WRITTEN
PRESENTATION TO US OR ANYTHING
ELSE THAT YOU'D LIKE TO PRESENT.
I'M GREAT WITH THE PHONE NUMBER.
JUST ONE SECOND WELL. OKAY HERE
IT IS. 916-651-4104.
916-651-4104 THAT'S THE SENATE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE-
PHONE NUMBER LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM YOU. OKAY TO
CONFIRM. 916-651-5410 THAT'S
CORRECT. AND WHO WOULD I ASK
FOR WELL IF YOU'LL JUST LEAVE
YOUR NAME AND NUMBER WE WILL
GET BACK TO YOU. ONLY YOUR
NAME. MY NAME IS RICHARD ROTH
I'M THE SENATOR AND I'M NOT
SURE OF THE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
CONDUCTING THIS HEARING. OKAY
IS THAT WHAT R. U. T. H. R. R.
FOR WATERS IN R. O. FF. THROWS
ROMEO OSCAR TANGO HOTEL R. O.
T. H. WONDERFUL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE CALL.
THANK YOU I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
PERFECT THANK YOU- MATTER
MODERATOR WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
THANK SURE LOW IN THE MEMBERS
OF OUR RESPECTIVE COMMITTEES.
LIKE TO THANK MS MELVIN THE
BOARD MEMBERS AND OUR OTHER
WITNESSES FOR THEIR OUTSTANDING
TESTIMONY TODAY ALSO LIKE TO
THANK MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
FOR PARTICIPATING THOSE THE
DEAD AND WEIGHING IN ON THESE
VERY VERY IMPORTANT PROCEEDINGS.
IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELEPHONE CONFERENCE
SERVICE TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING. TO THE SENATE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE OR THE
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE OR IN THE
ALTERNATIVE VISIT OUR WEBSITE
AS YOU HAVE JUST HEARD ME
DISCUSS. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. WE DO
APPRECIATE. YOUR PARTICIPATION
IN YOUR CURRENT YOUR CONTINUED
INTEREST AND INVOLVEMENT. IN
THESE VERY CRITICAL ISSUES. WE
HAVE NOW CONCLUDED THE AGENDA
FOR THE HEARING TODAY THE JOINT
SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT HEARING.
FOR TODAY IS A JERK.